welcome to Commerce Committee we're
going to start on time here
and we'll start with the introduction
of house bill 172.
apparently
these are all support
uh good morning Mr chair good morning to
the members of the Commerce Committee uh
I'm representative Jess Edwards from
Rockingham uh District 31 representing
um my my my town of Auburn Candia
Chester and Deerfield I'm here today to
introduce house bill 172.
um now to my right is a representative
leishman we both have a finance
committee starting right about now so I
don't think we're going to talk for long
but you have some really great people in
the in the audience today who can
amplify this
um so I'd like to
I'd like to go and point out that uh it
it it is the goal of the New Hampshire
legislature and and the executive branch
to assist with
um assist with trying to make sure that
uh prescription drugs can be made
available to the market affordably and
it's so much of an objective that we've
already implemented several programs
both at the federal and state level
this is the latest of multiple attempts
to try to do the same thing and so I'm
not here to dissuade you from the
objective of trying to do what we can to
assist with affordability I'm really
here to say that this legislation was
created
um
in a way in which the house did not hear
it normally so there was no house uh
hearing on it or testimony back when the
bill was originally passed the way it
got passed was through uh what was
called the Christmas tree or an Omnibus
Bill
and it didn't get the respect it
deserved and I think in our haste to do
it we took a some model legislation that
has been implemented by Maine and other
states I think representative leishman
or somebody is going to testify to who
else has been trying this but the
results no no one's no one doing this is
producing results and and so I'm just
generally a guy who wants
government if it's going to do something
important
to do it well and not to be redundant
and not to be wasteful and in this case
the the affordability board is on the
precipice of issuing tax levies
upwards to about six hundred and fifty
thousand dollars to the Pharma industry
various players in the Pharma industry
and I I know that the members of the
board
do not view this as a tax levy and so
when I say tax levy it's it's probably a
bit offensive to some people who see
this as a fee
I think it's a tax levy because
um our fees are intended to provide some
governmental benefit to the people who
pay the fee like a marriage license fee
for example this this is a
a tax on the farm industry so that we
can make them give us data that we may
already be getting so that we can do
some data analysis that's already
possible to produce a report that we
don't really know exactly what's going
to be done with it and so so to me what
this bill does is just say let's time
out let's look before we leap
um
by looking we're we're asking to
investigate the status quo and what this
board does
we'd like the department of
administrative Services the insurance
department and DHHS to look for
potential redundancies that's on line 15
and 16 of page one
we already know that the department of
administrative Services reverse auctions
in this area and Mr arlinghaus has told
me in public hearing that he thinks that
that's successful and is accomplishing
much of what was intended by this bill
we we are and that's in statute we
already know that at the state and
federal level we have things like the
New Hampshire Comprehensive Health
Information System and we also have the
federal Consolidated Appropriations Act
all intended to solve the same problem
in this same space in different ways and
this this program did not really get uh
integrated or smoothed with those others
um that investigative report would be a
due by one November 23
simultaneously and in parallel we're
asking HHS oversight committee which is
a joint committee of the of the
legislature to uh to to begin looking
into this as well with some very
specific items those are on page two
from line five to Eighteen with the
final report date of the November 1st of
and until we can do all of that we're
saying let's take a time out let's
suspend operations under this bill this
is not a repeal of the bill this is a
time out so that we can look before we
leap again we're on the verge of issuing
new tax bills for 650 000 and uh and I
don't even know that most legislature
legislators appreciate that we've got a
650 000 new tax in a Hang Fire situation
that I'd like to stop
one other small thing just that just is
was a little irritating and reviewing
all of this is that of all of our
prescription drugs 46 percent of those
drugs are are done through special
prescriptions which are or managed and
created in a in a hospital uh
environment and don't come through the
national Pharma companies directly and
that's 40 46 percent of New Hampshire's
drug costs yet this board was not going
to look at them uh instead they were
going to focus on things like the
prescription drug or the prescription
benefit managers there seemed to be an
inherent bias to not look at the entire
problem but to miss 46 percent of it I I
think they've since figured fixed that
but I'm still worried that they're going
to blend this white bag approach that's
meant to be competitive with the
hospital system costs so we'll never
really see what the right policy is and
providing those special prescriptions
and and so so in in an area that seems
to me to be apparently a place where we
have to worry about affordability I'm
just not sure that we're going to get
any actionable information and
um I I can take questions but Mr chair
I'd recommend letting representative
leishman do his intro and then the
committee if they have questions were
both available
okay yes
please representative Leachman
thanks Mr chairman and members of the
Commerce Committee for the record my
name is Peter leishman I represent
Peterborough and Sharon Hillsborough 33.
you know it's nice to follow
representative Edwards because he
covered just about everything that you
should know so uh I'm certainly here to
address any questions you may have but
also to point out some of my concerns
that representative Edwards did not
bring up but they have a position as uh
for an executive director and the cost
of that position is about 166
000 with a an assistant an
administrative assistant that they have
budgeted 75 000 for
uh if you look at some of our pay scales
for even assistant commissioners of this
state such as the insurance
commissioner's Deputy I think he's uh
getting somewhere in the neighborhood of
a hundred and twenty thousand dollars
and has the oversight of dozens and
dozens of individuals so there's a cost
element here there's a transparency
matter here as far as I'm concerned and
representative Edwards as representative
Edwards pointed out
this didn't receive its normal review by
the finance committee specifically
division three it did not receive any
review from the ways and means
committees as far as the establishment
of fees so I think is again
representative Edgewood stated we need
to take a step back and take a hard look
at this board before we go further
thanks Mr chairman
if I could just uh add to my earlier
comment
um that this is my reasonable Bill uh
the other bill that I think is coming to
Commerce uh recommends just killing this
board outright uh the point of this bill
is uh let's talk because I know there
are Advocates of the program and I I
hope those who are advocating for the
program will will do a reasonable thing
and just take the time to talk about it
and work through it to make sure that
whatever we end up doing it's it's it's
reasonable and integrated with existing
efforts
thank you
all right we'll open up uh questions
from the committee
thank you
um representative can you tell us why
um uh the bill proposes to spend suspend
certain Authority this is um section
four at the very end why the bill
proposes to suspend certain Authority uh
while the review was going on
I I think that's a good question I think
uh representative leishman uh hit on on
the on the main wise pretty pretty well
where uh they're on the precipice of
hiring uh an expensive executive
director and an exec an expensive
assistant to the executive director and
uh that we're going to have to establish
you know additional Manpower in the
system
um so so I would like to suspend it so
that we don't go with those hires
because at this point without the
program being clear it's not clear that
we what we would be asking of these
quarter million dollar total employees
so so there's that and then they are so
close in the jail car process that
within a month or two they're getting
ready to issue tax levies uh on an order
of six hundred and fifty thousand
dollars to the Pharma industry and and
and I think uh what we're trying to do
is trying to make sure that before we
tax somebody we know what we're doing we
know how it's going to be used we're
convinced it's a good purpose and that
it's efficient
further inquiry
follow thank you uh
could you tell us a little bit more
about the proposed tax where you said it
earlier it might be considered a fee can
you explain
what that is proposed for and how it's
proposed to work
yes I can thank you for the question
um
what the existing law provides for is
that once the the the the the board's
budget is approved and I'm still trying
to figure out exactly how that's done
I'm assuming it's going to be part of
the governor's budget process I hope
it's part of the governor's budget
process but once that budget gets
approved they have the authority to
Levy
fees taxes of 125 percent of that budget
and what what I understand at this point
is that they have a five hundred
thousand dollar proposed budget that
they'd like and and 125 percent of that
would be six hundred and fifty thousand
dollars
uh excuse me further inquiry further
inquiry thank you
um but what are they proposing to
Levy that you say they're proposing to
Levy that fee on the Pharma industry but
what for
you want to take them
thanks for your question uh they have
put forward a proposal their proposed
budget and they would be assessing a fee
of 700 dollars per
manufacturer that's uh there are 442
identified manufacturers that they have
identified the bill the 700 to then
there's a 164
um
Distributors that they would send bills
to
also additional pharmacies 37 so a total
income of almost six hundred thousand
dollars that they would just they would
send out a bill and if you go to their
website they've actually got a proposal
as far as the invoicing for that bill
which would be assessed every year on
identified manufacturers and
Distributors of pharmaceutical products
and sorry further inquiry okay last one
thank you thank you
uh so do I understand correctly that
these fees then would be to fund the
board's operation rather than funding it
through the general fund that's correct
thank you
thank you any other questions from the
committee
representative purcelli
so has thank you good morning thank you
um has this board been formed and are
any recommendations
forthcoming is there a mission statement
an objective or is this just under
consideration to get started when the
Personnel are hired yeah thanks for the
question yeah the board has been formed
as representative Edwards pointed out it
was formed more than a year ago when
they've been trying to get themselves
organized what brought it to our
attention both the representative
Edwards and I serve on the joint
legislative fiscal committee and they
came before the fiscal committee last
year looking for an appropriation or for
us to give them money to establish
themselves and to pay for an executive
director and an administrative assistant
we started digging further into this
after the request we tabled their
request and that's when we decided this
needs a little more oversight and
scrutiny so that's where that it all
came from
just to clarify no recommendations have
come out of this because there is not a
staff
formed yet correct I think they they've
probably done some recommendations on
their owns but I have not specifically
seen them okay thank you to expand on
that a little bit
um so so this board has been constituted
the board has some members from the
legislature that have been appointed
into other uh civilians in the industry
and they've been meeting and they've uh
and and I know the leader of that
representative Merchant I'm sure he's
going to testify I know he's been
working very very hard to accomplish the
purpose of of the board but he's had to
jump through some hurdles he's had to
get ready for gel car for example and so
they've made recommendations to gel car
gel car has responded they've come back
to address jail car concerns and so so
they are actively working but they're
doing it with you know part-time
legislators and others and so what
they're looking to do is to mature to
the next level people to get an
executive director and assistant so that
they can you know worry the problem on
an ongoing basis
okay thank you any any more questions
okay representative Herbert please
um
I just want to I've been here what eight
years and and I've never suspended a
bill that has already been passed
so it this is news to me I didn't know
we had the
we could do that
number one
and would you believe
if you haven't given them any money
it's unreasonable to
expect them to offer you recommendations
that are well thought out
uh in the beginning so it's you
it's to me it's like a a circular
argument about well I don't want to fund
this so therefore and I'm not getting
the recommendations and I'm thinking
well of course you haven't but it's
legislation that we passed
so I I'm uh I'm I'm a little confused
about our what we're actually doing here
so
so let's let's just assume for the sake
of argument that everyone agrees with
the purpose of the board the board wants
to make drugs affordable all right uh
the the the the the the issue is not
whether or not they should spend money
the issue is whether or not they should
waste money and do things that are
redundant and basically are not moving
us towards the objective and that's the
concern and so the legislature has the
power to repeal which is my other bill
just repeal it outright so certainly the
legislature has the power to call a
timeout and hold it in advance uh the
the statute until we have an opportunity
to have the legislative legislature do
its duty to ensure that this is not a
wasteful redundant program and that it's
set up for success and and and not just
to spin wheels did you have one more
okay go ahead
yeah perhaps as was mentioned earlier if
the process had gone through the normal
review like by the Ways and Means
Committee as far as fees and the expense
side of it through the finance committee
we wouldn't be here but because it kind
of went through a different process uh
that's I think why we're here and
looking for a little pullback to get a
better handle on what the board is
supposed to do and again there isn't
redundancy between the department of
administrative services and the
insurance department
so I just want to get it straight so one
bill you want to be repealed entirely
is and and that passed as well no you
you haven't heard that bill yet I think
it's coming up in Commerce in a I don't
know your next hearing or two okay so
and that one you want to kill
I I'm I'm trying to have a conversation
with with your committee I I I could
easily be convinced to just repeal the
entire thing and start fresh and use the
normal legislative process to figure out
what we're going to do I I could do that
this is my this is our attempt I think
to to to have a reasonable conversation
without the repeal this is this is the
less uh aggressive approach to to make
sure that we're doing the right thing
for taxpayers
representative uh remind me how to
pronounce your name I'm sorry
Julio representative
given that prescription drug prices is a
long-standing problem throughout
American politics what do you think is a
reasonable time frame in which to see
drug prices come down with a board such
as this
get Rudy um okay so
um what I think uh we we want to go back
to is that already under statute of the
Department of administrative Services is
conducting reverse options on
Pharmaceuticals and I wish Mr arlinghaus
hopefully somebody from that department
is in here I I've I've heard reported
some success in controlling price
increases through that reverse auction
process I'm not prepared to brief it for
them but but I've heard success is there
also uh in statute we're collecting a
lot of this data already uh in the
Comprehensive Health Information System
and so so the data is is there and could
be accessed to answer questions that we
may have and federally there's already
in statute Federal Consolidated
Appropriations Act of 2021 and so the
efforts legislatively have already begun
to shorten the timeline to when we think
we're going to see positive results
again the this board
is probably redundant my instinct says
this is redundant and let's look at it
so so even we accept the goal the same
goal we want to reduce drug prices
rapidly
I'm not convinced this is this board is
the right way to go YouTube Follow did
you have a follow-up
I do have a follow-up to return to the
question that I actually asked what is
the time frame in which you would expect
to see drug prices reduced with a board
such as this
uh I would turn your attention to this
report that was issued by the New
Hampshire insurance department uh back
in 2021 and they looked at an 85-page
report and there's actually been a
decline in a number of drug price
drivers the thing that's really pushing
things up right now are the specialty
drugs that are very expensive and often
insurance companies don't cover but
there's as you probably well know on the
federal level
this movement right now as far as
lowering prescription drug costs is some
question whether the states even have
the authority to go down that road since
the federal government is already doing
it so I think all of us would agree that
drug prices need to come down and the
whole idea of this board was a good idea
but again there seems to be a lot of
redundancy in what we're trying to do
when we're already having it done and
the review of drug prices by the
department of administrative services
and the insurance department
okay seeing no further questions thank
you and um I guess you can get back to
finance for a little while
next up
next up we'll call uh Jen Delay from
AARP New Hampshire
and uh it says time needed to speak 30
seconds but we'll give you a little more
than that
turn your microphone on just red means
good yep sorry about that uh good
morning committee members uh thank you
for allowing me the opportunity to
testify in opposition of s of HB 172 my
name is Jen Delaney I'm the associate
state director for advocacy for AARP New
Hampshire
um
I put 30 seconds down because uh
chairman Merchant who is the uh
representative Merchant who is the chair
of the prescription drug affordability
board is here as well as Dr Sherman who
is also on the prescription drug
affordability board
um they have been working
um
on the fiscal piece and can get into
great detail on that with you and answer
all of your questions
um I also uh wanted to just mention that
in the 2022 session there were two
additional uh pieces of legislation on
the prescription drug afforded
affordability board
um it was uh one bill was voted on in
the executive departments and
administrative
committee that was sent to interim study
additionally there was SB 450 which went
uh which passed the uh Senate with a
unanimous Voice vote and then also
um was voted on on the house floor
um that was a bill that actually
strengthened the prescription drug
affordability board and would allow it
to carry out its duties
um and so uh from what we have seen
this bill has been looked at ins in
committee and has been voted on on the
floor the prescription drug
affordability board it also was signed
into law in 2020 by the governor with
bipartisan support
um and AARP is in strong opposition to
anything that would inhibit the
prescription drug affordability board in
uh continuing on their work
um uh and it is very important I mean
people across 85 percent of granite
Staters say that uh the cost of
prescription drugs is one of the most
important things to them
um and anything well we're all for
um government transparency and avoiding
redundancy we've we believe that the
prescription drug affordability board
will bring that much needed transparency
and help Granite Staters and also help
the state of New Hampshire
um you know save funds
um in you know paying exorbitant costs
for prescription drugs for the public
payers
um thank you very much
any questions thank you any questions
from the committee
yes please
thank you
uh you you heard the previous testimony
and the claim of redundancy so in in
your opposition uh aarp's opposition to
this bill
um how does redundancy factor into your
decision-making process do you recognize
it or do you believe that it is uh not a
real issue sure so um when uh the bill
was enacted
um from I was not a lobbyist for AARP at
that point but from what I understand it
was put into place because
um despite best efforts of uh the
insurance New Hampshire Insurance
Association and
um and other state agencies in bringing
down the cost of prescription drugs
um due to lack of funding and lack of
Staffing they weren't able to do that
job do that effectively and so that is
one of the reasons the board was brought
into existence
okay thank you representative Terry any
other questions
all right seeing none thank you very
much thank you
so next we'll call Donald funstein from
a hip and he's in support of the bill
and asked for five minutes to speak
thank you Mr chairman just please turn
your mic on thank you sorry thank you Mr
chairman my name is Donald funstein I am
a lawyer at the Gallagher office with me
today is my boss Heidi Kroll who is the
primary lobbyist for a hip we have been
very involved in the operation of this
prescription drug board and I'm going to
try to touch upon the questions that
each of your members who asked one asked
usually people can hear me there we go
there's a audience on YouTube during the
21st century I just want to make sure my
mother's volume is okay I couldn't you
get that now here we
um this bill
was passed two and a half years ago it
took effect
two and a half years ago
there are only two states in the nation
that have tried this spending Target
experiment
the state of Maine
established this law in 2019 I believe
June 23rd is the effective date
the New Hampshire bill is identical
to the language that was in Maine it was
adopted as the representatives before me
explained as a result during the covid
emergency
so as a result of the emergency and not
due to anybody's mischief's Behavior
the bill never had a hearing in the
house
this is
an experiment that Maine thought might
work for Maine and Maine you may know
has an income tax the relationship
between the state and the municipalities
is different than a relationship between
the state and the municipalities here in
New Hampshire that's one fundamental
difference
the experiment in Maine is three and a
half years old
to pick up on some of Representatives
filio's questions
recommend what has the state of Maine
done in three and a half years
I looked at the minutes for the last 10
meetings
over three and a half years
they
in the fourth quarter or 2022 we're
still discussing what their law does
they created it we copied it the
principal component of the bill is the
establishment of spending targets
for prescription drugs purchased by
public payers
they're still debating
what that language means
the only recommendation that Maine has
come up with in three and a half years
is they think now it might be a good
idea to look at some type of reverse PBM
auction
well New Hampshire as you've heard from
representative Edwards has already
successfully using that mechanism
which is like the board incorporated
into our statutes
in fact I believe it was the same
Omnibus Bill but I may be wrong about
that
so with three and a half years in Maine
two and a half years in New Hampshire
with our
adaptation of the main experience and
we're all in on representative Edwards
and leishman's Bill
because it's time now to do it the New
Hampshire way
and I'd like to point out a few
observations
that we believe firmly support
the reason why you should stop and take
a look at what's going on
the spending Target methodology
that we are still debating two and a
half years down the road
and meaning in October 10th
2022 of this board
one hour in 18 minutes into the meeting
as it is recorded
the prime sponsor of the legislation
in a good natured way
makes a joke about who filed this bill
when reading
the spending Target methodology
which was an obvious acknowledgment of
you know what does it mean
yet at the very next meeting
at which the board undertook a
substantive review of issues as opposed
to Simply voting on the latest iteration
of their Communications with gel car on
administrative rules
they rolled out a budget
that now I can respond to representative
Gibbs
that is representative Edwards says once
the tax the prescription drug channels
for over half a million dollars
they want to spend a quarter of a
million dollars on an executive director
and an assistant
when the meeting before
this conversation
they acknowledge that the principal
component of their bill
the spending Target methodology one
member wanted to know whether it was a
methodology and suggested it shouldn't
be the primary response left and wanted
to know who filed the bill which of
course he did and it was a good natured
thing I don't mean to criticize
individuals it was all done in this
covert pandemic but what's let's let's
put the brakes on let's take a look
so what do they want to do with the rest
of the money
one of the members of the board
is a professor
and he spent the meeting talking about
spending a hundred thousand dollars of
the budget they want to raise
by hiring his employer
to look at Dater
and to tell them what their
responsibility is
for fifty thousand dollars develop a
methodology to set spending targets
now if the member had been
associated with Southern New Hampshire
University
would we now be looking at the data
once from Southern New Hampshire
University I don't know
I don't I didn't see any proposals I
don't know if there was an RFP I don't
know if anybody talked to anybody
now what really is astonishing
when you look at that is the fact that
New Hampshire has on its state employee
payroll
a PhD Healthcare data professional
that's actually been following the
developments here
New Hampshire has getting to
representative Terry's comments
questions concerning do you see
redundancy
New Hampshire has the professional staff
that people want to contract for in tax
for or impose assessments is the way the
language reads
we have the data system New Hampshire
has the all pairs
Health Care claim data system the
prescription drug claims under both
the pharmacy benefit and the medical
benefit the latter of which includes the
real expensive drugs that representative
Leachman was referring to the specialty
farmer drugs we have all that data it's
already being collected we have
professionals that can analyze it
those are just two redundancies there
are others so these are just examples of
what why we think it makes a lot of
sense to slow down and take a look at
what's going on and let's stop
trying to adapt
the experiment in Maine which if you
read the minutes three and a half years
out pretty well has failed and let's
look at the New Hampshire way thank you
very much
for your patience and I'm happy to
answer any questions if you have
you want to speak I guess I'm just going
to add um I wanted to also just be clear
that From ahib's perspective we very
much support lowering prescription drugs
and making them affordable for New
Hampshire consumers whether it's
individuals businesses paying the
premiums or state payers
um paying for the drugs and the premiums
our our hope is that we can do that
efficiently and effectively
um
and in a timely way as well so I just
wanted to to mention that the other
thing I was going to mention
um Mr funstein mentioned that the kind
of central focus of this board is to
come up with spending targets
um and I'll just read for you what what
the the law says
the board shall determine annual
spending targets for prescription drugs
purchased by public payers based upon a
10-year rolling average
of the medical care services component
of the United States Department of Labor
Bureau of Labor Statistics Consumer
Price Index Medical Care Services index
plus a reasonable percentage for
inflation and minus a spending Target
for pharmacy savings as determined by
the board
so far no one has been able to figure
out what that means it sounds like
there's a CPI plus another
um
inflation Factor on top of it so
first of all we're trying to figure out
what that even means and other states
haven't figured it out either the other
question is even if we do by some
um
happy happenstance figure out how to do
that you know the question is are we
coming up with spending targets for each
prescription drug are we coming up for
spending targets for each prescription
drug for each public payer which is the
state 10 counties and 200 and some odd
municipalities and even if we're able to
deliver spending targets to the public
payers are they going to be able to do
anything with those given that many of
them have contracts with unions that
or you know it's hard to um adjust uh
health insurance benefits
um when you have a Union contract so I
just wanted to be very clear that we
very much support the goal as others
have said
um but we just want to make sure that
we're not spinning our Wheels as other
states have and make sure that we can
figure out actually how to move forward
we're all for transparency around drug
pricing and in fact greater transparency
we do think could help put some pressure
some downward pressure on pricing so
we're very much in support of
transparency but we think we can you
know there's already other entities
working on transparency both at the
federal and state level
um
so I just wanted to make those points
thank you
thank you any questions from the
committee
oh represent Gibbs
thank you Mr chairman
um apparently up to this point uh we
have provided neither funding nor staff
to the board considering that
would you be open to the idea that it's
better to give the board a chance to
obtain the funding and hire staff and we
could we could discuss what the
reasonable
um uh salary level uh I don't think that
that's necessarily controlling
um but give it a chance to obtain some
funding and hire some staff that would
actually allow it to do the work
um that the statute proposes for it to
do before we decide that it's impossible
uh for it to do this work
this would be sure what else it would be
I I don't think it's a good investment
uh particularly after
a acknowledgment
that the primary principle
of the law
is in my words anyways nonsensical it
needs to be redone
um
if if
I don't know anyone that successfully
can run a business
that will raise capital
for something
they have no idea what they're going to
do with it
here we have a spending plan
but but we have no no app no business
plan the fundamental component of the
existing war is the spending Target
methodology nobody knows what it means
the people that wrote it originally
three and a half years ago don't know
what it means
and that's why at the meeting of October
10th
you know the prime sponsor basically
said to representative Edwards who was
in the audience
you know I guess we're going to have to
go to the legislature
I would just in in addition to that
response I would say that you know as
you've heard hopefully from us in the
prior testimony
um we do think that a lot of this work
either is already be done or could be
done within the department of
administrative Services the New
Hampshire insurance department and HHS
and so I think it would be reasonable to
see what is already being done there and
that's already built into those agencies
budgets now maybe there needs to be some
enhancement
um
but would it you know would the
enhancements need to be you know north
of a half a million dollars I don't know
um but again I I do think uh the other
piece of it is this idea of a spending
Target is just
kind of impossible to wrap your head
around
um originally it came from there was
model legislation it was not a spending
Target it was price setting and even
Maine recognized that they couldn't get
away with price setting so they turned
it into a spending Target
um but it the language really even if
you hire my point is even if you give
the money allow the board to assess fees
and collect money and hire an executive
director and Staffing
um I'm not sure that the executive
director and the staff are going to have
any easier of a time understanding what
this means and even if they could figure
out what it means and they do come up
with spending targets to my other point
I don't know what the public payers are
supposed to do with those spending
targets
thank you
great oh representative Philip
if the issue here then is we have an
indecipherable statute and to be clear
the work of lawyers administrators and
judges is to decipher indecipherable
statutes
when it's an equal fix to just be for
the legislature to make this statute
clearer rather than to throw out the
board
no
I mean if Maine created the statute
three and a half years ago and they're
still debating what it means and haven't
done anything in three and a half years
why would you try to build as I said
in one of our the meeting of October
10th
why would you build a house on a
foundation of crushed eggs
are too expensive right now
great thank you very much
uh chair will call on Tom Sherman
who is in opposition to the bill
and I bet you you were in the room when
this bill was passed
and Gary merchant do you want to speak
first sure is it is it okay yeah oh
that's fine I didn't know were you guys
going to be tag team but that's great
okay you're on
thank you Mr chairman thank you for the
committee
for the record my name is Gary Merchant
representing Sullivan County district 6
which is Claremont Croydon I also chair
the prescription drug affordability
board which seems to be a Hot Topic this
morning
before I get into trying to explain the
board
is trying to help people understand and
you can relate to this because you had a
previous bill you heard from the setting
a Mac price
and how challenging it is for a retail
pharmacy
to even find the data
that's only a tip of the iceberg
when you start looking at the pharmacy
market and how prices are set
this is how complex it is how
convoluted it is it's not
straightforward
and part of that is because it lacks
transparency
the reason why it lacks transparency
because most people in the pharmacy
supply chain benefit from
the lack of transparency
they will fight any effort to bring
transparency to Marketplace
now a couple of things were said this
morning I'd like to clarify or at least
counter
one regards to the executive director
the 165 thousand dollars is fully loaded
the actual salary is 118.
and has to be said by
The Joint Commission an employee
compensation so we don't actually know
where it's going to be said
that committee
through its Consultants will set it
appropriately depending upon the market
the other
35 to 40 000 is called benefits
but we pay in Social Security will we
pay in health care dental benefits Etc
et cetera et cetera
the same thing with the administrative
assistant
it's only a level two folks
get somebody to help with the paperwork
to make sure the office is running
accordingly
in regards to
specialty drugs we did listen to that
initially we wanted to focus our
attention on
the drugs in the pharmacy benefit
Channel because the data was more robust
and was rich
but after listening to
the public
we recognize that specialist drugs
according to the insurance department
was elect was a Lion's Share not Lion
Share but a large part of it and we
needed to include it and the board
changed
it changes direction we listened and we
responded
as far as transparency
every single meeting we have is open to
the public it's recorded all of you can
go online and listen to it
it's virtual you don't even have to be
there in person we wanted it to be
totally transparent
all the minutes
all the documentation by law
have to be published seven days before
the meeting occurs can you think of your
town or anyone else that's required
I wish I could say it was my mother but
it's not
in we are required by law by the statue
itself to post all the documents that we
share
publicly
seven days before we actually review
them at the board level that's how much
we take transparency it's hard to hold
other people accountable to transparency
if you're not transparent yourself
in regards to levies on pharmacies
there's no levies on pharmacies
there's levees on pbms like Caremark
Cigna
United
the three big ones
by the way the insurance or the
pharmaceutical Market the United States
is over 500 million dollars they have
the billion dollars
that's how much as a society we spend
back to the issue of not having
reports to share with you folks we have
two annual reports they are available on
the website if you want I'll be more
than glad to send them to you
we've struggled because of lack of
funding
we don't have the resources to
accomplish what the law was set out to
do we have been struggling through this
whole process
trying to get the board up and running
including through gel car getting the
rules written
it's a long process without having
appropriate staff and relying upon
the good nature of volunteers
none of this work would have
accomplished
with regards to the insurance department
they do provide an annual report
it tells us
what happened it doesn't tell us why
the key to it is trying to understand
why why are drugs going up not just
reporting the fact that they went up we
all know that every time you go to the
pharmacy you know that
but why is it going up
where's the money being made in the
pharmacy supply chain who's making the
money
the last report that came out of Pharma
get all this
Pharma used to have approximately 80
percent of the profit or the dollar it
was collected
in 2021 it was less than 50 50 cents on
a dollar
so if they're not making the money who's
making it
should we find out
we're talking about hard earned taxpayer
dollars this is in the public domain
this is not in private
we as legislators are responsible on how
we spend taxpayer dollars should we not
try to figure out and solve the problem
to use those monies wisely and
appropriately
in regards to
Maine
I talked to Noah I can't think it was Dr
Noah
they're wrestling with the same thing
states have passed similar legislation
and they struggle because a lot of times
they're not staffed with funding
the comment about Dr Woodward being a
retired UNH Professor he is
he's very proud of it I think we should
too he's from our State University
flagship
do you realize that UNH has a contract
with the Department of Health and Human
Services to do analysis
all he was saying was to build off from
that contract why create another one
we already have one why not utilize it
in regards to Dr Jason ezzy he is
with the insurance department he does
have a PhD
he also has a full-time job
I think he has a full-time job assuming
that's why they hired him
so if he has a full-time job how is he
going to do the role we're talking about
here
that we're tasked with
so in closing looking at things with you
folks the primary goal of the board is
to try to begin to unravel and provide
more transparency to the marketplace
we need a competitive Marketplace
lacking competition
prices don't go down
so the question we need to do in this
legislative body and through the board
is to understand why
it's the why so all we're asking for is
don't repeal the board don't put it on
ice
if you're looking for your Dynasty I
don't think there's redundancy because
no other
entity in the state is tasked with what
we're tasked with
so that's my my comments for you folks
today
um
in regards to
any other thing as far as another confu
another confusion the board does not
regulate Price Books it does not it
cannot
federally it cannot
it's a red flag
what the board can try to do is help
people understand
when they're spending more money on
drugs than they should
and then for them to ask the question
why we need to find a way to educate
people on how this thing works so thank
you
thank you Senator Sherman would you like
to speak um thank you
um for the record my name is Tom Sherman
I am speaking today as a private public
citizen but I also serve on the board as
a member and um
all personal comments from the ahip
representative aside I am the prime
sponsor of the bill and I do have a
sense of humor and it's nice to see it
used against me and in public forum but
uh I don't take it personally Mr
Feinstein
um
uh so
I'm here though really to talk about the
board and this bill
um
this bill puts the board on ice for a
year
um and
there are several reasons for that but
going back to where this bill came from
uh as state senator representing
District 24. I was Prime sponsor of SB
687 uh in 2020. this was introduced and
heard in the senate in January of 2020
before the covid crisis hit New
Hampshire
and due to the pandemic after clearing
the Senate it was incorporated as one of
several prescription
related or Pharmacy related bills
including the reverse auction bill which
I was a co-sponsor of
into HB 1280 as an amendment
um
the bill made changes in the statute uh
I'm sorry
we also last session introduced SB 450
and I was Prime sponsor of that bill
SB 450 was in response to the initial
meetings of the board and recognizing
that there were several areas that
needed to be upgraded or amended or
changed and how the board was structured
um
and also how
how we limited fees
how we limited our budget these were all
brought forward by people like
representative leishman by ahip by
others and we were trying to respond to
that and adjust the board accordingly
because we thought there was Merit to
all of that
SB 450 did have a house hearing
it had a senate hearing it passed both
Chambers and was signed into law by the
governor so the notion that this board
has never had a full Hearing in the
house is just false patently
and the house and the Senate
moved it forward with SB 450.
um
[Music]
so SB I'm sorry HB 172
has been introduced
and I don't believe the findings that
are listed in the bill are supported by
fact
the New Hampshire drug affordability
board prescription drug affordability
board which we call pdab
uh without the benefit of full
legislative review I just addressed that
it has had subsequent hearings in the
house on at least two occasions uh and
the house went ahead and moved the pdab
forward
the second finding was that recognized
that there were a high costs of
prescription drugs
but uh said that this was identical to
the main law
it wasn't identical to the main law it
was adapted to as was previously stated
the New Hampshire way as best as I and
others the AARP new Futures and other
supporters
knew to do
but
it has been further modified just like
was suggested right here in today's
discussion and it will continue to be
modified
the overarching goal here is to
understand the prescription drug Market
as it impacts State cost
and to do everything we possibly can to
identify strategies for lowering that
cost that
not the sentence that Mr fundstein
brought forward is the principal goal of
this and if we need to change which is
where my quip came from if we need to
change how we do that
we have legislative oversight we have
several legislators on board we have
already come back to the legislature for
modifications and we can certainly do
that if we need to
and as an aside the idea that
UNH currently has a contract that
provides much of the data we need
that we shouldn't go ahead and utilize
that but we should use a different
entity that would require
completely new contract is redundant and
we're trying to avoid that redundancy
finding number three
we created redundancies
honestly there is no entity in the state
of New Hampshire right now that does
what pdab is trying to do
we are trying to make sure we fully
understand the drug market and provide
strategies for lowering costs for the
taxpayers of the State of New Hampshire
that does not exist
but there are people in different
positions including Jason and including
in Department of administrative services
and Department of Health and Human
Services and UNH and Dartmouth that
actually have resources that the board
can tap into to achieve its goal
and that's the role of the goal of the
board
we've spent the last two and a half
years
really and my hats off to representative
Merchant he's done a phenomenal job we
are leading the effort in the country on
this and it is no surprise that the
people who are asked to pay fees and the
people who might feel threatened by the
existence of the board would come before
you and try to kill it
but we're here to serve the people of
New Hampshire
we're here to provide that transparency
that currently does not exist
and for which there is no mechanism to
do so in spite of what this bill claims
section two and three of the bill
require unnecessary and burdensome
investigation I thought our goal is to
decrease the work of the government this
board is
not increasing the work of the
government it's using actual
data and resources already available
coordinating them and coming up with a
strategy to move forward
can you imagine suspending the board and
then asking three different departments
to investigate whether the board is
redundant
I mean that speaks for itself and
finally
there's a requirement that the
oversight committee out of Da out of the
committee on Health and Human Services
that the law is required to
ask the oversight committee to provide
oversight over the board
they already have that Authority
we are statutorily attached to DHHS
and that's what the oversight board
is designed to oversee
so that's not even necessary it doesn't
need to be in statute they can already
do it and we'd be happy to work with
them
the part that to me is a little
disingenuous is that we have worked with
this bill's sponsor
over and over we've had public session
during and aside from the actual
pdab meetings
and yet this session
again
there are two bills designed to torpedo
and repeal pdab so the state of New
Hampshire
with millions of dollars
of cost for prescription drugs will
remain in the dark and the Black Box
around these expenses
will remain intact
as a physician my highest priority has
always been to advocate for the health
of my patients
prescription drugs have always been a
critical component of the provision of
appropriate care
as a provider I have had to have a full
understanding of their efficacy side
effects
and even their financial impact on my
patients
in a similar vein the role of pdab
is not based on a single sentence that
may need to be modified
the role of pdab is to ensure that the
state of New Hampshire has done
everything possible
to fully understand the extremely
complex prescription drug Marketplace
and cost structure in order to ensure
that patients covered by the state and
Municipal and County programs have
access to the medications they need at
the lowest possible cost
that makes sense that's common sense and
by the way this was never
a partisan bill
neither of my bills that I've filed
we're a Democrat or a Republican bill
they had bipartisan sponsorship and
strong support in the Senate and the
house
we have all watched as prescription drug
prices continue to Skyrocket
representing a significant and Rising
fiscal burden to patients municipalities
into the state
HB 172 will effectively eliminate
the only tool
that we have to fully understand why
this is happening and how we might
mitigate its impact
I asked you to itl this bill
and to allow the prescription drug
affordability board to continue its work
with transparency
on behalf of the people of New Hampshire
thank you I'm happy to take questions
uh we do have questions representative
Burroughs
thank you thanks uh thanks for taking my
question Dr Sherman good to see you
um
you say the board's been in it has been
going for two and a half years is that
right yes can you can you tell us about
what you feel has been accomplished or
how you're getting to the goal from the
past two and a half years
well yeah
it's you know for somebody who likes to
get things done yesterday this has been
an exercise in
incredible patience
um we have moved forward the the
approach to fiscal last year and and
representative Merchant can speak to
this as well came from the fact that you
know what's the horse and what's the
cart
we need funding to hire an executive
director
but we need an executive director
to move forward with our fee structure
and our budget
and what we realized is that
not only did we take pretty much the
first year to bring the entire board up
to Snuff on the complexity of this
system and by the way I'd recommend
people actually go back and look at some
of those if you've ever wondered what a
PBM is how insurers work how
Pharmaceuticals price all of these
things were covered in the first six to
12 months
then we've gone through the rulemaking
process which is onerous and you know
for good reason this has to be done
properly we also realize that in the
original Bill we had the wrong
classification for the executive
director we had to go through that
process of reclassifying
changing the classification of the
executive director
so there were things in the construction
of this
board that I did not anticipate as Prime
sponsor and that learning curve has been
occurring over the last two and a half
years requiring further legislation
requiring rules going back and forth to
fiscal
right now
with the budget we are poised to start
the data collection
and the data collection is both from the
entities that we are asking to work with
and some of it is proprietary so it has
to remain confidential we tightened the
accountability on board members for that
confidentiality
at the request of Pharma and at the
request of ahip we have adjusted much of
what we do at the request and on based
on the input of a hip
um and so we are really listening and
responding and finally we're at a point
where we can start Gathering that data
but again trying to avoid increased cost
avoid redundancy
we recognize that UNH even though
uh one of our board members is from UNH
is a professor there UNH actually
through the College of Health and Human
Services has the data that would be very
helpful Dartmouth also has it so we're
not exclusive
working with UNH and understanding
normally that would be the role of the
executive director but we don't have one
so we're doing it and representative
Merchant has been very good at divvying
up the burden so that each of us on a
voluntary basis is trying to fill that
role until we have the ability to hire
and assign that role to our executive
director
the point is that right now we feel
poised to start Gathering data
as was pointed out by Mr fundstein and
Heidi there is a question about whether
the metric that we identified originally
in the original bill is the most
appropriate metric for understanding
cost and how is it applied that's part
of the deliberations of the board
we still completely understand our
mission which is to lower cost
if possible to make recommendations on
strategies to lower costs for
prescription drugs for the people of New
Hampshire for the taxpayers of New
Hampshire
that's our goal
whether we have to make further
adjustments in the actual metrics we use
to achieve that goal
that's something we talk about every
time as you can tell from the prior
testimony
but that doesn't mean
that we should stop the process
Maine is a is a different state it has a
completely different process ours has
been
incredible for me personally I thought I
knew a lot about prescription drug
pricing and cost
it's been a very steep learning curve
but there is no redundancy there is no
other place in the state of New
Hampshire where
there is a charge to actually look at
all these costs unmask the Black Box
understand what the price driver what
the cost drivers are and then come up
with strategies that allow patients to
go ahead and get the meds they need at
the lowest possible cost of the state
thank you follow up quick follow-up I'll
make it further question I'm sure you'll
make it quickly
so okay Dr Sherman would you if this
board was put on Ice which is is what
the what seems to be what the the goal
is how would that impact the commission
would the all this data I mean all this
work be basically be fleshed out to see
what's your what's your take
um you know the the work that we've done
would be archived I assume
um
if the legislature chose to
unsuspend I mean the suspension goes
until June 2024
it you know these things are very fluid
um changes in the prescription drug
market and in cost drivers change
rapidly
as you've heard there's Federal
legislation but there's no federal
equivalent to this board especially
focused on taxpayers of New Hampshire
so
I I can't tell you what would happen but
I can tell you because the law requires
it I would have more free time
um we would be done the work would not
continue
um and I think that's a that's a huge
loss to the state
okay well set thank you
um just got a card in from the New
Hampshire insurance department DJ
Bettencourt and Jason Dexter two minutes
they do not take a position on the bill
but they do feel obligated to in Parts
some interesting information
thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee it is in fact true uh well
first for the record uh DJ Bettencourt
Deputy Commissioner of the New Hampshire
insurance department
I'm joined by Jason Dexter who is the
head of our life and health unit it is
in fact true that we did not intend to
speak initially
but throughout the course of the
testimony we were invoked so many times
and both supporters and opponents of the
bill were asking why we weren't going to
testify and we just couldn't disappoint
our loyal fans any longer so thank you
so first and foremost the
department is always happy to do the
work that is given to us by the
legislature so if the legislature this
committee and others would like us to
take up this work we will of course do
that work we do have a member of our
department on the pdab board and we are
kept abreast of their deliberations and
we appreciate that service
I did want to share before I turn it
over to Jason that the New Hampshire
insurance department has a long-standing
commitment to transparency and that
includes the prescription drug space
I don't recall if we got around to this
when we had our orientation with you but
the department is very very proud of its
Health cost website so the health cost
website takes all of the list prices for
procedures across the state of New
Hampshire and allows consumers to plug
in their particular insurance coverage
and then create a geographic region
around wherever they are depending on
how far they're willing to travel it
will give them prices that they can
consider so that they can perhaps choose
a provider that gives a lower cost than
another provider and we are looking to
expand that effort into prescription
drugs for a long time we were looking
very seriously at expanding
that effort to prescription drug
formularies unfortunately our life and
health actuary decided to retire on us
and so that work
um is on hold for now until we can find
a replacement for him if any of you know
any good actuaries please do send them
our way
but in the absence of that we are
looking to add high cost drugs to our
health cost website and then hopefully
we'll be able to expand that later
as was mentioned earlier I believe the
department has in the past looked into
prescription drugs and cost drivers and
that was the subject of a portion of our
annual hearing report back in 2021 I
believe it was
and so we do look at this very very
seriously and on a regular basis you
know as it pertains to pdab the ultimate
choice of what you want to do as a
policy decision and that is entirely up
to you as the policy makers but there
are complexities and some considerations
that I think are worthy to consider as
you deliberate and Jason's going to get
into some of those
foreign
thank you DJ
um thank you for having me today Jason
Dexter director of Life and Health New
Hampshire insurance department I oversee
a few units one is the healthcare
analytics unit the other is the market
regulation unit Dr as is uh is the head
right now of the healthcare analytics
unit
one of the issues that's been I think
mentioned a few times is we have
regulatory authority over carriers who
have these relationships and contracts
with pbms which are ultimately managing
something on their behalf we collect
data either through a market regulation
process or through our chis
Comprehensive Health Insurance system I
forget what just stands for but we
collect a lot of data but the reality
for us is that information that the
carrier and that Contracting with that
PBM is we're not able to give out it is
proprietary trade secret contracts that
we can't give that secret sauce that
explains where that money is moving it's
not something we can do both the chis
regulations make that clear that we have
to be protective of that in a market
regulation when we're doing Market
conduct exam that information is the
exam work is confidential
so that inhibits our ability to explain
it at that level
as DJ mentioned we we collect
information at the behest of the
legislature we collect information on
what carriers are doing with rebates
they have to file and attestation saying
we send our rebates are flowed back into
premium or something else there's a
statute on that that we adhere to
there's another where we collect
information from
manufacturers about high-cost drugs that
information we post on a website which
gives us the ability to as DJ mentioned
potentially add that to our health cost
page so that information is available so
if there's additional
information that can flow through us
we're happy to do it the primary concern
being the confidentiality
how did you take questions
representative spear
thank you
uh when we have the bill that you
referred to last time so you came in and
and spoke to us
uh we also had we were looking at the
drug prices and I found this picture
online this exact one and then I said to
myself
follow the money and I found out how
pbms make their money
and quite frankly I was appalled because
they make their money at the expense
they negotiate with uh
make sure you're focusing on a question
yes I am getting to the question
so the fact that there is absolutely no
transparency in that process as a buyer
of drugs upon occasion was really
appalling what Dr Sherman and uh
representative Merchant were talking
about was opening up some of that
transparency because otherwise how would
you get to that and you're saying that
you cannot get to that is is that what
you're saying
yes
and they will not be able to either
I don't think so interesting thank you
foreign
thank you very much
uh the chair will call on Jake Berry
the new Futures in support of the bill
good morning Mr chairman honorable
members of the committee my name is Jake
Ferry I'm the vice president of policy
and new Futures as many of you know new
Futures is a nonpartisan non-profit
Health policy and advocacy organization
we work to ensure access to quality
affordable health care for all Granite
Staters I don't want to repeat too much
of what's been said here this morning I
think we've all been here long enough
but I do want to stress new Futures
strong opposition to this bill certainly
we don't have an issue with exploring
redundancies and looking into maximize
efficiency and cost savings but we're
very concerned about the piece of this
bill that would suspend the activity of
the p of the pdap uh we believe strongly
that pdab plays an important role
helping the state set spending targets
and identify strategies to address
Rising drug costs and for the health of
our state we believe that it must uh be
allowed to continue to do its work
it was mentioned earlier uh that drug
prices are are that certain drug prices
are coming down I would ask if anybody
in this room feels that drug prices are
where they need to be
um
and believe it can everybody you know
can all of us access the pictures the
prescription drugs that we need at the
pre at an affordable price point I would
certainly think not people are still
unable to afford their prescription
drugs people are still rationing their
medications people are still skipping
their medications entirely and the cost
you know the the human cost of that the
cost that adds to our Health Care system
are our uh are immeasurable uh so
certainly uh as I said yeah you know
simply put Rising drugs Rising drug
costs are impacting the health of our
friends and our neighbors across the
state it's critical that we do all that
we can to support the pdab to help to
allow to continue it to do its work to
help address these issues rather than
enforcing it to stop to suspend the pdab
at this point would be unfortunate and
misguided and would really undercut our
ability to address this uh this
Healthcare crisis of affordable drug
costs with that I'm happy to take any
questions
see you none thank you very much thank
you I have no more cards so I will close
the public hearing
house bill 172.
all right Peter I'm sorry we're a little
running a little late but
right
foreign
good morning representative
Schmidt
good morning Mr chairman and members of
the Commerce Committee for the record my
name is Peter Schmidt I represent Dover
Ward one uh I have the privilege uh
representing Dover award one for the
past 20 years
and I'm pleased to bring before you
today
you guys
I like competition but not in all cases
um so uh bring before you uh House Bill
319 establish a committee to study an
all-payer system of insurance for
Hospital Services
um and I'm not going to go on at any
length here because I have several
medical friends and Associates who are
extremely knowledgeable about the system
which is currently in use in the state
of Maryland so this is not a New Concept
it has been looked at by several States
and is being used very successfully in
the state of Maryland and so I will
defer to Dr dalkhart for his testimony
in regard to the bill and thank you for
your attention thank you
thank you
uh chair will call and Ken dulgar
from Grantham
well
good morning good morning
everybody's interesting observing this
as a physician
um my name is uh Kendall card Dr Kendall
card
I have practiced in New Hampshire since
1983. initially in the Southern Tier in
Nashua and then up at Dartmouth
um from 2017 to 2016 and I'm currently
semi-retired teaching still at Geisel
but also working at Mount Ascutney
Hospital in Vermont which serves
Claremont
and the Claremont area and I have to
tell you
that tragedies related to
unaffordability
crazy deductibles not receiving care
does kill people and results in genuine
loss among your citizens
I'm seeing this firsthand in New
Hampshire
and you're likely hearing from
constituents
and certainly from many doctors that
Health Care in New Hampshire is in
trouble
I've been here for 40 years I have never
seen it like it is right now
I'm a Vanishing breed I'm a primary care
doctor
um and um you're going you are seeing I
don't know how many of you are having
difficulty finding a primary care doctor
where you live that is not an accident
and I'll discuss this briefly
um so you're hearing from your
constituents about this and what I'd
like to do is introduce HP 319
which is sponsored by representative
Schmidt and proposes creating a
legislative committee
based in the legislature appointed by
folks in the legislature but including
multiple stakeholders
including folks from communities
this committee would study the merits of
an all-payer Global budget system
that can bring down the Absurd costs of
Health Care that your constituents are
dealing with both in their property
taxes in their
employee sponsored insurers
and business owners who are trying to
keep up with this
so I just want to make a couple of key
points I'm going to just read a little
bit from here as well but
we have seen just now from uh the
discussion simply about drugs
that New Hampshire has no overall
strategy to manage the explosion of
health care costs that we have all seen
in the past 40 years there is no overall
strategy you have one group that may be
looking at prescription drugs another
looking at insurance issues but unlike
all other New England states by the way
the New Hampshire Advantage has in this
case resulted in a major disadvantage
in fact
according to the New Hampshire Insurance
Department's published information in
New Hampshire has the highest premiums
and deductibles
that our Citizens need to pay for
employee sponsored Insurance in all of
New England
and
we are 49th
in having the highest cost with the 49th
highest cost of deductibles of that
insurance this is a real issue
it's not imaginary
um so
a couple things about all pair is
probably something that is new to you
that word
uh it is not going to be new to you in
the next six months next 12 months
you're going to be reading a lot more
about this because centers for Medicare
Services has looked at the Maryland
model and said hey this does work we
have saved in Maryland
billions that's B of dollars since the
institution of this program and they are
now going to be introducing this across
the country
so I'm asking that this legislature in
fact
start to look at taking responsibility
for overall strategy for health care
costs and accessibility and quality
and this is one such model that would be
important to look at
um you know I heard something about
transparency
of costs
and I hear from my patients as you hear
from your constituents
you have no idea what the cost of that
procedure will be until you get the bill
in the mail
um yes you could see prices listed uh
throughout New Hampshire there's been
efforts there's been legislation passed
nationally as well as locally but those
costs remain opaque
not by accident it's how the system is
structured
um we heard a little bit about
proprietary costs for drugs well the
amounts paid by your insurance company
for a particular service if it's a
private a for-profit insurance company
what they pay for your appendectomy for
your colonoscopy for your whatever it
might be Hospital related or even
outpatient is not transparent if you
have an MRI your doctor ordered
yeah you could look up what MRIs cost
but you're not clinicians you're not
going to know if you need intravenous
contrast with that MRI if it needs to be
of this organ or that the costs remain
opaque because that is how the status
quo has designed it that's not by
accident so as you know Private health
care insurers
during the 1990s uh basically led the
show
so American health insurance plans ahip
represents a managed care hmos that
basically Ruled The Nest or the roost uh
in the 1990s and dictated to hospitals
this is how much we're going to pay you
for that procedure
hospitals got smart
they decided to structure systems
so it's not by accident that Leahy
Clinic expanded as it did that Brigham
and women actually MGH Brigham used to
be called Partners expanded as it did uh
that Dartmouth Health has expanded as it
has it wishes to have more clout in
those negotiations and in fact now
the Health Care Systems local Health
Care Systems like Leahy DH and these
large systems they actually have more
command of those negotiations that
happen behind closed doors
with the insurance companies that is
proprietary information although there's
may there's now a law and effort there
is recent legislation trying to pry open
that that information it is hard to do
so what you have is the health insurers
now dictating to the insurance companies
this is what you need to pay us because
we have this many communities that you
have insurance in
okay
the health insurance companies say no
problem
the ACA mandated that Health insurers
pay 80 percent of their revenue
to Health Care
the other 20 percent you could use for
administration for overhead for profit
Etc
so it the health insurance like a
utility that's unregulated says okay
you're charging us more no problem we
will raise our premiums and our
deductibles it's no issue and it's not
by accident that these prices have been
accelerating in the recent past because
of the change in the health structure in
the health industry
um this is uh well recognized by the way
there was a study that came out Tuesday
in general American Medical Association
looking at Health Systems
they raised the the prices through
communities uh and they do not pay that
they do not provide better quality and
that's been my experience as a
practicing physician in in New Hampshire
so they have little incentive to keep
down costs they make the same profit
regardless the problem is
what we pay for as Citizens this is
public knowledge it's on the New
Hampshire Insurance department's website
published 2020 and 2021
both in the large and small group
Insurance markets this is private
insurance
uh we averaged 19 higher than the
average deductible in the United States
and as you know we also pay higher
premiums for both the large and small
group markets than the U.S average or
any other New England State that's not
by accident because no one's watching
the store uh I don't have to tell you
between 2000 2019 when average inflation
given recent variables has been about 53
percent the price of your employee
premium contributions went up 243
percent that is not looking at their
deductibles that's premiums so there's a
problem
if you have to have a colonoscopy and
you have to pay five thousand dollars
out of your pocket to get that done
because you have a cheaper plan but
that's your deductible are you going to
get your colonoscopy heck no you're
going to get your surgery for your colon
cancer
um is what's going to happen
um and this is do I see this in my
practice
yes this is a reality
um
so
um another reality I mentioned I'm a
Vanishing breed of primary care Ducks I
don't know how many of you have had
difficulty finding primary care where
you are
that is not by accident either and
there's some background to that
the private intermediary Health insurers
selectively pay for more services than
others The Benchmark is Medicare as you
know Medicaid pays the least nobody
wants to take it Medicare intermediate
employee sponsored insurers they pay the
most but not for everything
if you ever wondered why you see the ads
for knee Replacements in the local
hospital or the bypass surgery it's
because the hospitals make 330 percent
over Medicare for some selected
procedures and surgeries
they get the best revenue for doing
things to people
Primary Care
um family practitioners Primary Care
internists pediatricians
psychiatrists what do we do we spend
time in front of our patient talking
about okay tell me about how you're
managing your diabetes how are you doing
with your depression is that impacting
how you're taking care of your diabetes
of course it is that's lengthy that
takes time guess what that's reimbursed
10 percent more than Medicare
the the
Primary Care is the only
sub-specialty recognized that you have
more docs who are primary care docs you
have improved longevity you have less
illness why we do lead screening for
kids we take care of your cholesterol
before you need that bypass surgery we
manage your diabetes it's low cost
low-tech timely and not reimbursed
hospitals look at primary Hospital
systems
whose intent is the right place don't
get me wrong when they have to manage
their finances
they look at Primary Care as a lost
leader
uh yeah we'll keep we'll we'll maintain
it but we certainly won't incentivize it
this has been the experience across the
United States this is not new this has
been throughout my career
Maryland and other states that have all
pair systems figured this out some years
ago
if we can disincentivize hospitals from
building more more real estate
if we can level the payments for a
service
between all insurers and by all insurers
that means Medicare
Medicaid which hospitals hate taking
because they lose money on it and
employee sponsored insurers then there's
one price for a service it's easy to
translate what your MRI is going to cost
because there's one price for it it's
not across the state it's per hospital
by the way that's important
hospitals by the way that are teaching
hospitals that have a neonatal ICU these
have big ticket items
they have different needs than Cottage
Hospital or Androscoggin hospital or
whatnot they have different costs so the
all-payer system
creates a transparent state agency
basically would incorporate all the
other agencies that you that comes
before this committee on HHS on a
regular basis gathers the data and says
okay let's sit down between Southern New
Hampshire Medical Center St Joe's and
Humana or Cigna or whatever and let's
negotiate what you think is going to be
the right price they set a price that's
uniform for all those in those employees
sponsored for profit insurers Medicare
and Medicaid
guess what it is allowed many hospitals
in Maryland to avoid the revenue issues
they've been dealt dealing with during
the pandemic they have a global budget
they can predict what they're going to
get paid the next year and it's up to
the hospital there's a lot of autonomy
in this
hospitals can decide do I want to pay
staff more do I want to invest more in
prevention of of opioid addictions do I
want to spend more on I don't know an
orthopedic procedures if it's if that's
their their want but they they have the
autonomy to do that
but they have the data by which to do it
because that's also an important
component of this it's compiled it's
it's put together
um and it works
you have before you some of those
specific statistics
but the reason CMS is now going to
incentivize the development of all pair
systems is it is
um really had a major impact on saving
money for the residents of Maryland
one other issue it's also helped keep
rural hospitals out of the red I don't
need to tell you many rural hospitals
have closed across the country
the reason for that as you may know is
they don't have pair mix
rural hospitals such as where I'm
practicing currently are working often
where manufacturing has left these are
rust belts
they don't have a lot of folks on
employee sponsored insurances who pay
better they have a lot of folks on
Medicaid even if they're working a lot
of working folks on Medicaid and many
older folks who remained in the
communities on Medicare they don't they
have Medicare and Medicaid and that's
where they get their revenue they don't
have the pay or mix
so when you set a price on a global
budget for such a hospital it can
predict what's going to happen the next
year it's not going to be vulnerable to
pandemics or to these payer mixes
because it's going to be incentivized
actually towards quality and serving the
community which is some of the
benchmarks that the total cost of Care
Program in Maryland has done
I think the other important issue this
is a Commerce Committee you you deal
with folks in many different
jobs and works and walks of life
hospitals actually have come to embrace
this remember there's academic
institutions in Maryland namely John
Hopkins
the academic institutions which are
teaching hospitals as well as the
independent other hospitals private
hospitals or Community Hospitals have
embraced this because it makes it more
predictable and they're having
assistance in looking at these Global
budgets for with the data that's
gathered
um I I think that it's something to get
familiar with
um it's going to be important in years
to come because of the the crisis that
we're actually seeing right now
um I don't the statistics are in um the
stuff that I've I've provided you
um and um uh I think that I will share
that no health system is perfect I want
to underline that that is clearly true
but in my career I have never seen the
health system in as much trouble as it
is right now
the status quo is not working it's not
serving as an advantage to New Hampshire
um and I think that creating this
legislative committee well I'm sorry the
study committee from the legislature uh
to at least look at all pair and other
options is a first necessary step
to have some overall strategy for New
Hampshire and create a sustainable
affordable Equitable and trusted Health
System
so at that I'll conclude and welcome to
take questions great uh representative
Herbert has a question for you
um your last statement
um
we I don't know if you were here when we
and the previous bill was discussed
would it be your advice
that we
um
keep that uh original
Bill and and not kill it
I am speaking on a related but different
topic yeah no no it's not no I I would
say I would agree with Dr Sherman
because with what's obvious to all of
you yeah that there are no restraints
on the cost of pharmaceuticals because
there are no restraints on the cost of
pharmaceuticals pbm's uh the pharmacy
benefit managers
are opaque they do not serve insurance
subscribers they serve the for-profit
insurers that's their design and
non-profit too anyhow but that's not far
sorry
that was a terrible question okay uh
yeah you don't ask you have an opinion
about a different bill yeah what do you
have a specific question about this bill
in front of you do you have a specific
question about this bill
um no I was going to do would you
believe that uh chairman hunt and I have
sat through uh an explanation literally
a couple hours of about pbms and and
trying to explain to us
that uh what it how it works and I'll be
honest with you
I left that and I had no idea other than
the fact that it was very this is a
would you believe question would you
believe would you believe that the cost
of your hospital care and your community
care is equally opaque
yes
okay unless you go on the insurance
Department's price doesn't help you
that's what I'm getting at why doesn't
it because every procedure has details
that are clinical
is this an emergency procedure because
you're Landing in that emergency room
because you're in the midst of having it
no I'm not worried about emergency no no
but but those are part of the costs no
no but I'm saying that MRI but you'll
get a bill for four weeks later you
can't shop around you're you're
obviously you can't shop around an
emergency yes right but those costs are
extraordinary and that's where people go
bankrupt okay not when they have
three months to research where in New
Hampshire can I get my knee replaced I'm
passing a kidney stone today
I need to go to the local hospital
because I'm in excruciating pain I can't
figure out or I'm having an MI a
myocardial heart attack I can't tell the
ambulance driver take me to Androscoggin
instead of you know uh Littleton because
it's cheaper they will take you to the
closest hospital when it comes to real
costs for New Hampshire citizens
that emergency
is real that's what kill that's what
makes New Hampshire citizens go bankrupt
if you have the time to to shop around
it's still going to be opaque you're not
I just talked with somebody the other
day got an immunization for something I
didn't realize it was going to cost 600
I checked beforehand it and and that's
someone who's Savvy and not in an
emergency so to answer your question is
it equally opaque yes does ahip want
Americans to know that no
um they were in it legitimately to make
a profit that's their mission statement
serving New Hampshire citizens you have
to come you have to balance that so it
is equally opaque and I make that
statement comfortably represent feellet
has a question
it would be fair to say that on the
insurance department's website all
procedures are listed however my ability
to choose the provider for those
procedures is limited by whether it is
an emergency or not
um so what's the distinction between
listed prices for emergencies versus so
I haven't been on the website recently
last time I did I was pulling my hair
maybe it's better now
um
the problem is insurance companies so a
whole bunch of issues with managed care
and employee sponsored insurance by the
way Medicare and Medicaid it's pretty
transparent because we pay for it
directly from the taxpayer when it comes
to our premiums and deductibles that's
not transparent because it's paid
indirectly
um
so there is a difference between an
emergency procedure and a non-emergency
procedure but we are clinically there's
so many details that go into the
performance of a particular procedure
that you really have to be a physician
to know does this kidney stone that I'm
passing need intravenous contrast can I
do it without contrast can I do this CT
scan versus an ultrasound Etc plus your
insurance changes if you're if your
company changes insurances and the
insurance changes their policies and
reimbursements depending on their
negotiations I don't know if that
answered your question uh that was great
thank you
this is
representative Gibbs thank you
uh I'm afraid I have a would you believe
as well
um in reference to non-emergency
procedures would you believe that every
single time I have a routine procedure
and I'm talking really routine think
blood tests I ask what my out-of-pocket
cost is going to be because if I could I
would rather pay up front than get a
bill in the mail
and every single time I am told we have
no idea
absolutely I hear this daily your
constituents are seeing this daily
that's not a what would you believe it's
yeah I know
okay great thank you very much for your
testimony we appreciate it welcome thank
you
uh chair we're calling James Fisher
good morning I'm Dr James Fisher I'm
retired also a primary care physician I
I don't have a ton of things to add to
what Dr dolcart said because he's been
leading this uh but I do want to clarify
a couple of things that might be helpful
and I also want to answer any questions
that you might have and I think it's
probably more important right now
um I think uh one of the things that
came up in the questions were about
emergency care versus routine costs and
and that's important I'm glad that you
were able to make a distinction
but one of the problems that that Dr
dolkart mentioned is that it's more
difficult to find primary care
physicians I was one of them and on a
personal story I've been working for at
um Portsmouth Hospital for about
close to 20 years and Portsmouth
Hospital back in
2014 2015 went through a primary care
Purge there was a report that we heard
one of our
meetings that the administration gave
mentioned specifically that Primary Care
was a loss leader and that the hospital
Administration thought that they had way
too many Primary Care Providers
and they said we need to cut about 20 or
30 positions which they did and I was
one of those those positions I ended up
at the VA hospital and was happy to get
into the VA system that's another story
um but as a result of having fewer
Primary Care providers and it's not just
Physicians there's nurse practitioners
there's Pas and so on but what happens
is fewer people able to get in in a
timely manner and when you have fewer
primary care physicians it means that
people aren't going to be taking care of
themselves as much you're going to get
more emergencies you're going to get
more problems coming out and people are
going to need emergency care emergency
procedures and so by definition you're
going to drive up the cost of medical
care so yeah it's nice to know in
advance but even trying to know in
advance is difficult because sometimes
things happen even during regular
procedures so it's difficult as as Dr
dulcart mentioned you know complications
occur even when it's a routine procedure
and so you don't always know and so
you're you're getting these extra bills
and it's driving up the cost
the other thing I like about uh this
particular house bill it doesn't force
you to do anything okay it asks you it
it beckons you to look at other ways of
reducing medical costs and and I I know
some of you campaigned on issues on
inflation well there's no bigger spot to
look at inflation than in medical care
costs it's been the the biggest driver
that's been going on for well over a
decade several decades so that if you're
really truly interested in in in
containing inflation this is a great
place to start this is something you can
go back to your constituents and say
look we've looked at this okay and we
want to do something about it it doesn't
commit you to actually doing something
yet
but it at least gives you a perspective
that you can take back to people and let
you let them know about
others of you were concerned about local
care and and local community control
well that's what this also does okay it
allows individual hospitals to decide
what their Global budget is going to be
from from one year to the next or for as
long as you decide that that time
commitment that time frame is going to
be and so it takes it takes a lot of the
the costs or the determination of costs
away from large insurance companies
which I'm sure aren't going to like this
very much and it puts it more in the
control of local hospitals
where we live uh so those are just a
couple of points that I heard from the
questioning I I'm not as well let me
just answer any questions you might have
based on either what I've said or any
backup on on your questions on Dr
dolkert
any questions from the committee
oh come on I'm not that clear you've got
to have some questions well sure I'll
ask a question how is this going to
control prices when when the house you
say the hospitals will determine the
price or is it or is it good I see here
is that there's going to be a select
board who's going to decide how much
that hospital can get no
my understanding is that the hospital is
going to con is going to have their
Global budget and and it's it the budget
is based on patient care not based on
real estate you know we're going to buy
up uh you know the land next door so we
can expand whatever this is based on
care at all as itself so that the
hospitals determined from one from one
year to the next the way that kind of
saves money is that we'll take the
pandemic for example okay we've just
gone through this and we're still going
through it it's not over I mean it's now
an endemic it's going to be with us for
a long long time but the hospitals that
that will fare the best are the ones
that know what their what they need for
personnel to manage from one year to the
next so part of their Global budgeting
will be based on you know how many
employees they need so they can
determine that if they have to if they
what's happening now in New Hampshire is
people are burnt out they're quitting
they're they're retiring early and so
what a hospitals doing well they have to
hire a lot of temps well that's twice as
expensive as just simply having somebody
on staff or having extra people on staff
that drives up their costs so by being
able to budget a year in advance what
they're going to need to take care of
the people in their Community that's
going to save money over time
okay thank you very much thank you very
much
Donald College
um physician from Hanover
thank you very much Mr chair and
honorable members
um I'll try to keep my my comments short
um I am a I've been for 42 years a
family physician in New Hampshire
my career began in the North Country I
was practicing in Monroe New Hampshire
and admitting to The Cottage Hospital in
Woodsville
now these comments relate only to this
bill about Hospital financing but I'll
refer to my background again later for
the next bill
as president of the medical staff of
cottage
I learned that hospitals which serve
low-income communities
and cottage serve farmers and loggers
and small business people
depends on an adequate payer mix
High proportions of Medicaid and
self-pay can sink a hospital
during that period I also worked in the
emergency room of the hospital in
Newport and I saw the Newport Hospital
close for exactly that reason
an oil-payer system has been
demonstrated in Maryland to save
hospitals
I believe it deserves a close look to
see if could result in the same
combination of controlling costs and
improving quality in New Hampshire
primarily by establishing a single price
for services at that hospital regardless
of the payer
and I'll be happy to take questions
marvelous
representative walls
what is the thinking for for all of you
for setting up a committee versus just
crafting a bill to accomplish what
you're looking for
um I think the main reason is because
there are many experts here in New
Hampshire who we can't readily have
access to particularly the experts from
the insurance department
and I think that that from my
understanding of the Maryland Bill and
also of the even more complex overly
complex as far as I'm concerned Vermont
all pay our bill which requires huge
data collection
um my understanding is that involving
the insurance department will make it
possible to craft something that is um
efficient and
um and effective so I think in order to
bring in the expertise that we have in
this state a committee would be the most
efficient way of doing it
represent Philip
thank you Mr chairman this is probably
going to require a little bit of go back
and forth to to get to where I'm going
to as I understand it any medical
procedures require any number of
variables to get to the final cost as as
our previous speaker talked to about
that for example Imaging may require
contrast or no contrast is that correct
yes and that will change the cost of the
procedure for example if there is
contrast or not is that right yes
and would that be if we if there was an
all-payer system would the need for
those types of variables still remain in
healthcare correct
um not quite
um because the way that that hospital
billing works right now is led by
Medicare is by bundling
all of the the care for any given
condition into a single bill
this
all-payer system only deals with
inpatient services does not deal with
outpatient services so that when
somebody is admitted to the hospital
with let us say a heart attack or a
kidney stone
um the total charge would be for the
total care of that condition
and so therefore
the hospital
shares risk
because it provides a single price
for all payers to care for anybody who
comes to that hospital with that heart
attack or with that kidney stone
regardless of whether or not they
use contrast for that MRI or not
okay I think I understand so for the
question you may inquire rather than
under the current system where for
example it may be and rather than be
particular surgery a is the billing it
would be heart attack care would be the
billing it and you'll have to forgive
the facts that I'm not a physician would
that be is that correct the way that I'm
understanding it short answer is yes
although they are often very closely
linked if you come in with appendicitis
the definitive treatment for
appendicitis is an appendectomy
um the big difference is that right now
Medicare is the only payer that does
this bundling
and the other ones all of the other
payers the commercial insurers
um pay for individual charges for each
of the the contrast each of the aspirin
tablets
um as well as the or charges so by
simplifying it to be bundled around that
unit of care
and by charging the same amount to all
payers it will both control costs and
allow for planning so one final for a
follow-up so for me as a
as a non-medically trained person if my
stomach hurts and I want to quickly
figure out how much this is going to
cost me I would have to right now
without all pay or go onto a website
look through these procedures have no
idea how much this is going to cost
whereas with an all-payer I could
quickly look up app uh appendectomy or
appendicitis and quick get a quick
glance at this is ballpark yeah short
answer is is if you're really really
lucky
um because if you have abdominal pain
sadly you do not know if it's
appendicitis diverticulitis or you know
or pseudocyesis
um you know and they might want to try
to cure it with antibiotics before they
put you under the knife so so at any
rate so
I want you to know I really like you to
see check the New Hampshire Insurance
Department's page because we are
bundling we actually we were able to
match up
because an office you have uh
anesthesiologist you'll have the visit
care and the physician and you have a
hospital truck we were actually able to
bundle all those together so when it
comes time for one of those procedures
that you're interested that you elected
obviously non-emergency if it's elected
procedure you can actually see what the
cost is for that hospital yes and thank
you Mr chair um I I think this might be
a true beer conversation about how that
um that data that that is provided on
that website that I've looked at not not
perhaps as extensively as you would like
me to does not
um provide the same price for all pairs
because each payer negotiates separately
so again we're what we're talking here
is is there's your apples and oranges
one is what is the cost that the
hospital is going to charge okay so even
your insurance company is a little fuzzy
on that because they don't know which
primary care which physician which
surgeon is going to show up that day
okay so but you can go on and see what
the cost is the hospital Cost Plus the
doctor fees plus all those added costs
then your question is well how much is
my insurance company going to do my
deductible you have to call your
insurance company that at that point and
say with this procedure
what gets paid yep I I I I I I do
appreciate that and I think that this is
almost as
um as difficult for hospitals to plan
their budget as it is for individuals
such as an early representative
um because it all again depends on pay
or mix and and figuring out how much
each of those if there are 100
appendectomies they may get paid
um 30 different amounts so I'd be
interesting you bring that up because I
heard you have a statements made before
and this I'm going to use this as an
education for my committee because I
have a lot of new members so right now
we run on fee for service all right so
that means absolutely the hospital does
not know how many people they're going
to get the old model of Managed Care was
capitation in which they got reversed
regardless of how many procedures they
did okay people didn't like habitations
because it seemed like they were getting
paid for procedures they didn't do and
that's why we got rid of capitation so
the idea that you're going to use this
bill is to help a hospital budget I
would then assume is that you plan to
get a rid of fee for service and that
you're going to allow that hospital to
charge some space amount and to the
insurance company based on a perp or
decapitation rate because you want them
to pay for not doctors and nurses who
might not actually do anything but
because that is a fixed price that they
negotiated ahead of time
um and with apologies um chairman you
know we
again that this might take a while but
um I'm not in favor of capitation I
think that that at least not at this
level I think that what is often now
called value-based care ends up being so
gamable
by by insurance companies that what what
what I'm proposing is not capitation but
rather
um by bundling
around a unit of care I'm sorry a unit
of concern which is diagnosis and care
but then charging the same amount
to all insurers
for that condition
is not capitation
what this is doing is creating a even
playing field for the hospitals and for
the insurers
because they're not what what is what
kills us all is the cost shifting by
having
um all payer there's no cost shifting
everybody pays the same whether it's
Medicare Medicaid or Cigna
great thank you very much for your
testimony
oh my God okay who's got their hand up
yes representative McVay
um I'm reading from page two of this
bill number one it says establishing an
agency or Board of New Hampshire that
has the authority to set negotiated uh
for in paper in Hospital patient
services Etc where do you get the
leverage to do that what does this group
have any leverage I don't understand
that
um I'm not sure that I can easily answer
that because I don't understand well how
how boards I was interested to hear
about the the the pharmacy board and how
complex it was to establish it but
um the I think that that leverage comes
through the insurance department and so
I think the answer to the question is is
that the study committee is then going
to be given uh they're going to create a
statute that's going to create this
board and this board would have the
authority to tell the hospital how much
they're going to get the let me clarify
I think that that
um and I'd have to take a very close
look at the individual words the amount
that the hospital gets for that unit of
care is negotiated it is not the board
telling it yeah word negotiators there
that is correct yeah and and this is
very important because
um this will determine how much premiums
are going to be
um and and so it the board is not
setting prices it's guiding the
negotiation
okay thank you very much
oh yeah yes representative post so what
would the all-payer system create a
for the state
it would be like redistribution because
of Medicaid and Medicare that those
dollars if it's negotiated now the
state's going to have to pick that up
um no ma'am the um the each hospital
will negotiate with the board with
representation of the insurance
companies as to how many let's say
appendectomies they they take care of in
any given year
um and instead of
um of having
the
um
each Ensure
negotiate a separate price
all payers will have the same price for
that appendectomy so a person who has
none who did not have any insurance at
all will still have to pay a bill
um although many hospitals some
hospitals pursue those bills some write
it off
people who have Medicaid Medicaid will
pay that that price people who have
Medicare or Cigna or something else they
will all pay that price so the the no
bill will be coming back to the state
except to the extent to which the
state's contribution to Medicaid
um is is contributing
okay now we're all set thank you
uh chair we're calling Heather Stockwell
who is in support of the bill
nobody else has done that
it's good
I was going to say good morning but I
guess it's officially afternoon now
um
my name is Heather Stockwell I've lived
in New Hampshire for over 50 years and
in fact my father served in the state
legislature and was a friend and
colleague of your chairperson here John
Hunt for many of the years that they
serve together
so thank you for this process and for a
chance to speak to you today I'm in
support of this bill as a patient
um I think that not only does this bill
bring more fairness and transparency and
oversight to hospitals and insurance
companies but it's also here for the
patient and as the consumer affairs
committee I'm hoping that you all have
my Consumer Protections in mind
and right now
as somebody mentioned before I feel like
we don't have a great Advantage we call
this state that we have this Granite
State Advantage yet not only are in our
insurance rates higher than any other
state we have very high rates of
deductibles as was said before we also
which nobody has mentioned has the
highest rate or not the highest rate we
have one of the higher rates of denials
of care
this would not in my view I don't think
that that kind of thing would happen as
much because people would know ahead of
time and in fact two years ago my
husband had a surgery where he was
denied care
he already had the surgery so it was
afterwards and we were being left with a
six thousand dollar bill
we had already done our budgeting we
thought we'd paid everything
the hospital told us that it was our
responsibility
now I don't know what you all pay for
insurance premiums I'm told I have one
of the best policies I can get
they still denied that care that year
I paid 24
in premiums alone we almost lost our
house
the people of New Hampshire need need
y'all to stand up for them we are being
nickeled and dimed to death we have so
many co-payments and sometimes I don't
even know when I'm going to get another
bill from another company that's like a
like a radiology or an Imaging uh test
that I've had to have I get another bill
for that or I get blood work and and
that lab has their own separate billing
it's exhausting as a consumer every day
we are we are trying to negotiate
through scam callers emails texting now
it's gotten to a point where I cannot
trust anyone that reaches out to me
that's a sad State of Affairs
and and I I really um I I don't know all
of the ins and outs of uh the details of
how the hospital would budget budget but
as was said it is a negotiated thing and
as someone who has you know not had
insurance for over a decade and suffered
that way have switched had to you know
switched jobs and policies and doctors
because this insurance wouldn't pay that
doctor or that hospital
a lot of the work is getting put on the
patient or the consumer and it's it's
gotten to a point where that's part of
getting care we I really feel like I
don't have any more time and energy I
need to concentrate on my care and every
patient should be concentrating on their
care
not worrying about what they're going to
be left with as a bill I've also been on
Medicaid I've worked with a lot of do a
lot of work around Medicaid and I talk
to a lot of people about their health
care in the state I I work as a
healthcare organizer
and do a lot of community outreach and
even people on Medicaid and Medicare are
being denied care it is um or they don't
understand oh it's so complex I helped
my husband sign up for Medicare this
year
it was so complex we needed help
we couldn't understand all of all of the
ins and outs of the policies they're
going to pay this much of this if this
happens or this much of this if this
happens when I was pregnant 20 years ago
I called our local hospital to find out
how much it would cost for me to deliver
my baby
and I got that same answer
well we can't tell you that
because there's too many variables and I
said well let's let's just think about
no variables my birth is normal fine I'm
out of here in 24 hours how much can you
tell me how much that would cost
they couldn't tell me they gave me a
range of 20 to 30 000 and when I did the
math of the percentage that I would have
to pay
I realized I was not going to be able to
afford to deliver my baby in a hospital
there's something wrong here I did find
Alternative Care
at a birthing room
near the hospital if I needed it
I figured that women have been doing
this for thousands of years
without hospitals that I should probably
be able to do this
even that provider told told me that I
said how much is it going to cost and
they said well let's see how much we can
bill your insurance company for so what
I'm saying is right now we're
encouraging fraud in the insurance
industry and the hospital industry and
hospitals are not they say they're
non-profit
I've heard that in this room today
but hospitals aren't really giving back
to their Community they're buying
property
they're not helping patients that can't
afford their care and in fact I've been
in that situation where I did not have
insurance at the time that I fell down
the stairs and broke my leg and I was
stuck with an astronomical bill at that
point
I applied
persistence
they accepted
and then I was asked a year later if I
could start paying that back
it was an amount of money that I hadn't
seen in
uh at least one you know no year in my
life had I ever made that much money it
was you know over a hundred thousand
dollars uh that's not even including the
actual operation that was my Hospital
stay
this isn't
this isn't affordable to average
citizens of New Hampshire or anywhere
really quite frankly we really need to
to oops sorry reign in those costs I
talk with my hands we really and I I
believe that this would help us do this
thank you very much thank you uh I think
we're all questioned out thank you very
much
thank you
uh so Ken can you really do it in one
minute
okay so what I recommend is is that you
mail us you know you can get on the web
page you can see get all and and and
send it to us but that would be the best
way to do it okay
close the public hearing
for 319
353 we're about to take up
all right we'll close 319.
okay how many cards you got for 353.
um
surprise
stay apart
thank you
yeah
Church
everybody who's here to testify to know
that all bills in this committee
go to a subcommittee and we have a
smaller group who are focused on just
insurance and so they would be the ones
who who would be uh there but we don't
take testimony when we do a subcommittee
we we just thrash out a bill and you
know and and get to go get to an answer
so otherwise
um
and we love written testimonies yes
sending stuff written testimony is great
that's very appreciative okay Peter
three minutes you're on
thank you
again for the record Peter Schmidt
representative Dover award one
um and I am pleased to come before you
with House Bill 353 FN
um and
I have been the beneficiary of
single-payer for about the last 20 years
I'm just about to turn 85
and before I had the coverage under
Medicare I was always in kind of a
catch's catch can situation sometimes I
had coverage sometimes I didn't
so not only have I had excellent care
for 20 years but I've also had
affordability that's the advantage of
single-payer is that there's a system
that pays a cost on the basis of a
reasonable Insurance one of the aspects
of the Affordable Care Act is that it in
El Candor it ain't that affordable but
it's better than nothing and way more
affordable than nothing which is what
many people had before so the concept of
my bill is single-payer for the State of
New Hampshire but to make the
affordability much greater because we
only have a million 300 000 people
roughly
uh is that the the basic costs are
spread among a very much smaller
population so the other aspect of my
bill is it creates a compact of the
Willing obviously we would have to
negotiate with Maine
Rhode Island any other New England
states that want to participate to have
a compact that would have 10 to 12
million people if all the states were
involved that would spread the cost out
over a much larger number of people we'd
obviously have to have a Single Payer
plan in place to be able to negotiate
with these other states but it it would
have that advantage of much greater
affordability than we would have
otherwise so
the The Single Payer com compact uh
sorry the single-payer part of the bill
is very thoroughly explained it's a
standard single-payer player pay payer
plan that I believe is based on the
Illinois state plan so anyway I will I
will end my testimony at this point
answer any simple questions you may have
and then a lead on to my colleagues who
will give their testimony
okay representative spear
and you're going to be right to the
question now right
good
and you have to speak right into the
microphone all of you are not following
that rule speak right into the
microphone then it works it ain't Magic
okay
thank you
you talk in the in the in the bill you
it's mentioned that um
you'll negotiate with Medicare
as one of the people to help fund this
this trust I went online and looked and
Medicare said that they don't do that so
how would you how do you feel this is
going to get funded I think that's a
better question from my colleagues who
are more knowledgeable in these
specifics
great thank you very much
uh next up is Thomas Lane
can you hear me okay yep go ahead
so uh good morning Mr chair and members
of the committee my name is Thomas Lane
uh and I'm from Hanover
I helped write this bill
um because I'm sick and tired of seeing
our state suffer needlessly from
preventable causes
as a son and Grandson of three different
small business owners and also a student
of Economics this bill excites me
because it's a new idea to solve one of
the biggest problems facing our state
our nation and the economy
that problem is our health care System
as it stands now we pay ridiculous
prices and we get ripped off I don't
know how many of you have been watching
Washington lately
um but last I checked they haven't been
very helpful on Healthcare recently
um for the taxes we pay to them uh we
get headlines about fraud waste and
abuse in programs like Medicare
Advantage and the ACO reach program
which was just started last year
it's time to take agency back into our
own pragmatic honest and down-to-earth
headlines ants
um the big picture here is we pay far
more for care that leads to solidly
mediocre results compared to our Pure
Nations it's an embarrassment and it
also puts our businesses at a
competitive disadvantage how does that
work in our peer Nations businesses
don't have to worry about health care
like they do here
their health insurance is managed by
something similar to what this bill
would create
they are free to focus on their trade
and offering the best product for the
best price
in the United States by contrast
businesses of all shapes and sizes are
expected to somehow also be masters of
health insurance
somehow they're supposed to find a plan
to offer their employees amongst a
myriad of different overpriced options
with ever shrinking benefits and
networks
it's a massive chore in financial burden
that makes it harder for them to do
whatever business it is they should be
doing best
it's especially honorous for small
businesses like my dads and grandfathers
often they just can't afford to navigate
the health insurance Maze and struggle
to hire workers as a result
there's been a lot of talk about Labor
shortages lately this is part of the
reason why in a world of insane
Healthcare prices
workers don't want to work for firms
that can't afford to offer them health
insurance after all why would they
this bill solves that takes health
insurance off the table so our
businesses can focus on what they do
Best by ensuring that all residents have
access to robust health insurance at a
price they can afford based on ability
to pay
we gain a Workforce that is happier
healthier and more productive
this is an investment in our state's
long-term future and will encourage
economic growth make our state a more
attractive place for folks to move to
live in and start businesses in
strengthen our families and communities
and do all of that in the most cost
effective manner
as I conclude I want to remind you of
some of the key points of this bill
it is specifically designed to only go
into effect once the time is right in
other words it only starts when we have
joined with enough fellow states to make
it cost effective
furthermore it incorporates existing
Federal funding streams to minimize the
burden on taxpayers Via waiver processes
that do exist
um thank you
it is designed to be durable and
flexible
at its core is the idea of cutting fraud
waste and abuse while strengthening
families and communities
because systems of this type are so
efficient even after we open up access
to care who all who need it ordinary
families will still see significant
savings compared to what they pay now
finally is about securing our future
prosperity and protecting our
independence from those who want to take
it away from us thank you for your time
and I'm happy to answer any and all
questions you may have
it's perfect that was perfect right
under three minutes I timed it
uh and if you're willing to part with
that does your presentation the clerk
would appreciate that of course
I thought he was reading from a speech
but this is it no that this is different
than that
okay and representative Burroughs has a
question
yes thank you for taking my question I'm
wondering if your group has been in
contact with with folks who from other
states about doing this and what if so
what the reaction was yes we have
they're interested
okay uh follow up okay reading here that
um you want to incentivize a medical
attention uh earlier rather than later
and I'm wondering how this may fit in
with I think one of the biggest failings
that we have at least in in my neck of
the woods is that we don't do Wellness
care we do sick care but we don't do
Wellness care which I think could really
um save um consumers a lot of money and
and avoid a lot of procedures and
heartache down the road so I'm wondering
if that fits into this at all
so the problem with the way we do things
now is because people don't know how
much they're going to pay and because
they hear stories of such big bills they
procrastinate going to the doctor you
know we should all see the doctor every
year for obvious reasons they don't do
that
they only go to the doctor when it's an
emergency and emergencies are really
really expensive so if we just get
people going to the doctor every year by
establishing A system that allows them
to do so at no charge up front
um
they're gonna see the doctor every year
and that's going to catch things before
they turn into disasters which saves us
tons of money it saves lives it's just
the smart rational thing to do thanks
representative
are you viewing this as a single pair
format or as a public option format a
single pair format
oh my gosh okay representative here yes
actually ladies first representative
Gibbs go ahead
oops okay now it's on thank you uh
as I'm sure all of my colleagues uh have
I've been receiving many many
um email messages uh in opposition to
this bill and many of the writers of
those messages make an argument that
this proposal would allow interference
by the government
between uh the doctor and the patient
um
in your opinion if if you can tell tell
us
um would this system uh allow for
um greater or lesser or about the same
interference uh between the doctor and
the patient as we have now from
insurance companies
I think it's amusing that you're you're
getting those letters because it's
actually quite the opposite
um we currently have boatloads of
interference
um in the the relationship between your
patient and your doctor that existing
comes in the form of insurance companies
using they'll require prior
authorization prior authorizations and
other sorts of tactics like that because
they make money off of paying for Less
care in their insurance company they pay
out less they get to keep more
um and so what they do is they look for
reasons to say no
which is really hard which is really
dangerous because if you're you know
some insurance employees some are
sitting in an office and you know on the
other side of the country in San
Francisco or something
they don't know what's going on in that
doctor-patient relationship
um and so what we do here with this
system is we say you know we're just
gonna open it up if the doctor says that
that this is what the patient needs
and it's you know a normal procedure
we're going to trust the doctor
and we're going to let that go forward
um and by you know investing then in in
Primary Care
because we're going to reduce the amount
of those emergency procedures we can
afford to do that
um and so we're really doing here is
again protecting that
um doctor-patient relationship from
undue interference from Outsiders
representative McVay
um most of the letters I get are saying
this is a giant step towards socialized
medicine and the letters are almost
exactly the same who is behind this
who's generating generating this kind of
negativity you know I see it a lot
people see the s word and they get
scared
um
this is not socialized medicine
socialized medicine is where
um doctors are government employees
this does not make any doctor a
government employee this is just saying
that we will provide Insurance to ensure
that everyone can go see the doctor the
doctors are all going to be employed by
the same hospitals or whatever groups
they work for if they're you know on
their own doing their own private
practice nothing that does not change
this is not socialized medicine
my question was obviously this is an
organized effort to put this down who's
behind that
George Santos the Koch brothers
he's not smart he's paying for his next
campaign with this
um
you know again I mean the the the
private insurance industry is is not
going to like this I imagine that that
they have an interest in in trying to
shoot me down here um I find that
unfortunate
um but
you know that that's the way it is
okay
we really have a question
thank you
I don't have a I don't have a poker face
that is true go ahead represent his beer
is this about the waivers
I asked the question before okay
it does not allow anybody to go into
their income stream and take it and
negotiate it away so and neither and I
also looked up and neither does
um private insurance companies but for
employers
employee provided
so if these two income streams are not
going to work
where are you going to get the income
for this
um so
going back to the all player which is
not related to this this is not all pair
um Maryland has a waiver from the
federal government that'll
well they've been doing this for decades
you're you're not Medicare you're not on
taxes too you're right you're not on mic
but but we all heard you
okay so with with programs like um the
ACA with Medicare I believe chip as well
um you can get waivers they're called
Innovation waivers that allow you to
take the money and do something better
with it than what the federal government
is doing if you can prove that you
either improve quality
or reduce cost without impacting the
other or both you know makes sense so
these these waivers do exist and they
would allow us to take that money and do
something better with it
yeah so the insurance companies don't
really
play a role here because they're
basically you're telling them to exit
the state correct will you put that so
yeah the exiting New Hampshire is not a
big deal we're only a million what three
people but I would say to you since
you're in Hanover uh you should look
over what happened in Vermont where they
are this closest to ever come to
actually Implement a single-payer system
and it got all the way to the governor's
desk and he vetoed it because he said 11
increase in the state income tax was too
much this bill is designed with that
experience in mind
um
Vermont was trying to do it alone
Vermont is very small
because of that they're not able to
develop the economies of scale necessary
to push prices down far enough
to limit the the increase in taxes this
bill is designed so that it only goes
into effect when we have partnered with
sufficient states to give us enough
economies of scale
to make it so that we save lots of money
fair enough I don't think New Hampshire
wants to put in an income tax for the
sole purpose we would we wouldn't have
another in we don't have an income tax I
know in Vermont needed 11 increase on
their four percent tax
do you think that you think economy's a
scale got it okay
thank you very much
okay uh Ahmad Cuddy
Dr Cuddy
from Peter Pro
welcome
thank you for letting me speak Mr
chairman and esteemed members of this
committee
I'm a physician retired a cardiologist
who practiced for 50 years and retired
10 years ago
so
my claim to your attention is that if I
speak to you from what I experienced
American medicine from 1962 to say early
80s 20 years of my career in the United
States
you would call me a repo and bingo
because that era of American Medicine is
gone forever because we as an intern and
as a resident and trainee in cardiology
and so on in different care settings
I practically saw no
no uninsured patients or no family
members going into medical bankruptcy
and having to sell their Farm
pay for I'm an Interventional
cardiologist who had to have stents put
in and the patient would you know tell
me I saved their life but next visit
when they come to see me they would also
be having Tears in their eyes because
the hospital asked them to Hawk their
family farm and that was my experience
both in about the last 20 years in
central Nebraska but my primary years
were in Philadelphia Pennsylvania
for 24 years
so therefore and all along starting with
when I landed here in July 62
Saskatchewan Canada had just begun their
Medicare program for Canada and you may
recall or I will tell you that
provincial doctors went on strike
against Tommy Douglas who was the chief
proponent and the governor of the
province but he imported doctors from UK
and Australia and also to fill in the
Gap and the strike got busted in the
doctors by Christmas of the year went
back participating in the program
and that was the nucleus or you know
Forerunner of the national Medicare
program in Canada and so ever since then
uh my question to myself has been why is
it not possible on this side of the
Border
and of course there are many many
answers anyway for New Hampshire
we now spend uh per capita
uh six to seven thousand dollars
per year compared to the national
average of 5 000. so we are already
paying in spending in excess
and an average cost for a average person
in America now total cost is around
estimated around twenty thousand dollars
per year out of pocket through Insurance
all sorts of outlay cost
so if you take an average American
family earning say 55 000 that is way
over their annual income and we Define
we meaning most Health Care Community
policy experts
that a person should not have to spend
more than 10 percent of their annual
income on Health Care
so why is that
obviously and by my historical
background around early 80s
this profession rendering care to the
sick became corporatized
and not any you know can blame one
person one factor but it happens early
it happened
and institutions including organized
medicine and insurance companies drug
companies every player uh need to ask
that question did I help to bring about
the mess that we are in now
and I believe this planet bill that I'm
supporting
at in a compact uh setting in a regional
New England sense
would alleviate would take away New
Hampshire has 29
000 people with no insurance and if you
take in
underinsured that's about 70 000.
and nationally as you probably I'm all
familiar with is
under uninsured is 29 million in America
the richest country in the world and you
know birthplace of modern
uh technological scientific medicine
it's still the Envy of the world the
mecca of scientific
research medicine
and people from where I am from
originally India and so on still even
this generation of doctors training over
there look forward dream of coming to
America but do you see the Paradox when
they land here and when they are put in
say Bronx Hospital or a hospital in
Manchester or CMC
six to ten percent of our people are New
Hampshire people are uninsured they
cannot afford this this life-saving high
quality very scientifically
up there level of care
so that's where they we experience that
Paradox are we also containing a third
world within the first world the Paradox
you guys can save it by supporting this
bill
thank you thank you thank you that was a
time so I appreciate your testimony any
questions for the guests
thank you very much
thank you
all right looks like we have four cards
left and just to remind everyone we're
using an hourglass so I might interrupt
you uh if we get too far we are into the
committee's lunch so and uh and I know
some of you have been here some of you
have been here for some time uh waiting
to testify so uh the next uh the next uh
person to testify is James flesher
representing himself
and supports the bill
yeah I have a tough name I blame my dad
for that uh Dr James Fisher you've seen
me before I think
um let me go through a couple of things
um you know there's a fear about
socialized medicine and and a lot of
that actually came from the insurance
industry one of the ways in which they
they can Lobby
um they don't just Lobby
um politicians they can Lobby groups
um and uh such as uh the uh cons uh
uh just just went out of my head here
um
so and so the in lobbying groups they
they planted the idea of well we'll do
socialized medicine because that seems
like some sort of government control
um well you know the government has
things like Medicare which pretty much
keeps its hands off of what happens
personally with us with with
um our I'm still trying to think of the
word
um with their own health care in fact uh
regular Medicare has far fewer denials
far fewer interferences than the
Medicare Advantage plans which is which
is a privatized form of it's not even
Medicare privatized form of insurance
for older people
and and so uh one of the ways in which
those private companies make money is by
having people contribute to their plans
and then not paying out
um and I call that sort of Fun Size
health insurance uh you know those
little fun size candies it takes longer
to unwrap them than it does to eat them
you had a single bite from it and that's
kind of what happens in private care and
and here in New Hampshire we we've
championed private care we have among
more private care per citizen then just
about anybody else in New England and
what do we get for it what we get for it
is we have the highest the premium costs
the highest deductibles okay and the
highest co-pays we also have among the
highest denials of actual care so we get
the worst care possible of all of New
England for championing private
insurance and so what are we afraid of
we're afraid of well we're afraid of the
government saying look you know let's
let people and doctors get along with
each other and and not interfere with
them which is what what we're suggesting
here so uh
you know the whole idea of premiums is
that gets you in the door to to
insurance but getting in the door isn't
good enough because then you have to pay
for a deductible what's a deductible
that's additional money that they're not
charging for the premiums and when the
deductibles go up it basically says the
insurance company is saying look we're
going to pay you even we're going to pay
even less you've got to be in the
forgive the pun for candies but sweet
spot when it comes to Health Care you've
got to be able to make the make the
amount of money back from your premiums
make the amount of money back from your
deductibles make the co-pay for your
hospital or doctor or whatever it is and
then your health problem has to be
serious enough to cover all of those
expenses but not too expensive because
you have a cap that if you go over it it
comes out of your pocket as well and and
so that's fun-sized insurance and that's
going to only get worse we're looking to
get away from that okay we're looking to
say look let's let's let the doctors and
the patients get closer together so that
there's less interference from other
outside sources whether it's the
government
or whether it's private care and so yes
there's going to be a little bit of
government only to regulate it to make
sure that doctors are doing what they're
supposed to do and hospitals are doing
what they're supposed to do but beyond
that we're saying look let's let's get
this right let's make sure that Health
Care is is more available and cheaper
and when you have a Single Payer type of
system everything else goes away you no
longer have to worry about Medicare or
Medicaid it's already covered you don't
have people putting things off until
they get desperately sick that now it's
going to cost us more money to fix
and that's basically a nutshell what
this is asking to do except as Thomas
pointed out earlier
we don't even want to get it to kick in
until it becomes something that this
state can handle
especially this state because we don't
have a a an income tax we want to keep
it that way
so let's co-opt with other states which
are very much interested in this so that
we can make it affordable for our own
citizens this is why it's especially
important in this state to do
I'll entertain any questions you have
all right any questions from the
committee
question my testimony oh I'm sorry yeah
question so how would your Universal
Health Care coexist with the Affordable
Care Act That was supposed to solve some
of these problems you know one of the
things that happened in Massachusetts
because they did something similar in
terms of uh with their health care under
Mitt Romney
and uh and they actually got uh they got
waivers from CMS and other places to be
able to do it their way and and so the
same thing would happen here
um this we're taking it out of there's
no National system but we're taking it
out of what is National and we're we're
making it our own our own as far as uh
area group coverage
okay thank you for your question
thank you for Testimony seeing no more
questions we'll call uh Dr Donald kolish
and you have written testimony and you'd
like to hand that out
and we could ask you to summarize your
written testimony please I will thank
you
um so I'm and
Mr chair and and and members
um thank you very much I am I'm still Dr
Don kalish
um I practiced in the North Country in
Woodsville and then at Dartmouth
Hitchcock and then I finished and
finishing my career at the VA hospital
in White River Junction
but beginning about two years into
practice
I realized that our system of insurance
coverage
just didn't work
too many people postponed care and
suffered because they didn't have
coverage
things are better with the ACA
um but
six to eight percent of New Hampshire
residents are still without coverage
and because much of the ACA was written
by the insurance industry the
coverage through the ACA still has
between 20 and 30 percent overhead as
compared to two to four percent in
traditional Medicare
so the ACA was in the right direction
but
um hasn't gone far enough
I do believe that a system of Universal
Insurance like Medicare would be best
but New Hampshire is too small to have a
single system work we're just too small
with 1.3 million people
I support HP 353 because a multi-state
compact will achieve the economies of
scale while retaining our state's
ability to craft a system that works for
New Hampshire
and that's the end of my testimony I'd
be happy to take any questions thank you
nice and short any questions from the
committee
I think we're good to go thank you very
much thank you for your written
testimony
uh
Catherine Smith
we didn't lose your card
so he's in opposition to the bill
so my name is Catherine Smith and um I
have a very different perspective hold
the mic as close as you can my name is
Catherine Smith and um I have a very
different perspective I'm a home care
hospice nurse and I get to kind of see
what everybody thinks look good on paper
play out in reality in people's lives
and it's not
consistent at all
but that's not my van my my angle here
my angle here is to look at the some
specifics of the bill
um so I did write something I'm a
landowner taxpayer of State of New
Hampshire and I've taken into serious
consideration House Bill 353 introduced
in the regular session titled
establishing an interstate compact for
Universal Health Care
so we've been told it's not Universal
Health Care but it's right in the title
we um I'm conceiving that the same if
finally armed with the sanctions of an
act will be dangerous abuse of power and
a violation of the limits of
governmental power established in the
Constitution Bill of Rights adopted June
2nd 19
1784 acts 7 article 7 State sovereignty
says the people of the state have the
sole and exclusive right of governing
themselves as a free solvent and
independent state and do and forever
Hereafter shall exercise and enjoy every
Power jurisdiction and right pertaining
thereto which is not or may not
Hereafter be by them expressly delegated
to the United States of American
Congress in Congress assembled
so I believe government should have
minimal involvement in health care and
this bill is first step towards
socialized medicine as it seeks to
create a completely
government-controlled Health Care System
Beginning by creating an interstate
compact via the compact trust fund
additionally upon serious consideration
of section V 404-k
colon 4 it says eligibility
each beneficiary shall be issued
a compact health insurance card with a
unique identifying number and any other
relevant information the board or its
designated officers deem necessary
and
conceiving the same if finally armed
with the sanctions of an act will be a
dangerous abuse of power and a violation
of the limits of Government powers as
stated in the Bill of Rights
Article 2 Dash B right to privacy
it states that individual's right to
live free light an individual's right to
live free from governmental intrusion
and private and personal information as
natural and Central inherent
and a more consideration of the house
bill
pertaining
404-k colon 6 qualification of
participating practitioners or
facilities
as well as facilities shall also meet
quality and Licensing guidelines the
board or its designated officers May
from time to time deem necessary to
create
and I can see that same if finally armed
with the sanctions of an act will it be
a dangerous abuse of power and a
violations of the limits of government
power as stated in the constitution of
New Hampshire Bill of Rights adopted
June 2nd 9 1784.
article 12 protection and Taxation
reciprocal every member of the community
has a right to be protected by it in the
enjoyment of his life liberty and
property he is therefore bound to
contribute his share if the expense of
such protection and to yield his
personal service when necessary but no
part of a man's property shall be taken
from him or applied to public uses
without his consent or that of the
represented body of the people nor are
the inhabitants of the state
controllable by any of the laws than
those to which they or the
representative body have given their
consent
because the policy of this bill is
repugnant and important to the
constitution of New Hampshire's Bill of
Rights and a measure of such magnitude
and delicacy ought not to be imposed
without clear evidence it is the will of
the people to delegate these
governmental powers to non-elected board
members non-government organizations
Global health organizations which
provide participation guidelines
for the center for Medicare Medicaid
services is our hope that the
representatives of the counties will
espouse the dangerous principles of the
bill
furthermore investigation into the
privileges and immunities granted these
non-elected governmental organizations
should be investigated and revoked
and it might not seem like there's a
connection but anytime
anytime these
that says right here the facility shall
meet federal and state quality and
Licensing guidelines including those for
safe Staffing ratios and career these
facilities are beholden to Medicare
rules and regulations in order for
participation who's beholden to the
Center for Center for Disease Control
the World Health Organization and all
these other organizations so well it
looks like we have autonomy we do not we
are controlled by outside forces
non-governmental elected officials
great thank you very much and I hope
you're willing to share that testimony
to the clerk
you want a copy yes please
okay thank you I have one card left uh
Heather Stonewall
from Dublin
John okay all right uh and we don't have
the blue sheet so all right we will
close the public hearing on 353 and this
bill will be going to subcommittee
and with that I will break for lunch and
we'll be back here at 1 45.
foreign
okay we'll open up the public hearing on
House Bill 389 and hear from the
Prime sponsor representative I'm sorry
about the delay oh you're not the prime
oh okay she's surprised
all right
Emily Phillips
okay
sorry
all right
good afternoon uh we passed out some
copies
um for the committee
um on some backup on what I'll be
speaking about but the um
this uh legislation the purpose of it is
to require Health Care Facilities to
disclose prices for certain items and
services provided by certain medical
facilities
um in prohibit Collective action of debt
for non-compliant facilities there is a
federal law in place
um
and we're trying to hold hospitals
accountable for not complying with that
federal law
there are two states that have passed
similar legislation which I'm sure
someone else will speak on but uh this
law would further encourage compliance
by hospitals by preventing collection of
non-payment from patients if the
hospital is not in compliance with
transparency requirements
for too long the price of Health Care
at hospitals has been shrouded from
patients leaving them with unexpected
bills
long after they receive care the lack of
transparency leaves patients in the dark
and renders them unable to make informed
decisions about where and when to
receive care efforts to improve
transparency are bipartisan and aim to
increase consumer knowledge increase
competition and put downward pressure on
the prices of medical devices and
Services
I believe in a free market and I think
competition would be healthy here and if
it's all shrouded behind darkness and
the patients can't see prices then we
don't have that here Hospital compliance
with this rule since last year has been
subpar since it took effect last year
only 53 percent of hospitals in the U.S
disclosed any prices and an estimated 14
percent were in full compliance in your
attached packets we have
two recent articles that were published
this month saying that most hospitals
are not compliant I mean up upwards of
uh you know near 80 percent are not
complying with full price transparency
guidelines and then I have a specific to
our state in New Hampshire this
breakdown of hospitals that an
independent Group Patient rights
Advocate had pulled
um downloadable data on their websites
and they are not compliant you can see
you can go through them I actually
called for hospitals in my area from
Fremont and found that one out of
for we're compliant so it is a real
issue here so people want to shop online
and find prices for a shoppable service
like a knee replacement or a mammogram
colonoscopy and they're not able to get
the data that they're required to
provide through the federal law on a
personal level I am a type 1 diabetic so
I'm pretty familiar with navigating the
healthcare system to get quotes my son
needed to be sedated for a dental
procedure and I was quoted One Rate
through my dental insurance and then I
was quoted a rate somewhere between two
to three thousand dollars to have a one
hour procedure of sedation at a local
hospital
um this was in 2019 so it was before the
um federal law went into place but that
two to three thousand dollars became
twenty four thousand dollars
and that's what I was billed so and I
think I was pretty educated and I tried
to get all the information but they
surprised us and then they are allowed
to do out of pocket I'm sorry out of
network providers or they do the
anesthesia fee plus the facility fee
plus the or fee and it's very hard to
get information from these people so if
we had it all online My Hope Is that the
transparency would be there and I could
shop services and everyone else could
help reduce prices across the board
um
that's all I have I think is I'm open to
questions of course did we talk we
talked did I tell you we talk about the
insurance department has this available
I saw that there's a public website so
there are other states um Colorado who
has a nice
um a private provider of a website that
is more
um and all-encompassing and you can kind
of put in your insurance information and
all of that so I'm not sure nobody can
be better than ours I think privatizing
some things is better than uh case this
case we were able to gather the
information for
The Physician and the hospital so that
we could get so that when you look at
the price you can really see the total
price
of what that procedure will cost at any
given Hospital
so what you're saying is that what I
just presented is not true and they're
all compliant all the hospitals
um in terms of what the compliance
because I know we did talk about that
issue and I heard there was some uh
pushback in terms of what they're
tracking what they're trying so in this
case what I was telling you is
regardless of the hospital themselves
that the state of New Hampshire on its
Insurance Department's web page
you can go in and you can type in the
procedure that you want you know I'm
I have to do that Colin Haas could be
every five years so I do Leo type it in
and and see you know what the hospital
that I'm going to go to anyways to see
what they're going to charge and and and
uh and I actually tested this last time
just match up when I got billed by my
insurance company to see if the dollar
amounts followed and they did so uh we
actually do it and so it's not as much
as that we're regulating the hospitals
we were able to get the hospitals to
generate that information with the
Physicians we can really see the whole
cost analysis for each individual
hospital for any or I wouldn't say any
procedure but for the vast majority of
procedures through which people use
and I don't think I told you that when
we were talking well the the
persuasion is to prove to prevent
Hospital
with collecting debt
so collecting debt so if they are
compliant there's no penalty to any
Hospital who is compliant with the
federal law so what you're saying may be
true in your situation but if there is a
hospital which according to mid-year of
last year there's plenty that are not
compliant with the current federal law
so yeah actually my Hospital said it was
non-compliant you said you're on that
list had my hospital is non-compliant
right but I but I absolutely was able to
get the information from the insurance
department
okay what if we're self-pay what if I
don't have insurance you can still look
that's actually what the numbers are it
would have been the self-pay number it
would have been that it's because
obviously with your insurance company
you then have a lower
payment so in my case because it was a
colonoscopy that I was looking at
colonoscopies uh are free because uh
they're preventative medicine so uh but
it's still I was I wanted to see that
dollar amount to see if it really
carried over and it did carry over but
um
so is there a question or no no I'm just
saying would you believe yeah would you
believe there is a way you can do this
through our insurance department
I I believe that this is a real issue
affecting Granite Staters and I think
that the hospitals in the Granite State
Should comply with the federal law and
there should be a consequence if they
don't
gotcha and that's what this is okay
representative filo
as I understand that from reviewing the
proposal there is no enforcement
mechanism through the statute we're a
hospital to Bill
nothing happens according to the statute
what enforcement mechanism do you
envision as occurring as a result of a
hospital violating the statute
so as it's written now it would not be
collectible they could not take a
patient to court to collections or
pursue any collection activity
but so yeah so the penalty is that you
don't have to pay the bill
for the question as a follow-up
and then if they do what happens there
needs to be an enforcement mechanism for
somebody who breaks the law
foreign
if if the committee is interested we
have a pre-written amendment that would
allow DHHS to find hospitals for
non-compliance
so it would go into the general fund and
they could set their own you like that
yes okay so we have we haven't answered
his question yes so we have an amendment
drafted
um I can pass that around maybe
because like I said Colorado and Texas
had similar legislation pass and I think
there's others in draft right now but uh
it is
you know nice to have some Revenue
stream for especially hospitals who
continue to not comply per day or what
have you in the amendment I believe
there is a no there isn't okay we're
gonna allow DHHS to set their own
um penalties whether it be a thousand
dollars a day or what have you
um
there is a corrective Action Program
a plan to be submitted if they're found
to be non-compliant so in this example
the patient would report it to DHHS that
this hospital did not
comply with the price transparency laws
on this date and offered me services and
now they're trying to collect
and then
the rest of the amendment would
show that all right representative Terry
as sometimes uh is the case I'm confused
so I would appreciate if you could
clarify
uh perhaps by explaining uh what
non-compliance means because what I have
heard
is Chairman indicating that he was able
to go on the State Insurance website and
find the cost for a procedure at a
particular Hospital which in fact turned
out to be the cost for that procedure
and yet the hospital is listed as being
non-compliant is that what I heard and
if I did could you explain how the
hospital could be non-compliant if at
the root of this is the requirement to
post prices for procedures and the
chairman indicated that he was able to
find the price for the procedure at the
hospital that is identified as
non-compliant thank you
I'll try to unwrap that so
um the final rule the federal law uh
required hospitals to publish machine
readable file of five types of standard
charges for all items and services and a
create a consumer-friendly shoppable
list of 300 items and services included
including 70 identified by CMS centers
for Medicaid and Medicaid services so
um there are certain levels there's
people who are partially compliant
they're doing some of it
um you know user-friendly machine
readable available those are all terms
that are defined
um in I don't think I've provided that
that documentation with it
oh in the amen and the amendment and the
amendment
um so
there's a good explanation on this chart
for the New Hampshire of why they were
found to be non-compliant like the files
were not broken down into the three you
know private pay cash pay or Medicaid
charges that sort of thing so um I'm not
sure I can't speak to repon's experience
as to why it worked for him it is a real
issue I don't I guess what he's asking
is who is the judge
who is the determinant that they're in
non-compliant
well actually no that's that's not your
question I'd be happy to hear the answer
to that question and then if you'd give
me a follow-up I will clarify
for the question you may inquire do you
want your answer no no I'm okay you're
going where you're going so is it
possible that we have different
standards here such that the hospital
was able to meet the state standard and
and and be in compliance by posting the
prices to the State Insurance
Department's website but it was not in
compliance with the different Federal
standards for compliance it may be
possible I'm not familiar with the state
insurance page that he spoke about
um I do not I'm not an expert on that so
I don't know what they provide okay
thank you but um the person who
determined whether someone would be in
compliance would be a a judge if the
person was brought to collections in
court okay and then in the amendment
DHHS would be the one to determine
whether or not they complied
thank you
okay representative
I would this be a administrative action
or would this be a legal action I think
you mean this would be an administrative
action correct
correct administrative
okay representative Walsh
thank you Mr chairman
provided this as well I'm just I opened
it and it's talking about uh leopard
battle tanks to the Ukraine really
and it sure it sure is now and and
something about Republicans in the
Senate and so I was just wondering what
what happened it's a bit of a
non-secretory I apologize but I just
wondered what happened
I'll have to I will send the committee
the copy of the article I sent it
upstairs to have them print all these
copies and this is what happened so
um when you let the government do things
now okay okay I need a tank for my
Hospital
yeah but they were great recent articles
supporting the fact or reinforcing the
idea that hospitals are not complying
with this a year later and it's all over
the country it's not just here right
okay so there's a Forbes article in an
axios article but I will get the link
since that would be great committee
representative Sullivan
thank you Mr chair
um so
I guess I actually have two questions
but the first one would be so you said
that it would be up to the judge to
decide whether or not they're in
compliance does that mean like I get a
bill from
whatever hospital and I I can just not
pay it and then go see if maybe they're
not compliant by going to court is that
is that really the mechanism by which
this would be enforced
I don't I don't know about that no I
mean
okay so you said earlier that the person
who would be in charge of deciding
whether or not somebody was in
compliance because we don't seem to have
like a an authority here in the state so
if and the FEDS apparently don't have a
way of enforcing it so
if if I get a bill from Littleton
Hospital is the one that would be close
to me
I can just say well I don't know if
they're in compliance I'm going to just
not pay go to court and see what the
judge says like is that is that really
how how it would work like how how do
you see it working if that's not how it
works my interpretation would be that
could work that way yes okay because it
is up to the judge yes okay and then my
for the question
um my other question is
um this is more just a clarification of
maybe the federal law that you probably
know better than I do but does this
apply to just hospitals or like if I'm
gonna
go get a colonoscopy from the local
colonoscopy Clinic do they also have to
put this all online or is this just
affecting hospitals specifically it says
facility so I'm not really sure if
that's what defines a hospital versus a
like a day surgery Place type of thing
okay yeah I think it would be
um maybe um the expert is going to speak
about it would know better but I think
it's facilities that could include a day
surgery okay thank you
represent Ammon
thank you Mr chair I thank you for your
testimony
um
could you help me understand the term
material compliance
um so to me
uh one layer is uh that the information
is available and then the second layer
would be is it accurate you know is it
up to date so how are you thinking about
material compliance and Does it include
the information being accurate and
current
and and how is that uh checked
um you're referring to the amendment did
you read that portion or no the
amendment um I defines material
compliance means information regarding
the cost of items or Services provided
by a hospital must be available as a
comprehensive machine readable file with
all items and services listed and as a
display of shoppable services in a
consumer-friendly format
so that gets to follow please that gets
to the question of is it available but
not is it current and accurate
um what was your thinking on that aspect
as far as how much like time you would
allow for them to update prices that
sort of question how do you know that
the price is accurate
uh that the information is accurate
I don't know I mean I assume if they
bill that price that they had on the
website on that day then that would be
accurate
I think what he's getting at is saying
is that to be compliant with your
statute is they could just put anything
up and as long as they dotted their eyes
and crossed their T's
then they'd be in compliance even though
the information there's no actual tests
to see if the information is correct
or accurate
so they would put any price
they we would assume they wouldn't just
wing it right they would they would make
a college try at the number but that but
that there's no accountability you're
the bill is not about accountability
that the numbers are accurate that this
bill is really all about is did you die
are you in compliance with the federal
did you dot your eyes cross your t's and
that's all we care about we don't really
care whether the information is actually
accurate if the transparency is just
that it's going to breed competition and
people are going to shop elsewhere so if
they're putting in a price and someone
can find a less expensive price or they
that they can compare apples to apples I
feel like they're not doing themselves
any good by
I guess that's what I'm following if
everyone was complying then you could
shop for a colonoscopy right at all the
services and you're going to go most
likely with a lower cost provider
so that's the incentive is that you
breed competition
and that people will go to the provider
who has a usable
format
so but is there any part of this bill
that then says uh that if it wasn't to
the penny if it wasn't that they
accurate in other words when they
actually did get billed
and it was a different dollar amount
does the still the department then have
to uh be or be responsible for finding
them because it turns out the dollar
amount was wrong it's an option to find
them if they so choose but if they're
not they're not complying if they're off
by a penny that's correct like because
they quoted the price is supposed to be
transparent right so they're supposed to
be billing what they're posting that's
the whole point of transparency got it I
think that was what the question was are
you a representative Terry are you still
so historical accurate means that it's
in the best interest of the institution
to update
its numbers with its current prices of
course especially if they go up
yes
right the example you gave was with
respect to competition and uh it's in
the best interest of the hospital
presumably therefore to have it uh it's
uh the lowest price possible
conceivably because we're not dealing
necessarily with current we were asking
about current and accurate you could
actually have a price on there it would
make a whole lot of sense but it could
be artificially low in which case they
would be held to that price
right what they post is what they should
charge that's how you comply should or
must
complying is a must thank you okay
you all set
thank you thank you all right uh now
Josh
thank you chairman for the record my
name is representative yokella
um from Rockingham 32 Fremont Danville
and Brentwood
um so the
the main thing in this uh
this bill is to ensure that if they were
if you get a quote
um for you know uh if if you go online
and you see that the Bills should be 500
and they try and charge you twelve
thousand dollars you should be able to
go to court and say hey this is
this is not the amount that I was I
agreed to because part of this
um transparency is is just like if you
go to the grocery store and they put the
price of five dollars on on the carton
of milk if they go up to the if you go
up to the cash register saying they try
and charge you 25 that is not
appropriate right and so just like that
that is no different than than this if
they post the amount of 25 for your
surgery then they should be held to that
just like any other business in this
state and so
um I think that I think that that is
what they would be held to irrespective
of this law I think if they post the the
amount
that this is just getting them to post
the amount right now a lot of times you
go in and you don't necessarily know the
amount and my understanding is that the
um the amounts on the the uh
the insurance website is estimates they
are not
um binding to those providers is my my
understanding
but um that is
so this would actually be binding
um is my understanding of the current
law and so
um also
it it uh
I think that
it's possible that some of the the
things that are currently posted this
may be uh what the federal government
are requiring may be a broader
um amount of of things to be posted
and
um I think that
we we pass around this amendment that
that gives the option for for if the
committee so chooses to to empower the
DHHS when a person complains instead of
as the representative suggested instead
of just not paying the bill and waiting
to go to court that they could
preemptively go to DHHS and file a
complaint and say this place is not in
compliance and then DHHS would make a
determination and so that you wouldn't
have to wait to go through that court
process and it and so we're kind of
giving
uh the committee the option to go with
either situation the situation where you
go to court
um
and uh you use this as a defense that
they were not in compliance and you
should not be held to to pay for a bill
that you didn't know how much it was
when you were getting the services
rendered
um
that is one way to address the issue and
and it's my understanding that in
Colorado that
um sends the the the bill is passed the
sentiment is that when people reference
the law and say that they're not going
to pay it because because it's against
the law then the the uh the facilities
will actually just
um just not try and collect because they
know that they will lose in court and so
that is that is um
um my
knowledge about what the the sentiment
is since the then since the law passed
also
um I wanted to
um just give my personal experience as
far as as being someone that had to go
to uh the emergency room and wanted to
to kind of make informative choices
about what the bill like what I was
accepting and what I was not accepting
um and and under the current
transparency or price
um
uh
structure that we have now you can
request the information from the
hospitals but it takes multiple days and
multiple phone calls to actually get
what the price will be
um like a hard quote for your procedure
and I was not able to do that when I was
in the emergency room but later for a
recommended outpatient procedure I did
make multiple calls to multiple
um
facilities and and
providers to get those numbers and it
took probably a week to get competitive
bids whereas once this is transparent
there's already people that are um
bringing these machine readable formats
into an app that you can then just pull
up on your phone very quickly and be
able to compare and so the
um I think that from a consumer uh
standpoint you're going to be able to
essentially compare Real Time with being
able or having to do it now with
multiple days of calling and tracking
down to get an exact quote so thank you
for for
testimony and I'm here here to answer
questions Representative Vincent
thank you Mr chairman
uh what you're referring to in your
example was called bait switch in the
retail business which is illegal but and
I'm not assuming that
um that or saying that the hospitals are
doing this however my question is
um
do you know if the hospitals actually
put when they put those prices on there
revise at a certain date sometimes
they'll put like a thing that says
revised on this date
meaning and I'm not saying they haven't
they still need to comply with federal
law right but do you know if they do
that to let the consumer know that hey
uh we revised this two days ago and it
could change
thank you for the question
um I'm going to refrain from answering
because I don't know the exact thank you
um like the price as of this date and
then prices of this date kind of a thing
I'm I'm not 100 sure so
I will hopefully there's an expert with
more more uh knowledge that we'll be
able to answer that question thank you
thank you representative Terry has a
question so are you aware of what the
penalties are at the federal level for
not complying with the federal
regulations
thank you for the question
um the penalties were
um there's obviously there's going to be
someone here that testifies that knows
more intimately than me but my
understanding is that the penalties were
recently raised to around two million
dollars but the um
uh the department
decided to not really enforce
any of that this is a
um
this kind of law stemmed from
a previous president's executive order
and the current president's
um
did not rescind it but is not
necessarily enforcing
um it is in Thoroughly as we would like
to see so this is an another way of
enforcing that
thinking
representative Gibbs thank you
um
as I understand it the postings required
under federal law are provided in New
Hampshire on the insurance department
website
um do you know and and I'm going to ask
a question and then just give you a one
sentence explanation of why I'm asking
um do you know if there are any
limitations on the types of procedures
uh
for which the costs are required to be
posted on the insurance website and the
reason that I ask is that never having
heard about this uh provision of the New
Hampshire insurance department uh
previous to it being discussed here
um I used my iPad to check on it and
found no listings for inpatient
surgeries so are there some types do you
know whether there are some types of
procedures that must be posted where the
cost must be posted and others where
they're not required to post them
thank you for the question I am not
familiar with the list of things that
need to be posted in which things are
not not required to be posted so I
wouldn't be able to answer that question
for you thank you
sorry thank you very much
uh chair uh well let's go let's do it
Paul Paul manahan represent New
Hampshire Hospital Association who uh is
opposed to the bill
okay
I think I counted right but if you need
more copies please let me know I have
some
and good afternoon Mr chairman members
of the committee for the record my name
is Paula minnahan Senior vice president
state government relations for the New
Hampshire Hospital Association
representing all our hospitals we are
opposed to House Bill 389 there's a lot
to unpack here and I will try to answer
any questions that you have
um but I'm going to actually jump to the
attachment and so that's why I really
want to make sure everyone has a copy of
my testimony
the sponsors referenced that advocacy
Group Patient rights Advocate and I
think it's just really important that we
talk about that first because the no
surprises Act was passed in January 21
January 1 2021 it does require that the
hospitals follow the the law which I
will emphatically state New Hampshire
hospitals do in fact the
um the the government does audit the
hospitals in nationally there are two
hospitals I repeat two hospitals
nationally there are over four thousand
hospitals in the country two two were
found out of compliance not any in New
Hampshire so I just want to make that
emphatic statement
um in and back in last summer you will
see there's a letter that is attached to
attorney general formula from Steve on
and the president of the association
um and this I will not read it for you
but it does um New Hampshire hospitals
and attorney general from Ella as well
as the commissioner of insurance and I
don't know who else but um we're copied
on these emails from this patient rights
Advocate Group making misleading and um
inappropriate statements relative to the
compliance of New Hampshire hospitals we
take this very seriously we looked into
this and we wanted to clarify working
with our partners at the AHA American
Hospital Association as well as HHS and
again two hospitals throughout the
entire country they are not New
Hampshire hospitals I want to reassure
you are not out of compliance
um in fact most the vast majority of our
hospitals around the country are not
they are following the law it was put in
place in January of 21 so keep that in
mind too there are many Provisions that
are implemented um and it is actually
um it was passed um Senator Hassan was
uh our Senator was very instrumental in
getting this law passed so
um I was I'm a little confused about
that statement um about a prior
Administration
um the current Administration is in is
following this um requirement in fact
the second chart
um shows the hospital transparency rules
that were the criteria used by this
Advocate Group versus the CMS
requirements and it is pretty clear that
the criteria do not match what the CMS
requirements are so any report that is
done by the by a group that is not using
the same criteria will result in a
different outcome and that that is just
a fact so I just wanted to clarify that
and again we are opposed to this for
many reasons we do take this very
seriously and our hospitals are in
compliance to have something at a state
level and I understand this advocacy
group is my understanding there is um
there is kind of model legislation being
shopped around the country
um that is not what New Hampshire
typically does New Hampshire wants um to
do what New Hampshire needs to do for
their for their residents
um the the federal law is com is complex
they do have a requirement to have
machine readable charges on their
website and again the hospitals do this
we routinely double check with them they
are they have compliance officers they
have revenue cycle folks they have
um Chief Financial officers CEOs the
board they take this very seriously I
just want to reassure you to add more
complexity to this by adding references
to let me find that bill because it's I
find it I found it very confusing and I
a number of you have already picked up
on this what material compliance
according to who
and what what what is the this for a
balanced bill would go to court that
just um that just seems um really adding
a lot of complexity to an already very
complex system as you all know
um because of anyone that um because you
follow insurance law and Health Care is
very complicated
um so we are concerned about having
inconsistencies with a federal law and a
state law and the penalty is significant
again I you just heard what the federal
penalty is that's pretty staggering um
and then to have HHS then has our DHHS
would then have to promulgate rules to
have additional penalties seems really
excessive and not appropriate again our
hospitals are complying with the with
the law and I I do I agree with the
chair
um our health cost website that the
department of insurance I think are here
and they can they can talk about this
very um good it's called
healthcost.org I believe it is a very
good website it has been in development
it is considered a model for other
states they've tried to come they've
tried to actually
do exactly what New Hampshire did to
some some different degrees of Success
New Hampshire is very proud of their
health cost website it does not have
everything there are reasons why it does
not have everything privacy is really
important and the department can
certainly address that but between the
insurers that they have a lot of
information on their websites hospitals
have a lot of information on their
websites and the department of insurance
we believe that there are many
opportunities to to seek this
information I also wanted to clarify
getting a quote from a hospital has been
something that you can you have been
able to do it is not easy you certainly
can't do it in the middle of an
emergency room but hospitals have done
that that is different than posting your
charges getting a quote for a total knee
replacement is not going to be something
that you can look up on a website I'm
happy to answer any questions
um thank you
uh yep represent a post
can folks just go to their
Insurance surgery or whatever
I believe they're in the insurers are
here and they can answer that I know
um my insurance company I can do that um
because what is you because they the
insurer knows what your did if you've
met your deductible or not um and how
much um if you've met you're out of
pocket Etc so I I know that many
insurers do have really robust tools
um to but as far as being able to I
believe that they can
um I usually use it to just see what my
deductible out of pocket is that kind of
thing yeah but the problem was that the
the insurance company will can know what
the hospital cost is but they might not
know what the physician or the
anesthesiologist exactly which are the
other two and that was the benefit of
the state plan was to try to merge all
those right together you're right you're
right okay representative Gibbs thank
you
um I'm going to ask you the same
question that I asked the uh previous
person who testified and that is do you
know if there are any limitations as to
what hospitals are required to post on
the New Hampshire Insurance department's
website and again the reason that I ask
is because I decided to check it to see
how it worked and I could find no
um category at all for inpatient uh
surgery there was a reason why we don't
provide that information the hospitals
don't provide that information and again
there are experts here from the
Department that can explain there are
criteria how they I think there's
actually information on their website
that explains where they get that
information it's the Comprehensive
Health Information
um
yeah we don't provide the hospitals
don't provide so what I've done is just
now is ask the insurance department and
when we take up this bill and
subcommittee that they will be prepared
to make a presentation so bring your
iPad on February 1st and they can walk
us through it so we positively will
thank you and also um if you have a few
minutes afterward
um and uh we should just talk about this
just for a moment I'd appreciate it no
problem okay
yes representative Sullivan
thank you Mr chair
um so it seems to me as I read the bill
that the Bill's intention is to just
make sure that hospitals are in
compliance so if you're all in compliant
what is the concern about this bill I
mean you cite a lot of things like
conflicting standards but it seems to me
that the standard is to be in compliant
with the federal law you guys are all in
compliance so if that's true hey you
have nothing to worry about in B it only
becomes a problem if somebody becomes
not compliant with the federal standard
so I'm just trying to figure out why you
have such strong opposition to it
because a couple reasons why one is
there is a federal law that addresses
this to um the um the new language has
to do with collection action and this
idea of medical of material compliance
when you and there are hospitals
um that um that would find if you have a
state a state law that is not consistent
with a federal law that is very
confusing to them um so that would like
which one applies and um and so that is
our concern that they follow the federal
law um and the and the HHS at the
federal level is responsible for
auditing so that is our concern that
this is redundant and not necessary in
our opinion
double jeopardy
representative
thank you Mr chair thank you for your
testimony sure I'm just looking at this
letter that you sent to the attorney
general yep
um June 16th last year
um the last paragraph it says there's
352 notices by CMS that went out
and then it says half of those are now
in compliance while the other the other
half assuming it means that the other
the others are working to be compliant
so that that's about 175.76
hospitals that are working to be
compliant and my question is are any of
those in New Hampshire and it sounds
like you're saying no no no no no no
okay yeah this was information that we
got at a national level
thank you yep
any questions all set thank you thank
you I got one card left Patrick Neville
who's in support of the bill
good afternoon
good afternoon Mr chair and committee
thank you for hearing me um I come from
Colorado and actually passed a similar
bill here or there on this topic and so
we have a thing in Colorado called term
and wits and I think it's so now I'm
officially in recovery stage of being a
politician and this is part of my
therapy to come and speak to you so
thanks for the three three therapy
but so I want to break this down into
how this bill actually works and there's
some pieces in the amendment that
Colorado doesn't have I wish they would
add that's good but I like to break it
down into basically two different
buckets so you've got your state agency
enforcement and then you have your
consumer protection provisions and the
bill was originally drafted mostly with
those consumer protection Provisions in
mind and that's exactly what we did in
Colorado
so this bill is based entirely on the
federal rule so it's not creating a new
separate standard of rules it's just
making sure they comply by the federal
rules and then rather than the federal
government
instituting it and enforcing it the
state has the ability to do that as well
and I think the state can probably react
a lot quicker than the federal
government and I know my circumstance
even though I'm in a very blue State and
I'm a very red person full disclosure
and when I did run this bill by the way
I ran it with someone on the other side
of the aisle who we probably never
agreed on in eight years of serving
together and we got it done 99 to one so
it's a very bipartisan issue but it
allows the state agency to actually
enforce it but the beauty about the
consumer protection piece is is if a
consumer is actually affected and the
hospital does not comply by this it
doesn't help that individual consumer
to have the government issue a fine
and so what's happening in Colorado this
bill went into effect August 10th and
what's happening is I'll give you an
example there was a patient out there
who got a quote
was given a price by the hospital 1300
out of pocket
for a hysterectomy retired school
teacher
two weeks after the after the surgery
they say no the insurance declined it
here's your bill for eighty thousand
dollars
well the bill creates an affirmative
defense so if the hospital tries to send
her to collections or sue her in court
she now has an affirmative defense
so this bill's been in effect since
August 10th in Colorado we haven't seen
one lawsuit because what's happening is
they turn around and say we have this
law
we're going to use it and then the
hospital says okay we agree
pay the 1300 and we'll call it even
and so I think what's happening in the
um
I did a little bit of research on the
New Hampshire
and New Hampshire's
database is based on the all play all
claims payer data which is past
historical data that can be accurate so
Mr chairman in your case it might have
been very accurate but it's not always
accurate so this bill would ensure that
the prices that are posted must be
accurate and if they're not
the state agency then can enforce it and
then the consumer if they're actually
violated by this they have an
enforcement mechanism as well
and I think what's really exciting about
this in Colorado
is now we have Tech developers that are
coming together and putting together
some really usable platforms for
consumers that can give all sorts of
options so even if you have insurance
coverage and it's a high deductible plan
you can find other out of network cash
prices for a much less can be sometimes
up to 40 percent than the lowest
negotiated insurance Price so it helps
those people on those High deductible
plans it's not necessarily Insurance
related and it's starting to bring down
the cost and these Tech developers are
going to the point where they're even
starting to geo-fence hospitals so
hospitals
you can come in and you'll get a text
and it'll say if this is a true
emergency don't let it slow you down but
if you want to speak to someone right
now
click this link it'll pop them into a
link you can speak to a medical
professional right away and they can
tell you
okay it's going to be a three thousand
dollar bill if you go into the hospital
for this but you can go to an Urgent
Care 1.2 miles away and it's going to be
a 600 bill
and so it's a very powerful tool for
consumers and then now we're actually
starting to see competition and that's
truly what I love about this is once you
actually get price competition into a
market that's 20 of our national economy
we're going to significantly lower
prices and help consumers out
and with that I'm open for any questions
welcome to New Hampshire yes we could
have used them yesterday so uh under New
Hampshire law the Consumer Protection
Law would be in effect hospitals are not
exempt from consumer protection
and yes if they quoted you a misquoted
price
you could absolutely go to court and in
under New Hampshire law you can get your
legal fees paid and you can even get
Triple damages
so that's current law
do we need this bill
Mr chairman I would say that this
evening strengthens it even more because
it actually defines it Shores it up says
exactly what's happening if in this
specific circumstance
and like I mentioned too in Colorado the
beauty about this is with this law
we haven't even seen any lawsuits we're
seeing hospitals first off coming into
compliance more
second off the consumers that are
actually violated the hospital says
we're going to honor that original deal
that we quoted you on yeah I mean in New
Hampshire you would just call up a
lawyer and have the lawyer make the call
and say we're going to exercise our
rights on the consumer protection act
you know you misquoted the price and
theoretically the hospital would refund
the money
no no well you're still using a lawyer
even with this bill I mean your health
and human services is you know they're
going to have a hearing on the case so I
I guess uh uh the question is is
my fear is this bill is all about not
paying a bill
that if that you're using it it's
getting used and I think representative
Sullivan asked the question is it is
that is it the real intent is that you
just don't want to pay the bill
and that you're using this federal
statute as a as a say well look see you
didn't do it right or you didn't quote
right you didn't do that so I don't have
to pay the bill
have you seen that happen in Colorado no
and in fact Mr chairman it's been the
exact opposite so the bill like I
mentioned has been in effect since
August 10th and what we're more likely
seeing is that when there's a bill
discrepancy the exact opposite happens
the hospital realizes they're going to
lose in court if the patient takes it
any further they go back on their
original their original deal or they go
back to the original deal honor the
original deal and then the patient then
pays that original price they were given
and it's a price I mean that's one of
the things that I want to get into
that's that we need to make more clear
in the healthcare industry a price is
not always a quote a quote's not always
a price an estimate's not always a price
and I think consumers want the price
that it's going to be okay sounds great
oh representative Harry thank you
so I'm intrigued by your mention that
someone
could presumably it's an app go on their
phone
and see that if they went into the
emergency room for a procedure would be
three thousand dollars but if they went
to the Urgent Care it was six hundred
dollars
I don't think we have any such tool
available to us here in New Hampshire if
we do I would appreciate somebody
telling me before I leave today
um but would you would you address the
question if you believe that the law
that you say went into effect in
Colorado on August 10th was had anything
to do with this tool being made
available to the consumers to the
residents in the state of Colorado is
there any kind of cause and effect
relationship or is the tool that you're
mentioned that you mentioned something
that's just somewhat independent of the
law that was passed
yes uh representative thanks for the
question I think they are connected
because one of the things the tool is
actually doing as well is they're
cataloging cataloging that data from all
the hospitals daily
and then they actually can see whether
or not the hospital is compliant on the
date of the service what the hospital's
price was posted on that day so then if
the patient then gets a different bill
for a separate amount than what they
actually had logged on the date of
service then they can help the patient
then fight that discrepancy in the bill
representative post
so what was your fiscal note what
did you have to have an agency take care
of this on it
certain level
so unfortunately representative in
Colorado we didn't do the state agency
enforcement I think it's a yes and
conversation here not an either or we
just did the consumer protection so we
did not have a fiscal note on that there
was no fiscal note now imagine there
probably would be with the state agency
enforcement I don't know if that would
be positive or negative as we've seen
with the White House they've raised the
the fines up to two million dollars
however they have chosen not to they
actually issue Discretions or issued
orders out there saying we're not going
to enforce this indefinitely so while
they raise the fines they haven't as we
heard there's only been two fines issued
but there's we know there's more
hospitals out of compliance than that
and so it's hard to parse what the
fiscal note would be but in Colorado in
our circumstance we did not have one
for the question main car
yes so the other part of that is
um
who are the people that are
um doing these new systems where you
know is that something that is being
paid is the healthcare industry doing
that is it people doing it on their own
are they different companies and who's
paying for that
thank you for the question
representative it's private individuals
that actually see a business opportunity
once the data is actually posted they
can use utilize that data and what we're
seeing a lot of too is it's not just
individual patients that are using this
but employers are taking advantage of
this in a big way because employers can
start looking at what they're paying in
their true prices they're paying to the
hospitals and actually negotiate better
rates negotiate better rates with their
insurance companies once they actually
have that information and so oftentimes
the tech developers are actually selling
this to employers as well so employers
can access it and actually see what
they're paying because problem is a lot
of employers especially small employers
want to we'll want to ensure their
employees but they don't actually know
what the out-of-pocket cost is once they
have all this data the tech developers
can sparse that for them and actually
show them that yes you have insurance
and you're you're you can move to a
better insurance plan that's actually
going to cover less out of pocket
for your employee or if you've got an
employee that's got a very specific
issue that maybe there's another
insurance carrier that has lower cost
for that the employer can then move it
to there and it makes it much easier for
them to do it and it's all being done by
private Tech Developers
so they're also tracking the insurance
reimbursement and insurance Price rather
than the hospital because I assume this
was just the rack price for the hospital
you know they actually tracking the
individual insurance
reimbursement for that bill a hospital I
mean because most hospitals have no idea
what the dollar amounts are going to be
they track so under the federal rule
that's actually another thing that
that's not really separate to this bill
but under there's another Federal rule
that requires the all claims payer data
so they can actually pair that up and
then the employers can actually see this
is what the hospital's posted price was
and this is what my insurance actually
reimbursed and match those two up
wow we like to see that
okay
thank you very much thank you Mr chair
and committee I have no more cards
so we will close the public hearing
and move on to the next one
because this is me
do you want to distance yeah
pretty soon
okay we'll open the hearing on House
Bill 613
who's got the wipes
who took off with the uh the wipes they
were there earlier today I saw him
and uh just the time check we're an hour
behind schedule so
I will be
very brief uh this is okay I forget the
form so this is a legislation uh we will
call it a housekeeping and it's uh
submitted by the insurance department
and so my name is on it because
um I I think I was in the room where
most of these things got passed in the
first place
but otherwise uh I will let the
department introduce uh and explain all
the different sections of the bill
okay and
did you guys submit cards for the
testimony
yes okay they're here somewhere
so if you just introduce yourself for
the record
good afternoon I'm Heather Silverstein
I'm general counsel of the New Hampshire
insurance department
and I'm Alex felvin examiner for the
um this bill HP 613 it is truly a
cleanup bill it's a um uh it relates to
RSA 404g which is with the individual
health market
uh this was originally acted that
statute was really originally acted in
1998 it created a non-profit then
Hampshire health plan with the purpose
of making
um health insurance more available and
also to establish a mandatory risk
sharing plan with regard to the
individual Market
um we have been working with the New
Hampshire health plan to make these they
helped us with this bill because what
happens is with any type of legislation
you you put things in changes happen
programs change and then several years
down the road there's things in the
statute that have become Obsolete and it
makes it confusing if you're just
picking it up Anew I encountered that
I've been at the department since 2015.
there was a couple of years ago when
Alex was my supervisor as deputy and I
was General Counsel and I was trying to
help him write an order and I didn't
understand why there was a mention of
all these other programs that no longer
applied you know I I as an attorney
particularly one I used to I started my
career working out for working for
judges as a law clerk like I didn't
understand why there was mention of
these sorts of programs and should I be
somehow concerned with that and luckily
Alex was is a great historian as to all
of these programs that have been you
used as to how to um help share risk
with this this particular Market So This
truly is we went through we with the New
Hampshire Health Plan
and helped change the definitions
and remove any terms that were no longer
needed you know in the past a couple of
programs you'll often see through the
statute the high risk pool there was a
state high-risk pool there was a federal
high-risk pool those are no longer
applicable you may have heard of the
1332 waiver program that is currently in
play and that is something that the New
Hampshire Health Plan does administer
for us so
we have tried to do the best that we can
to clean up the definitions get rid of
what is not needed and just
make make it better you know
if you have any questions
um I may be able to help and Alex
definitely like I said he's a great
historian for all of the things that
happened in the past with regard to this
Market
any questions
I have a quick question okay
representative I'm sorry I'm not that
familiar with some of the terminology so
the new New Hampshire health plan is
it's a
non-profit quasi-governmental entity
that is set up by Statute by this very
statute and its operations are overseen
by the insurance commissioner through an
approval process they develop a plan of
operation which the for executing the
programs that they're statutorily
responsible for implementing and the
commissioner approves that plan of
operation
so that's how it's existed that way
since the initial creation quick
follow-up so uh give me an example of
the pro
thank you for asking that
um just a little context
um would help to explain it the
individual health insurance Market is
different from the group markets the
small group and large group in an
important way
for group coverage you have this
phenomenon where you get a group of
people together for reasons other than
buying health insurance they're together
because they're working for their
employer and so you inherently get a
coverage group that isn't necessarily
high risk from a health insurance
perspective
in the individual Market you have people
buying coverage one by one because they
want it and they're more likely to be
high risk individuals
for that reason this Market has always
been unstable in New Hampshire and in
other states as well
so originally in order to
keep the market
vital and competitive the first program
that was set up was called a risk
subsidy mechanism whereby all
insurers group and individual offering
coverage in the state were assessed a
small amount and that funding was used
to pay for some of the excess risk in
the individual Market
so that was the risk subsidy mechanism
and then came the high-risk pool which
is a different way of doing it
where you don't require the carriers in
individual Market to accept everyone
but you do require that there be a
source of coverage for people who are
high risk and that that has to be
subsidized
so we had that we had risk subsidy
mechanism in the hybris pool and
today we have a reinsurance mechanism
which essentially does the same sort of
thing it pays for some of the excess
risk in the individual market so the
premiums can be affordable
everything
okay
any other questions for
our guests
I was seeing none thank you very much uh
I don't have any more cards for 389 was
there anybody else that would like to
testify on this bill I'm sorry yeah 6
13.
or 389 but 6 13.
all right well I don't see any close to
hearing thank you and then we'll open
the hearing on 4 14.
and now we're 55 minutes behind schedule
so we we gained five minutes
thank you
so open the hearing
414.
um
just get my bearings here uh
representative Thomas yes and you
support the bill
I'm introducing them they're introducing
the bill all right so I do to answer
your question yes I do support it
before I get started I um there I I'm
going to make reference to a document
it's 300 pages long and I've emailed it
to each of you instead of making copies
of it the other thing is that I've
recently lost a tooth implant so I have
a wee bit of a lisp I've emailed you my
testimony as well in case you can't
understand me for some reason
could you just just state your name for
the record yes
um
greetings Mr chair and members of the
Commerce and consumer affairs committee
for the record I am representative Wendy
Thomas representing the town of
Merrimack
I come before you to introduce HB for
414 relative to health insurance
coverage for preventive pfas care
this bill came about due to a few
reasons some personal
recently I was diagnosed with breast
cancer I have no history of breast
cancer in my family
I had genetic testing and the 13 genes
they tested me for were all negative I
did not have those genetic mutations
on the advice of the environmental
working group I had my blood tested for
40 pfas chemicals by the laboratory
eurofins
it turns out I have 12 pfas chemicals in
my body that are over the toxic limit
for humans
my total pfas chemicals are 38 times
over the national average
P fast chemical exposure has been linked
to breast cancer
because of this I opted for a double
mastectomy
I have more total pfoa in my body than
99 of Americans do
pfoa chemicals have been linked to
ovarian and fallopian tube cancer
based on this information the
oncologists I saw at Dartmouth Hitchcock
Lebanon felt it was prudent to
preventively remove my ovaries and
fallopian tubes
initially this surgery was denied it
took several hours on the phone and my
doctor recoding the surgery for it
finally to be approved
because I have gone public with my
cancer story in our town a young woman
contacted me she is the daughter of a
mom with breast cancer
when she had an abnormality with her
breast she was referred to a breast
clinic
they examined her and told her that she
had dense breast tissue when she asked
about a mammogram she was told that she
didn't qualify because she was 24 and
they quote don't offer mammograms until
you are 29.
for a young woman who has known pfas
contamination waiting five years for a
mammogram might be a death sentence
the science of pfas and health has been
steadily marching on and we need to
incorporate it into Health Care
standards in the greater Merrimack area
we have seven towns with nhdes
identified long-term pfas exposure to
thousands of residents
many residents in my town have contacted
me with their cancer stories according
to a state analysis of cancer rates we
have high rates of breast cancer ovarian
and prostate cancer in this area
I have been told of young women in our
town who have been diagnosed with
ovarian failure they will not be able to
have their own children
we also have a lot of cardiac conditions
in our town many heart attacks stents
diagnosed irregularities of electrical
activity and cardiomyopathy
my husband who also has elevated levels
of pfas in his body had a quadruple
bypass at the age of 55.
we are also seeing high levels of
autoimmune disorders reproductive Health
irregularities and learning disabilities
we now know that women who ingest pfas
contaminated water at the levels we are
seeing in our town are giving birth to
children with autistic symptoms and
learning difficult and learning
difficulties
this is all consistent with pfas
exposure research with hundreds of
peer-reviewed studies showing the same
pattern
we now know that pfas is is definitely
linked to several Cancers and we are
learning of new of new connections every
day
pfas chemicals are hormone disruptors
hormonal balance is an important part of
our health it is not surprising that we
are seeing reproductive illness and
Cancers in women we are seeing breast
ovarian fallopian and uterine
dysfunction and and Cancers and Men we
are seeing breast prostate and
testicular cancer
hormones do not just govern reproduction
we are also seeing thyroid issues
alterations in liver function high
cholesterol and high blood sugar as a
result of chronic pfas exposure again
all consistent with the vast body of
knowledge
this bill would require insurance
companies to cover pfas related
illnesses based on both the current and
rapidly evolving CDC
atdat SDR guidelines
and for your information
CDC is obviously Center for Disease
Control atsdr is the agency for toxic
substances and disease registry
you will hear from the insurance
lobbyists that if a doctor orders it
then it will either be approved or the
patient can file an appeal we all know
that's not true my surgery was initially
denied a mammogram for a young woman was
denied a patient should not have to
argue with an insurance company to get
care items such as non-traditional
Health screenings preventive care and a
standard of care based on the health
science related to pfas exposure must be
listed as covered by Insurance in order
for Physicians to apprec appropriately
treat their clients
this bill would eliminate the need for a
stressful and non-guaranteed appeal
process for documented preventive pfest
care
according to the atsdr guidelines a
total pfas blood volume of 20
nanograms per milliliter is what would
trigger the pfas related preventive care
this would mean monitoring infants for
autistic symptoms and learning
disabilities it would mean cholesterol
blood sugar and hormone monitoring if
indicated by exposures above EPA and
State Health advisories starting at
Young ages
it means allowing women to have
preventive mastectomies if they choose
it means allowing women to preventively
remove ovaries Fallopian tubes and their
uterus if they choose
it means monitoring indicators of
reproductive Health in both males and
females starting from when they are
young children it means giving younger
women with high pfest levels access to
mammograms
in the document I sent you by email
there are guidelines for physician
treatment of people who have 20
nanograms per milliliter or higher in
their blood these guidelines will soon
be adopted by the CT CDC atsdr but there
is no federal regulatory requirement for
insurers to provide for pfas related
excuse me pfas related care
this is why the New Hampshire
legislative body previously passed a
requirement for insurers to cover the
costs of pfas blood testing in our state
that was that was two terms ago this
bill builds upon that requirement
the fiscal note suggests that this bill
might raise insurance premiums updating
coverage requirements to cover science
indicated appropriate Health screenings
in areas of known environmental exposure
to toxic chemicals will not only save
lives it will save the progress the
progression of disease and ultimately be
less costly
despite the Decades of pfas-related
science indicating harm to human health
corporations are still allowed to
discharge and emit toxic pfas chemicals
that have contaminated our water sources
air and soil
it is crucial that residents in known
areas of exposure be given the tools we
need to diagnose diseases and illnesses
as early as possible so that we can be
properly treated
this bill asks that our health care
System something we all pay an awful lot
of money into do the right thing and
cover preventive care based on the
atsdr guidelines for this fairly new and
very bad presence in our lives
thank you and I'll take any questions
thank you for your testimony and for
sharing your personal story thank you
any questions representative Speer
thank you for sharing your story
I went on the CDC and I and I went to
the 18 SDR website to look for the
guidance
and in all honesty I couldn't find
anything other than
check with your doctor
so if we're going to be looking at the
atsd guidelines is that in the 300 Page
document that you're providing I I don't
know where that is the 300 Page document
yes that's considered the gold standard
what I sent you and it's called The
Guidance on pfas exposure testing and
clinical follow-up 2022.
excuse me one follow-up
the only other thing that I saw on it
was that they said that getting tested
for pfas levels in your blood is very
difficult and they're not not an easily
accessible test
uh do we even know if we have facilities
here that could do that
uh I'm not sure if we have them in the
state of New Hampshire but Quest lab
does uh test for pfas and it is a a
codable test
um but if you ask your doctor about it
he's not gonna or he or she is not going
to know about it they're not gonna it's
difficult to find the number I've talked
to many doctors that that just don't
even know it first of all they don't
know it exists and secondly they don't
know how to order it
um it might have to be sent out of state
though
thank you
uh yes uh thank you representative
Thomas just a quick question is this uh
Bill unique to New Hampshire or have
other states uh try to pass this time of
Bill this is the first in the nation
thank you
yes representative Burroughs
thank you um this will be uh what do you
do you believe question first of all
thank you for that compelling testimony
and I just uh last session we heard from
representative Wendy Chase who you
probably know who lost her adult
daughter
um related to they believe related to
pfas contamination and she was frankly
disparaged for some of her testimony so
I'm hoping that um this this hearing may
lead to
um action um for people like you because
um I'm sorry for what you had to go
through thank you
um
I have people in my town oh we seem to
have reached a Tipping Point in
Merrimack um the canaries in the coal
mine are the small animals that we have
and our cats and dogs are dying if cats
are left and right I've just put down my
fourth I have the little dogs I've got
the bedroom slipper dogs you know the
little guys I've just put down my fourth
dog who has died of cancer
okay good question oh yep representative
as I am uh growing in my uh awareness of
this uh issue
of this issue I'm wondering if you could
uh and I just uh downloaded an article
from the uh the EPA on uh pfas and just
glanced at it as I was trying to listen
to you more intently of course uh could
you speak to why it is that Merrimack
appears to be a center for uh pfas uh
problems it sounds quite
um uh in quite urgent and quite intense
it is uh urgent and intense those are
good words to explain it we have an
industrial polluter in our town that has
been spewing uh pfas into the water and
the air for decades
um they self-reported in 2016 that that
they were over the the limit
um they recently put and they've lied
they there's a Boston Globe article
about how they they lied about how much
pfas they've put into the into our town
recently they put scrubbers on their
chimneys what they do at night is they
burn their refuse which creates
particulate which then comes down on the
town
and then the rain drives that into our
water system as well as the plants take
it up so our produce is infected and
contaminated with pfas as well
this has been going on for a long time
um
when we first in 2016 when we first
found out about this we were told by the
state of New Hampshire uh Des that only
the people that lived within half a mile
of this industrial complex needed to
worry about their water then they did
some more testing and they said no we
were wrong people that live within a
mile of this industrial complex need to
be concerned I lived three miles from
this Corporation we have a private well
I had my well tested in 2016. the
results were so high we had to shut our
well down
a house without well water as a house
without water so we had to put in a
whole house filtration system at a cost
of about five thousand dollars along
with an RO which is reverse osmosis
system
we only used the RO water for drinking
so I'm one of the three water Warriors
that that came up two terms ago I did
everything right you know I I did
exactly what they told us to do I
filtered our water we stopped you know
everything and I have these kind of
blood blood levels if if I have these
levels what chance do do the rest of the
people in my town have
quick follow really question
so you would say that with with respect
to Merrimack that the the major
contributing contributor to the the
health problems that you are uh speaking
to today uh with respect to uh uh
residents and and pets uh in in
Merrimack uh but is this particular
corporation and its its practices such
that the water is the prime source of of
the uh pollution if you will the water
is is the most significant Source um of
course it goes into the rivers and we've
tested our fish and and the um
suggestion what the it's more than a
suggestion
um don't eat the fish if you catch it
release it because they're so high in
pfest I recently I think it was two days
ago I saw an article by uh CBS news that
said eating one fish that's contaminated
with pfas is equivalent to drinking one
month's worth of water that is
contaminated with pfas so you really
don't want to eat those fish
represent a sphere
a few months ago uh my my sister
received a notice that she's no longer
allowed to drink the water
and that some company is providing
bottled water to their house and they're
told don't drink any water is that and
she lives in Bedford
is that the same company that's
infecting the water in Merrimack it is
it is our family so it's that distance
oh it's it's seven it's seven uh towns
around Merrimack so here's the thing
water flows air flows you know just it's
not going to stay in our town it's
slowly I mean Bedford is slowly seeing
you know more and more health issues
because of this Nashua is going to start
seeing more and more health issues
um these are called Forever chemicals
because we don't have the technology
right now to break them down
they are they will forever be in in our
soil they will forever be in our water
unless we can filter it out they will
forever be in my body
I will die with pfas in my body
yeah representative post
I have a would you believe
in
uh last term we had a waste uh treatment
come in and they were saying they
remediated it using wood chips and they
were taking those wood chips after they
combined them washed them and everything
and they are putting them in playgrounds
I unfortunately would believe that
happens because people are not
well-versed in in how pfas is so
dangerous to I mean that is appalling
that they would put that where children
play it is appalling
okay thank you very much thank you
uh uh chair with Cullen Heidi Kroll from
ahib
it
good afternoon Mr chairman and members
of the committee um for the record my
name is Heidi Kroll I work at Gallagher
Kelly Hannah gartrell and I represent
ahip America's health insurance plans
which is the trade Association for the
health insurance carriers
um
I want to say that we certainly
sympathize with the um
story you know the personal experience
of Representative Thomas and we did chat
with her actually last week I think it
was about this legislation
um
uh we we are opposed to the bill
um I think largely because it's kind of
a mandate before its time
um the federal guidance is uh still you
know kind of catching up to I think
where maybe some of the scientists are
around this
um the
my understanding is that the um guidance
which was referenced
uh was is part of a report from the
national academies and that was
um a report to the CDC and the atsdr
um and but the the CDC and the at
SDR have not adopted any of those
recommendations yet
so if you go on to the
CDC and at SDR websites
um
you'll see first of all from the
patient's perspective
um
what is recommended for the patient so
the CDC website says for example we
don't know if exposure to pfas may cause
health problems in the future you can
talk to your doctor if you have been
exposed to pfas and ask if you need to
be monitored for symptoms or conditions
that may be caused by P P fast exposure
in the future
and then they go on to say some of the
health effects possibly linked to P fast
exposure like high cholesterol can be
checked as part of your annual physical
and it's important to have regular
checkups and screenings and it goes
finally on to say you can talk to your
doctor about any exposure to pfas and
any symptoms you have if you then go to
the clinician guidance and this is in a
document that's a short review and
guidance for clinicians
you'll see that really the guidance is
for patients concerned about exposure
first of all identify and reduce the
current sources of environmental
exposure and then secondly promoting
standard age-appropriate preventative
care measures for General Health and
Wellness
and it goes on to talk about
um
what to do if people have either if you
have asymptomatic individuals or
patients with signs or symptoms of
disease it says treat using the same
established standards of care regardless
of pfas exposure so you know I think
that the carriers are covering if
somebody does have symptoms or
um
the Doctor is recommending screening
um you know in the cases that
any of that is medically necessary the
carriers are are covering it and would
and will cover it
um I think our concern simply as you
heard this this is not adopted in any
other states in the country in terms of
a mandate or or required or mandatory
coverage and
um I think we just really need to wait
for I know it's hard to wait but
um the the guidance is really still very
much in flux in development and kind of
wishy-washy and you know carriers when
they're determining their coverage Look
to You know they have their panel of
experts continually looking at
um where the where the science is going
where the medical care is going and
really make sure that things are
evidence-based so I'm happy to try to
answer any questions
thank you representative Burroughs
thank you and thank you for taking my
question
um the first part is what what would you
believe which we have had evidence from
representative Thomas in the past
representative Chase of anecdotal
evidence of patients who are not getting
care they're being turned away because
of their they're they're not being
covered by insurance and the next if I
could the next part of my question is I
guess is how many cancer patients sick
children and deaths do we have to that
are are found to be related to pfast do
we need to see before we don't feel that
this is a bill before it's time
thank you so in response to your first
question my understanding is that um the
care that representative Thomas received
ultimately was covered covered so
initially my understanding that there
was a coding
um
misunderstanding I guess with how the
provider initially coded the care
um
okay I apologize that was my
understanding that there was Ultimate
that there was at least for part of the
care that there was some sort of coding
problem which ultimately
um you know care was initially denied
um the provider went back and provided
additional information and ultimately it
was covered
um you know I don't have a good I'm not
a scientist I don't have a good answer
for
um you know
the
the body of evidence that needs to to be
brought forth for New Hampshire to have
a mandate but I do know that
um you know the carriers do look toward
um medical necessity and kind of the
body of evidence that is
um pointing in a particular direction
and and again when you go on the CDC
website and the um the I'm going to get
the acronym wrong the at SDR website as
I quoted you know it's
um
I quoted you what's there it's it's
readily available
uh representative below thank you Mr
chair thank you for taking my question
uh in your testimony
um you stated
that
we need to control the source the source
is there
it's not going away so what do you mean
by controlling the source of pfas
I'm
I think I was if I'm remembering
correctly I was quoting
um
this is information off of the short
review and guidance for Collision
clinicians so this is the CDC and the
atsdr guidance and they talk about how
many how many clinicians approach
patient care for pfas exposed
individuals and so the first thing they
say is to identify and reduce current
sources of environmental exposure
so that's I mean I'm just reading what's
on that website just to follow up these
are forever chemicals they will always
be in the water
so what do you have to say about that
well it's real
I understand I I'm not the CDC but you
know I I think the you know you have to
do things like you know try to get a
different source of water as as is
happening in some of these towns as an
example
um I mean my understanding is that you
know to some level Or Another We're All
exposed to pfas obviously there's a
different situation in Merrimack and the
surrounding towns
but I heard it was uh they talk about
the water we're drinking now is the same
it could be dinosaur p
the water the water is all the same
water I'm just saying it's all it's just
water
no it's not about the pfas I'm just
saying that the water the what we have
the water now has not changed the Earth
hasn't gained water or lost water it's
all the same same water if the water is
here forever
I'm exactly I'm reinforcing what you're
saying okay is that it's the water is
there forever
so the pfas once it's in the water is
going to be in the water forever
yeah I'm saying because
the chemical doesn't break down right so
that's all I was saying he said water is
here forever we're stuck with the same
water
okay okay
Representative Vincent that's what they
did in the evil times
and thanks a lot for taking my question
um
and I'm
certainly people oppose bills in a four
pills and I'm not here to beat you up in
any way shape or form
um but do you have an idea when the
insurance company is going to
acknowledge that they're and I stepped
out for a minute maybe this has already
been asked and I apologize but do you
have any idea when the insurance company
is going to acknowledge this problem and
then take it on as an insurance polycarb
coverage
yeah I I think the the really the issue
is that the federal government needs to
make further progress with what it's
what it's publishing what it's posting
what it's giving as recommendations for
patients and for cl for clinicians you
know they're um as I mentioned the
insurance carriers have panels of
um uh professional experts you know
medical experts who are continually
looking at the evolution of
care standards of care and continually
updating their coverage in accordance
with that and so
[Music]
um
I know it's not the answer that people
want to hear but I just think you know
when you go on the CDC website and the
the um the other websites out there even
I looked at the Department of Health and
Human Services here in New Hampshire I
looked at their website they all pretty
much say the same thing and and none of
them are there yet with this level of
these are just recommendations that are
in this report uh to the CDC so
you know I don't have a time I don't I'm
not familiar enough with this issue to
have a timeline for you but
representative thank you thank you
thank you Mr chairman uh it seems maybe
I've got this wrong but you were it
seemed like you waffled back and forth
in your testimony because you started
off saying this is a mandate before it's
time
and then later you said there doesn't
seem to be a problem with people getting
paid for issues getting reimbursed by
insurance but clearly there is a problem
and clearly there is a problem with with
pfas
um so a
I guess which is it we in other words
you're stating that until the CDC
who is questionable with some people as
well uh until the CDC or other agencies
acknowledge that people are dying from
pfas
that's when the insurance industry will
start covering this is that well
paraphrasing you I think the the issue
is that if if people have
symptoms or you know
um
if there's something indicating that
medical testing or medical care is
required then that then that is covered
um and my understanding in the little
bit of reading I did is that you know
for example high cholesterol has there's
a lot of potential sources for that
um and regardless of what the source is
your your doctor will test you and treat
you appropriately so you know again
going back to what's on the CDC website
for asymptomatic individuals exposed to
pfas there is insufficient evidence to
support deviations from established
standards of Medical Care It also says
for patients with signs or symptoms of
disease treat using the same established
standards of care regardless of pfas
exposure and so what I think what I was
trying to convey is that
um
you know those uh standards of care we
do cover
another question you may inquire thank
you
so am I to interpret from that that the
person such as representative Thomas has
to be completely filled with cancer
before the insurance industry will
insure her and and pay for such patients
uh no I don't think that's true I think
her care was covered
um I mean I don't want to speak to her
medical history and record I only know
the little bit that I've heard but you
know my understanding is that
um the care she received was covered
so
um is there a code for pfas now in terms
of medical there is no code per se so is
the problem here is is that if somebody
uh could use the word asymptomatic which
I probably didn't really know what that
word meant until the last couple of
years it turns out that I am one of
those asymptomatic people uh multiple
times so that that uh
so the issue is is somebody wants to get
tested
randomly because they don't have
anything wrong with them they just want
to get a test
where what this bill would say is that
that that test should be paid for is
that correct
so it's already paid for it P fast
testing in your blood right just to get
a test you can get a test now it's
already covered I'm sorry I had to walk
out of the room that is already okay so
that is covered out so I can get that so
now the question is all right if I got
into my body
what we're really waiting for is some
symptoms
because if I don't get a tumor right you
know I get you know if I don't have any
tumors or I don't have any then then how
are we you're asymptomatic so what
there's no real coverage at that point
because there's nothing wrong with you
but then once you get some
cancer diagnosis
whether whatever
at that point we don't really we don't
really care whether it was pfast it
caused it or not at that point we're
trying to cure the cancer
so I don't understand
yeah I'm sorry I walk out of the room
and we'll have to talk later we'll tell
you that but I'm just you know in my my
trying to understand what the purpose of
this legislation is is that is that is
that some some Physicians
using the word pfas in it and then and
that's how it's getting rejected by an
uncovered or what what's going on here
no I I don't no I don't think that's I
don't think that is happening I don't
think Physicians are I
I think of anything the Physicians
there's probably an opportunity for
further education with Physicians
um to uh educate them around you know
the potential for what exposure might
mean for health and and having you know
the monitoring uh
the monitoring happening okay
Mr over here yeah uh to the right to the
right
three in a row on the left over here
okay right field
representative Gibbs
[Laughter]
ladies first
I'll see you later
go ahead thank you
um yes uh you mentioned that the
insurance companies look at the uh
standard for medical necessity
um and also that
um there was a an issue in the denial of
care
um in in one of the cases that was that
was discussed um an issue of a coding
error my question is why isn't it enough
that the doctor makes a determination of
medical necessity
well part of Managed Care in in
healthcare is to kind of have those
checks and balances with the you know
through the insurance company
um that is just how Managed Care works
but part of it is to look out for
patient safety
um part of it is to help try to keep uh
you know premiums down
representative Terry thank you thank you
that's it
so I'm I'm confused again I'm looking at
lines
um
17 and following in the bill proposed
bill
for purposes of this section preventive
p f a s p fast care means medical
treatment provided in accordance with
the CDC and
prevention the agency for toxic
substances and disease regulatory
guidelines for care of an individual
with elevated levels all right so
do these guidelines
actually exist at this time
not that I'm aware of so the bill is
calling for
a requirement with respect to
uh standards that don't even exist yet
and
so therefore the second part of my
question because of your answer can wait
for another time because I was wondering
if in fact the standards do exist then
why wouldn't there already be care
provided why would you be denying care
for for very real uh health conditions
as a result of whatever it doesn't
matter whether they're P fast or or
anything else you're you're going to
cover health conditions unhealthy health
conditions right but you're telling me
right now that there there are no
guidelines for care that exist at this
time as the Bill calls for
so my understanding is that the report
that the national Academy's report
makes recommendations to the CDC and the
atsdr
but those recommendations have not been
vetted or adopted or anything of that
nature the the guidelines or guidance if
you will for both patients and
clinicians that I could find on the CT
cdc's website are what I've referenced
earlier about you know patients and
doctors should have conversations and
make sure that they're trying to reduce
their exposure and
monitoring for symptoms and you know
just doing basic standards of care and
so all of that
it is being covered
okay I think you know regardless of the
source of whether your symptoms are due
to smoking or being overweight or
exposure to something
thank you and I'd just like to point out
to the chair and the remaining members
of the committee that the EPA has some
very very detailed information about a
very aggressive process that has been
put in place and they have a three-year
plan and I would behoove I think all of
us who are very very troubled and very
frustrated by what we're hearing today
and what we heard last year to become
better acquainted with what the
Environmental Protection Agency is is
doing thank you representative spear
the documents or the the things you've
been quoting uh for what the CDC
guidelines were I found exactly the same
thing after looking online for all of
three minutes
representative has told us that she has
a 300 page document that she's given us
and I I didn't know how to look for that
is that all the ensure I'm trying to
form this in a question is that all the
insurance company is going to do is
spend three minutes looking for some
guidelines when in fact there's 300
Pages worth of guidelines really out
there
so again I'm not a medical expert but I
do know that the insurance companies
have panels of
doctors and other experts who are
continuously looking at
medical evidence standards of care and
continually
updating and
updating their coverage accordance you
know in accordance with where the where
everything is pointing to so
um
so so I do think that people not me I'm
I'm
I do government relations I I'm not a
medical medical expert but I I do
believe that the medical experts at the
carrier you're supposed to say I'll get
back to you on that one
okay I'll be back to you on that one
okay representative Herbert
thank you Mr chair
um as a legislator
um and and we have our consumer
protection responsibilities here but uh
as a legislator I tend to want to see
some sort of causal
a relationship between
uh you know more than anecdotal and it
sounds to me as though
there is especially in Merrimack and the
surrounding communities which covers
35 40 000 people that there is a causal
relationship between
illnesses and
um
and and even the corporation itself has
done some things in order to try and
modify uh the impact but as a legislator
to me this is a clear and present danger
and and so as as a somebody just
supposed to be looking out for the
consumer
um
I think it's
far beyond far past time to
put in a mandate actually because that's
it we know we went stop
that's a mandate stop it
so
um
when you're having as an insurer
at what point do you
um determine that uh there's a there's a
a problem
big enough to you have to uh you have to
either ensure or uh
go to brownfields and you know on
bankruptcy so it's this one sounds to me
to be very very dangerous and at at what
point is uh the insurance companies
trigger where's their trigger where they
say oh we have to do something here
because theoretically it's it's part of
your problem that's what you do for a
living
Chris how many mandates how long you've
been on this committee now
15 mandates ago you're right I mean a
lot of the times the mandates you know
we've we've gone through this
conversation about mandates that well it
was about something that was absolutely
diagnosable but we've had plenty that we
had like pandas that we never could
figure out we've we've had ones that are
are head scratchers well we've got
brownfields remember I understand the
1980s and 1970s and I was the Federal
Government had to do it
we can't afford to do it
so representative I believe we can't
afford represent posted you have a
question
um I'm not so sure it's a question but
um more of a statement or I can't figure
out would you believe it would you
believe would you believe the Des
um uh again in research Recreation and
development
um came to talk to us about pfas and all
the different ways that it is entering
into Waters Rivers things like that and
they are identifying these chemicals by
the day
and and I would think that it might be
beneficial to have them at our meeting
because they could probably help us
address those because I know they are
putting them into categories with the
federal government
something to think about
representative
good question about terminology so the
bill
um covers preventative care which I
think could be very frustrating if
you're trying to get it up a test to try
to prevent a problem before the cancer
treatment is covered so I'm trying to
understand and I understand there's the
guidelines are very
um
uh well they're not they're not very
specific so what would you interpret as
preventative care so that young women
that think they have a problem would be
allowed to have a mammogram for example
which I would consider preventative care
right
right so first of all in the Affordable
Care Act in the ACA there
preventative care is kind of a a term of
art if you will so there are things that
are outlined specifically in the
Affordable Care Act in terms of what is
um
preventative care that is covered at no
cost to the patient so there's there's
that type of preventative care
um but again I think that you know
if if a doctor makes a case that
something is medically necessary for a
patient
um then
then I think there's you know
opportunity for coverage there
yeah all right one more
thank you Mr chair
um if this bill passes
how would that affect the insurance
companies in the state
well it's a it's a good question because
I think first of all we're going to have
to figure out what the
what the standards of care are and I
think that's part of what we don't
know yet from the CDC
um maybe you can get it
I I guess I would have to say I I I'm
not sure you're all set thank you Heidi
so Alex do you want to weigh in at all
or you wrote here for for uh for
questions but I I get well the question
I have is what is preventative care the
purpose of the bill is preventative care
then we don't really have I mean you
know in terms like the mandates I mean
the fact that we don't have deductibles
on colonoscopies I guess I don't know if
that was never a mandate but I'm trying
to think I'm going through my mind all
36 mandates that we've seemingly passed
while I've been here and I'm trying to
remember what you know when what do I
compare this to in terms of what what is
it that this bill could do yeah I think
it would be useful if I just quickly
went through the insurance Department's
analysis because we were asked to do the
fiscal note right now okay cool and
overall our impression was that it
wouldn't change coverage very much
um that uh the preventive care for
people who found to have high levels of
pfas in their blood would naturally be
covered under Wellness visits or lab
coverage which is right but part of our
reasoning is that um well in our team at
the insurance department we have our
director of economics who has a PHD in
epidemiology and is very familiar with
CDC and he took just a few minutes to
show me a chart that has very specific
treatment recommendations for people who
were found to have high levels of pfas
in their blood I mean it's very specific
it's if you have greater than 20
nanograms per milliliter of pfas it
recommends
uh screening for dyslipidemia
thyroid function testing
kidney cancer screening
testicular cancer
ulcerative colitis and then it has a
separate set if you have between 2 and
20 nanograms per milliliter so I'm
confused because I thought we you know
found the cdc's guidelines and that they
were very clear and that was our
assumption but from the discussion today
I'm no longer sure
um uh what is the case and if the you
know committee would like I could go
back and consult with our director of
economics and make sure that these are
the CDC guidelines and that you know
because they seem very clear and well
established from what I see and and
theoretically those things would have
been covered yes anyways in a typical
well so this is really I guess it is a
an unusual situation in terms of the
request of what she wanted to have
the procedure and and that in terms of
she was doing it for preventative
and and wants to and and because she had
the high pfas level
if the CDC has these scales and with
what to be tested for it would have to
be on that list right in your mind for
us for it to be covered or not yeah yeah
so okay so we can go back and look if
there's a subcommittee and try to help
you know nail down this issue of you
know whether they're established
okay
thank you
don't forget the children I mean adults
get free that children are born with
high levels okay
so Alex would you take a question
representative amen has a question
thank you for coming back thank you Mr
chair I'm just looking at your fiscal
note could you just explain uh
the on the on the last page of the bill
it says that it would add a health
benefit that's above or in addition to
the essential health benefits offered in
the exchange Marketplace
like could you help me understand that
oh um
yeah let me sort of
um condense what we said in our fiscal
note basically
um we assume that the coverage required
in the bill is likely to be something
that would already be covered
um under the health plans that would be
affected
um and then we
hedged our bet and in the fiscal note
and said if the bill represents an
expansion of coverage then you have the
usual concerns about effect on premium
and the federal defrail considerations
just just a quick follow-up I'm sorry
for the question it sounds like it would
create a sort of an uneven playing field
am I reading this right where the
exchange Marketplace wouldn't have these
requirements but private insurers would
have this have additional requirements
oh I think you're referring to one way
of dealing with the defrail problem
which is if this committee were to
conclude that this you know is mandate
that represents an expansion in coverage
that would have some cost
um
uh
they could pass it but exempt the
individual Market from the mandate
which we've done in the past yeah we
have done that which begs the question
is because this was a new mandate with
Dad then when it comes to the Medicaid
expansion would we then have to pay for
the mandate
the mandates don't apply to Medicaid
Medicaid coverages are dictated by no
excuse me but there was something under
the ACA that any mandates that we passed
was that's the individuals that was the
individual Market yeah that's the
individual I take it back all right that
was the individual market so that's one
of the reasons we don't pass mandates on
the individual Market because we there
is a potential it would it will be a
cost to us if the person is getting
their insurance through the exchange
Bingo okay
thank you very much all right I have one
card left Sabrina you still want to come
up here
okay let's have let's hear Anthem story
oh sorry
old habits are very hard to break
thank you for the chance to speak I'm
Sabrina Dunlap director of government
relations for anthem
so thank you chairman hunt and members
of the committee
um we did meet with rep Thomas last week
and raised some of our concerns with her
and we do have concerns about this bill
not because we don't appreciate the
importance of the issues but because
it's unclear what exactly Insurance
could cover in terms of preventative
pfas care and
um I was talking to our medical director
and he described the science and this as
a moving Target in terms of causation so
he felt this is more of like a public
health monitoring issue because it's
very unclear what is even meant by
preventative pfas care it's undefined
and I know the bill refers to CDC and
astdr guidance and fact sheets but it's
very inconclusive and I won't repeat
what
um Heidi right but one of the guidelines
they say they point to Providers using
their best clinical judgment there's no
Clear Connection where it says there's
pfas in your blood to therefore do X Y
or Z that's our problem with this it's a
practical issue
um and so I think
it's also important to point out there's
a lack of agreement within the medical
community and I think in the example
that rep Thomas used about the woman
with the mammogram I don't know the
details but I do wonder if the doctor
actually said this is not clinically
indicated therefore I'm not going to
order it for you that would not be an
insurance problem so I don't know if
that's the case certainly if a doctor
felt that a mammogram was clinically
indicated it would be it would be
covered doesn't matter if it's cause if
pfas is in the mix or not so I think
that if you were to ask the provider
community in the medical community if
there's agreement on what we even mean
by some of these terms there wouldn't be
agreement
um and so I think you know the bottom
line is there's not an agreement on the
standard of care for pfas and I just
wanted to make that clear because it's
really kind of a practical issue codes
don't exist for this
um so I don't even know how you would
you would put something under pfas
preventative care
okay
all right I think we're all set thank
you very much thank you and we'll see
you on the first
okay we'll close the public hearing
just just let me build
and uh we had one two people for it one
person against it
all right close the public hearing
and get to
the one I thought was gonna be the big
bill for the day
we've had I
Stay With Me Hold My Hand
s
scared of all the big guys in uniforms
huh scary people yeah
did you hear it um
the insurance commission really yeah
which is a big deal he's gonna he said
I've got you
I'm I'm not I'm not supporting a chance
you're joking
see I mean
okay we'll open up the public hearing
and hear from the prime sponsor Anita
Burroughs and Jerry are you
also are you responsible okay
is there any Mark that you were for the
bill but I assumed that okay good
afternoon and sorry we're running so
late today
you ready yep yep
um thank you everyone for hearing us um
I know it's late so I'm only going to
take 45 minutes with my testimony
um actually I'm going to be very brief
because my smarter half hair is gonna
it's gonna take over after I give my
testimony
um this bill would provide for um to
prohibit balance billing for ambulance
services
um the bill provides that patients under
the Managed Care Act under I'm sorry
under managed care plans would require
Insurance insurers to reimburse
ambulance providers directly and not the
patient
the bill as it stands now is a case of
The Haves and the have-nots
ambulance services in urban areas have
high baroleum good commercial coverage
and low Medicaid reimbursement on the
other hand rural areas have low volume
High reimbursement from Medicaid and
Medicare and low commercial coverage or
employer-based insurance plan making it
an economically unsustainable model
many Urban ambulance services are doing
well but many rural ambulance services
are failing
balance billing hurts consumers who may
be hit with a large and unanticipated
Bill for ambulance services the
insurance company may also pay the
consumer for the ambulance services
leaving the ambulance service with debt
that is unable to collect and I think it
might have been in this committee we
heard it an instance of a consumer
getting a um a check
um a good amount for the for the balance
billing and um he knew that he shouldn't
keep it but he said I had to feed my
family so the ambulance service in turn
was unable to collect for that for that
amount
municipalities often bear a significant
portion of the costs of running an
ambulance service through local taxes
this bill is just a start IT addresses a
minority of patients the majority are
covered through large employers who
contract with insurance companies most
residents in the north do not have
access to this type of insurance
coverage because we don't have the large
large companies that we that other
people work for the this will not fix
the entire problem of struggling
ambulance services other work will be
needed to help rural ambulance companies
to become sustainable and to provide
needed Services the insurance company
indicates that this bill would extend
consumer protections of people covered
by a commercial insurance policy covered
by a managed care plan for ambulance
services
Bill also limits reimbursement for
ambulance service to a commercially
reasonable value when a dispute cannot
be made between an ambulance company and
the insurance provider parties may go to
the insurance commissioner for a hearing
to determine if a fee is commercial
reasonable and I'm going to turn this
over to my partner
uh thank you I'm Jerry Stringham I
represent Lincoln and Woodstock in the
North country and for the past 25 years
I've been a consultant in medical
technology with a specialization in
healthcare reimbursement
um uh thank you representative Burroughs
for for bringing this bill back which is
kind of a legacy bill that has been
going on for for several years here the
version that was submitted is as
previously presented there's obviously a
key need for legislation in this area
just by example I recently had a
constituent in Florida who needed an
ambulance ride for a heart emergency
Insurance denied the claim because they
stated they had no contract and she was
left with over a thousand dollar bill
which was
quite significant for her but likewise
an ambulance in our area took an injured
hiker uh 35 miles and what involved a
lot of waiting and were paid just a a
almost insignificant amount uh by an
out-of-state insurer uh with virtually
no repercussions neither these
circumstances is fair and
um uh and we have to do better
ensuring Fair payment for the
life-saving services provided for
patients is critical as well as
preventing any surprise and potentially
financially devastating ambulance bill
it's very laudable goals but since we
filed this bill there's some new
information that I wanted to share with
this committee the federal government
recently enacted the no surprises act
the no surprises act prohibits balance
billing for most Medical Services
however they saw to specifically and
exclude exclude ground ambulances
Services as they're uniquely excluded in
part because of the unusual economics
secondly they formed a special committee
as it was pointed out to me by our chief
of our local ambulance services here
today as
they have just organized in December of
last year and the first meeting was
supposed to be last week but postponed
this is supposed to be looking at issues
of how can they Implement balanced
billing
into Grand ambulances services and still
have a healthy industry
ground ambulance represents one of I
believe 48 Medicare fee schedules uh
there is a this is a third Point there's
a substantial multi-year project
involving surveying all ambulance
providers to try to better understand
their cost
it's widely recognized at the national
level that ambulance services are
underfunded and uh and costs are poorly
understood
fourth as part of the late December
legislation passed in Washington you
know the
what trillion or trillion dollar bill
that came through included a temporary
boost of about 23 percent for ground
ambulance services uh and um was
perceived as critical uh to include this
to preserve uh rural ambulance services
and uh I guess a fifth thing to note is
we did have a commercial uh ambulance
service provider announced that they
would be going out of business in
Manchester in the next few weeks
uh there is a critical need to provide
balance billing protection for patients
perhaps creating a mechanism to
challenge unreasonable fees but just as
critically protect the economics of our
ambulance services
uh the deck is definitely stacked
against them in dealing with insurers in
rural areas like Lincoln where any skier
or hiker or any visitor to our state may
end up in our non-profit ambulance we we
have just one service that requires a 25
mile drive to the nearest hospital
and you know without them uh you know we
don't have it we don't have much of a
town there's no other option so based on
our the current status
of our rural reimbursements I think it
would be critical to
exempt the rural ambulance services like
like Linwood in any such legislation at
this point
you know the
um
uh
you know I I support the direction uh
that this bill is going but I'd also
support uh the formation of a committee
mimicking the National Ground ambulance
committee that I think others here can
talk to better than me
but at the New Hampshire level
uh as our own unique service and
character could be incorporated in such
a review
uh another another option since the
activity is so hard is uh so uh furious
at the national level uh is to consider
to continue to monitor uh and implement
the things that are there
I am concerned that balance billing from
the federal government is coming
uh and uh there's strong motivation
they've done it in most health care
services uh ground ambulances have been
a uh Exempted so far uh by the skin of
the teeth
and I would encourage this committee to
be diligent so uh that uh you know so
that we have the kind of systems that
are he's talked about in this bill to
ensure Fair payments to ambulances so we
can be sure that our 9-1-1 calls are
answered by these able professionals
um thank you
thank you
[Music]
uh I guess we're all set
thank you
I have one more rep mark
who has been waiting a long time sorry
Mark
in opposition to the bill
good afternoon representative Mark Prue
Hillsborough 15 Manchester award eight
I guess the question is when you dial
9-1-1 do you want the ambulance to show
up
right in a timely fashion
so to do that
you have to pay them
right because the day of the volunteer
is gone
right the day of people wanting these
jobs is fading unless you pay them
a lot
right
and in this build I saw a commercial
commercially reasonable
who decides that what credentials do
they have to decide that so I don't know
if you have seen But Maine
just kicked out a report uh in December
on ambulance and billing
and they actually came up with a pretty
good cost and I have a handout boy yeah
and it's only two pages
and it came up with a cost of a call
per call volume
in an area where they were running 300
calls a year
the average call came out to
2522 dollars and six cents
all the way up to for
2100 calls per year to 700
and 9.60
they're
reimbursement was 491
dollars and 99 cents
leaving quite a bit to be
absorbed
where
not sure whether that money is going to
come from to keep that going
but you have insurance companies when
they receive a bill let's say of a
thousand dollars
they arbitrarily decide
well we're only going to pay four
hundred dollars
because we have a formula that says
that's what you should be charging
we've asked for that information what
are you using for a formula and they
refuse to give it to us
so we don't know how they come up with
it magic I guess but I'm not really sure
but
we're only getting a third of the call
and don't have any uh
easy way to fight that
because they have a fleet of lawyers we
don't
um
so
you know I look at
we build them a thousand they pay us 400
my oil company comes gives me a thousand
dollars worth of oil and I only want to
pay them 400 because I think that's
commercially reasonable
can you guess where I'm going
straight to jail right so I'm not really
sure how they get to decide what they
get to pay and I'm sure there's some
loophole for them
but a they really need to pay the bill
and they need to pay it to the ambulance
provider not the patient
because like you heard earlier
we don't get it
in my district we actually have somebody
a couple people that call once a month
to add it to their monthly income
and I'll take questions
we do have a question Representative
Vincent
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question
um being well versed in the medical
field uh I served as a firefighter a
lieutenant out of Somersworth for 33
years and I'm well versed in Medical Aid
in the field itself and I know there's a
lot of variables there not only with
private service that Somersworth holds
but municipality service such as Dover
fire and so forth so uh yeah I have to
agree with you 100 because of the
um complexity of what goes on today so
my question to you is this uh yeah how
can an insurance provider come up with
what you're going to use for services at
a scene of a traumatic incident a motor
vehicle accident that requires oxygen
maybe you had to use a defibrillator and
so forth and so forth how do they come
up with that right representative that
is a very good question
and if you ask those people they won't
tell you
how they come up with how they're going
to pay you thank you very much for that
answer
I have a question representative Exton
so
this is a would you believe with a
question behind it would you believe I'm
a select one
and I represent the town of Troy and
Fitzwilliam here and we recently put our
two ambulance services together because
as somebody said who wants this job
and we're competing with
the county no Cheshire County and they
can't find anybody who wants the job but
the real problem and my question to you
is
we have we the combined tri-fits William
uh Ambulance Service
have gotten our collections all the way
up to 40 percent of Billings which is an
achievement I'm told in this business
and I'm not sure what business in the
planet Works giving 60 percent of your
Revenue stream away but
are you guys getting more than that have
you got some what's your thoughts on I
mean it would seem to be as a business
person I go well okay I know where I'm
going to get the money I'm just going to
collect my money but
there seem to be a lot of people who
feel when they get on the ambulance ride
that somebody else was supposed to pay
for it which ultimately somebody else
does it's the taxpayers right so a
little history about me I did 30 years
in the city of Nashua retired as a
lieutenant I am now a deputy chief in
the town of Epping and our collections
is a little bit higher than that because
we use a really good
private company that collects for us I
can hook you up and uh
but
I I agree with you that
they think their insurance company
should be paying the bill
right and they actually think it's taken
care of hey I submitted the bill to my
insurance company I'm all set and then
we send them a bill and they're like oh
what the heck
and I found out that on some occasions
not all that if that patient calls their
insurance company and says hey
what's going on you're supposed to be
paying this to oh yeah we'll take care
of that now
but they have to kind of rattle their
cage to get anything out of them and not
always
from what I understand
and if they're writing the check to the
patient
we ain't seeing it
a whole nother problem
all right thank you Mark sorry you're
welcome sorry to take so long to get to
you
okay DJ you guys are on
foreign
used to be the deputy and DJ now has his
job so it's great seeing the two of them
together there you get new deputies for
the price of one Mr chairman uh I just
need to have George Russo's get back
again well we started our day with you
and we'll end it here as well thank you
Mr chairman for the record my name is DJ
Bettencourt I serve as the Deputy
Commissioner of the New Hampshire
insurance department I'm joined by my
colleague Alex feldavel and we are here
in support this afternoon of this
legislation which is rare for the
Department to take a position on a piece
of legislation that we did not request
I'm going to try throughout the course
of this testimony to circle around to
some of the questions that have been
answered I think we can help in some
areas
but I'll start by saying that New
Hampshire has a history and a very good
history of addressing balance billing
issues and I think that that is
something that the legislature can be
very very proud of
New Hampshire as I said has been at the
Forefront of protecting consumers
against surprise bills and it started in
2018 when governor sununu and the
legislature and the insurance department
worked together to pass legislation
prohibiting out-of-network
anesthesiologists Pathologists
Radiologists in emergency physicians
from Surprise billing to commercially
insured patients when the care was
provided at an in-network facility now
it's important to understand that that
legislation impacted fully insured
products
but then in
2020 I believe
the federal government came along and
passed the federal no surprises act and
you heard a little bit about that which
extended those protections and ended the
practice of surprise billing in most
other aspects of insurance which
included the self-insured market I think
it's important to appreciate that the
self-insured market represents roughly
two-thirds of how people get their care
not only here in New Hampshire but
across the country
the erises yeah
so between the state law and the federal
no surprises act consumers with either
fully or self-insured health plans have
protection
and that bill at the federal level was
sponsored by Senator Hassan was passed
with bipartisan support in Congress and
was assigned by President Trump so
there's been a a pretty broad bipartisan
support for protecting consumers against
surprise medical bills
there these are obviously great
advancements to protect consumers but
there remains one enormous Gap
and that is in that both the state and
federal law and that is balance billing
for ground ambulance
a review of complaints revealed that two
common scenarios that leave patients in
trouble is first a patient gets into an
ambulance after a 9-1-1 call and second
an ambulance transfers the patient from
hospital to hospital
in both scenarios patients later learn
the fee is much higher because the
ambulance was out of network and after
the insurer pays what it deems Fair they
get a surprise bill for the remainder
I asked our consumer division to run
some numbers for me
as balance billing protections came
online in both state and federal law
the number of complaints coming into my
department evaporated almost entirely
however during that same period of time
the number of complaints about ambulance
balance billing spiked
the biggest Spike came last year
which fell squarely under the first year
of the no surprises act so when both
those state and federal protections were
in place
one patient got a three thousand dollar
bill for a Four Mile ride
another was charged over eight thousand
dollars for a trip from One hospital
that could handle his case to another
that could
we hear from consumers who tell us that
had they known they essentially had
little to no coverage for ambulance
transportation and would be billed
they would not have bothered to call the
ambulance at all or had someone call an
ambulance for them
and as I've cited these are not small
bills
so this is a pretty scary Prospect when
an individual is experiencing a health
health crisis the last thing we want
them to be worrying about is if they can
pay their ambulance bill
moreover the decision is almost always
out of the hands of the consumer's
control
patients usually choose to go to the
doctor
but they are vulnerable when they call
9-1-1 or get into an ambulance
I think we all understand the process
the dispatcher picks the ambulance crew
which in turn often picks the hospital
moreover many ambulances are not
summoned by the patients instead the
crew arrives at the scene having heard
about an accident from somebody else or
they've heard about an accident on a
scanner or because police or a bystander
called 9-1-1
the core of the problem is that
ambulance and insurance companies often
can't agree on a fair price
so the ambulance service doesn't join
the insurance Network and I'm sure
you're going to hear about that in
subsequent testimony
we acknowledge and appreciate that it is
unrealistic to expect EMTs and
paramedics at the scene of an emergency
to determine whether the company takes a
patient's insurance
we appreciate that the ambulance service
have to charge enough to subsidize the
cost of keeping the crew ready
in the equipment ready for
around-the-clock service even if no
calls come in
the problem is is that we often hear
that sometimes the carriers and the
ambulance service or municipalities do
not even attempt to negotiate a contract
and I want to repeat
is not the expectation that it is fair
for the EMTs to cover the costs on their
own rather it is how do we get the two
parties together to negotiate a fair
rate
but at the end of the day the problem is
is that this current situation leaves
patients Stuck in the Middle with
out-of-net work charges that are not
negotiated
we believe that this legislation would
incentivize
those negotiations to take place or at
the very least remove the consumer from
the dispute and provide the insurance
department with the ability to arbitrate
a commercially reasonable rate I'll
depart for a moment to answer
Representatives Vincent's question from
from previous
so having the insurance commissioner
arbitrate a commercially reasonable rate
is what currently exists in the state
level balance billing provision
to date we have had zero
requests to have the insurance
department arbitrate a commercially
reasonable rate
I would estimate that the very likely
reason why is because it is in neither
party's interest to have someone else
decide what that commercially reasonable
rate is
because that starts to start that begins
to start looking like a fee schedule
which I don't think the insurers want so
they come to the table and they work and
they negotiate with the provider in this
case the EMTs to come up with something
that is commercially reasonable and that
both parties can live with however
if the parties were to choose to go the
route of having the department arbitrate
that we would call both parties in
and we would say explain to us why in
this situation you feel that what you
are looking to provide the provider is
is commercially reasonable and provider
you tell us why what your billing is
what you feel is commercially reasonable
and then everybody has to put their
cards on the table
so again I think for those reasons
there's a fairly strong disincentive for
the two parties not to negotiate with
each other and to resolve the in to
resolve the issue before it ever comes
to us
so whether or not you believe this
legislation is the appropriate way to
address this problem is a policy
decision of course for you to make but
we believe that this is an appropriate
remedy but what we can say is that the
current Dynamic is incredibly unfair to
Consumers and it demands reform thank
you Mr chairman
thank you and Representative Vincent has
a question
thank you very much Mr chairman and
thank you for taking my question and I'm
going to try to find a way to ask a
question out of this and I'm hoping that
the chairman will have a little latitude
with me because on your testimony Sir
with all due respect some of the things
that you had pointed on are archaic
first of all I don't know where you got
the test where you came up with the the
information that ambulances of following
accident scenes that may have happened
maybe in the 70s but that don't happen
anymore
one other thing I like to point out that
you pointed out is you're talking about
an eight thousand dollar trance uh a you
you've taken a trance uh ported a
patient those variables are so widely
spread if you're going from Somersworth
New Hampshire to Mass General and you
have to keep a patient alive and you're
using multiple people in keeping that
patient alive so those would you agree
here's my question would you agree that
those charges would vary from anywhere
between a hundred dollars and you're not
going to get a hundred dollars just so
we both are clear two eight thousand
dollars would you agree with that at all
sure so let me answer your first
question and then I'll take on your
second one all of the examples that I
cited in my testimony came from our
consumer division so those are real life
cases that came to us from residents in
the state I didn't make any of these
things up and I asked our team to pull
them from the last five years so maybe
things have changed dramatically over
the last five years but these are real
stories that came from our consumer
division that's number one number two
and Alex is going to expand on this a
little bit further you all right there
are variables in all of those variables
would factor into what is a commercially
reasonable rate for that particular
transport and so to your point distance
would obviously be one the severity of
the care that the patient needed from
One hospital to another would play into
that and so all of those factors would
come together and would need to be if
they chose for the Department to
arbitrate it those factors would all
come in to how our department looked at
that case and how we ultimately reached
the commercially reasonable rate and let
Alex with all due respect I just didn't
hear that any testimony the first time
no I appreciate that
I would just uh
I would like to mention that the
insurance department
um
did a study using the claims data about
ambulance services a couple of years ago
and there were some you know interesting
findings that came out of that one is
that it's true that roughly uh half of
the services are out of network so you
know that's why we have the problem that
uh balance billing that we have is it's
a very high percentage of services that
are out of network
and uh another interesting finding that
I think explains a little bit of why
this has been the hardest nut to crack
out of all the surprise billing uh
contexts
is that there is a great difference a
significant difference in the um
reimbursement rates and the billing
rates between public uh or Municipal
ambulance services and private and then
private
Equity owned ambulance services so we
found that the private Equity you know
we're the highest and the public uh and
nonprofit were the lowest and there was
a significant difference so
um I'm not surprised to hear that uh
some ambulance services
especially rural ones are struggling to
make ends meet
um
and I also believe that other services
are not and that is you know part of the
issue there's such irrational
variability in the rates
representative incident thank you Mr
chairman so would you agree today that
the Dynamics of our wonderful Medical
Aid Services changed meaning
from covid to now that uh that the rate
of pay has gone up in the incentives
that these people have to receive is
much greater
would you agree with that
that they've changed the rate of pay
yes and and don't get me wrong I'm not
trying to beat your gentleman up here
I'm just trying to I'm just trying to
protect a wonderful service from going
bankrupt thank you
he had never had so much fun since he
was left science and technology and got
on this committee see how this committee
does Everything You Touch everything
here
we certainly we certainly do not want to
see any of these Services go out of
business
and I I'd like to think that this
legislation would help prevent against
that because if you are forcing the two
parties to come together to negotiate a
rate that both parties can live with
then you will avoid the situation where
you send a patient to collections
and ultimately that patient may or may
not ever be able to pay that bill and so
you're left with that bill at the end of
the day when that patient cannot pay it
as opposed to having an agreed upon
contract where you know what the rate is
going to be and you know that the
carrier is going to pay
great thank you gentlemen thank you
Okay so we've gone through all the
people who support the bill now we have
two who are mixed and that would be the
insurance companies and uh so Paula
we'll have you go first and because we
had Heidi go first the last time so this
time
you can take the heat first
good afternoon and members of the
committee Mr chair my name is Paula
Rogers and I'm here on Bob of anthem
and
I come with a lot of
I don't know whether I've absorbed all
of the ins and outs of the challenge is
faced with Contracting with ambulances
how they feel how the plans feel how the
committee policy committee feels but it
is a problem
and this Committee in its
prior makeup has heard about ambulance
since what probably
since you were a commissioner
so you know I wish I had an answer but
all I can say is when I was out in the
hall sort of greeting some of my old
friends who were getting as gray as I am
um I heard that
these ambulance companies aren't
in contract with most of the carriers in
New Hampshire
so we have a serious problem so whatever
causes them to do that
and us to sort of be locked in at
Medicare which I believe is where our
Contracting team starts because the
understanding is Medicare is fair
compensation
and then we go above Medicare now
they're all laughing but Medicare is
Medicare and we all know you generally
don't argue so um I was talking to one
fellow out here who said well today
you're below Medicare anthem
and I said how can that be
and then a few minutes later in a
different conversation he said well
actually anthem's 10 above Medicare on
average so I'm going to have to go back
to Med to Anthem and find out exactly
what we're talking about but I know one
thing we're talking about from anthem's
point of view is there's Anthem New
Hampshire so if you have a contract that
was issued in the state of New Hampshire
Anthem New Hampshire
if you live in New Hampshire but your
employer is in Minnesota
you may have the Blues in Minnesota as
your I'm sure are so it's called a blue
card and the blue card sort of folds
into the contracts that the domestic
company has in a given State and it
creates all sorts of billing problems
and it's often self-funded and we know
now I guess we just heard that
two-thirds of you in the state of New
Hampshire are either in a government
plan self-funded or you know Europe in
employment where you are in a
self-funded company and so that's out of
the realm realm of any domestic
company's interest in Contracting but
it's creating these strange things
because Anthem may be
reimbursing at our rate set sort of what
we think is reasonable in the community
for an out of network coverage
and the company makes the ambulance
service May settle for that but I also
learned that they may get Bill charges
paid by an out of state
blue card company so there's there are
different there are different receipts
depending upon who the insurer is
whether it's self-funded whether it's in
the state of New Hampshire outside of
the State of New Hampshire
what is
absolutely puzzling me is why we cannot
get to good contracts I also heard in
the hall well why don't we have a
network adequacy standard so that any
plan writing New Hampshire in writing in
New Hampshire would have to have
contracted
Network providers we don't have that
commercially reasonable came up with the
Department's presentation about how they
would handle commercially reasonable in
a dispute situation it's already in New
Hampshire law under the prior surprise
billing Provisions that New Hampshire
passed to its good credit which is
mostly for providers you would bump into
in a hospital where you're in network
with the hospital but the
anesthesiologist was out of network and
suddenly you get a surprise Bill the
standard there is commercially
reasonable
if you go to network adequacy and say
okay
Anthem signal Harvard whoever you are
you have to contract and we can't reach
contract and that that is the conundrum
because I'm not entirely sure why
but of course it's all about money and
whether it's whatever it is and laying
off costs to a municipality up north
that is struggling so if you say network
access these standards should be set by
a committee
you're going to run into the same thing
because what's going to happen is we're
probably not going to contract and then
the standard under the network adequacy
law is okay we'll let you continue
Anthem Cigna Harvard to sell insurance
even though you don't have a network
because you weren't able to reach a
commercially reasonable standard we
looked at what you were offering Anthem
we thought it was reasonable but you
can't get contracts that's not your
fault so we would go through this
discussion somewhere and so what I'm
saying is what the heck is the answer
it's late in an afternoon you've heard
six bills before this this is the
naughtiest I mean k-n-o-t-t-y bill in
the afternoon session and I don't know
what the answer is all I can say is when
I see the fellows behind me many of whom
I've seen before I'm happy to see them
we all say hello and we go through the
same protocol
so I hope we could be creative I think
parts of this bill do make some sense
maybe it would create the dynamic that
the two assists Deputy Commissioners
advise I don't really know
but something has to be done one thing I
really supported is and I think I owe it
to representative Weston who retired and
used to be over here her concern concern
was the North Country providers and she
put I don't know whether she did it but
her friends may have helped her do it
put it into the bill that if the
commissioner were going to be disturbed
dealing with a dispute that there could
be some
Edge to a rural community
when you're looking at conversely
reasonable that you would have to take
into consideration the special strains
of that we right now have two major
companies in New Hampshire where they're
major by New Hampshire standards we have
Steward ambulance which you see I see it
in Concord it was up in the Lakes Region
when I first got involved now it's in
Concord and probably goes elsewhere I
think I saw it going down 93 or whatever
and
um AMR
they are very serious
issues they're huge companies I'm well
respected I'm sure they provide great
service but private Equity monies have
now found Ambulance Service those along
with Dermatology are two big investment
opportunities in the medical community
so what I'm saying is you have a
terrible problem I don't know what
you're going to do I think the
Department's bill is reasonable the one
part that Anthem doesn't like about it
they're taking out the option of so we
have a non-contracted provider these
gentlemen behind they don't have an
Anthem contract one complaint this
morning well I don't know what the
co-pay is I don't know what the I don't
know how to figure out what you know
what the consumer has to
I don't because I I said well you don't
have a contract you can't call provider
Solutions you've got a card but how are
you going to get to Anthem well then I
get well Anthem doesn't answer the phone
anyway which could be true on a given
day with given the training issues that
everybody has
and I've lost my train of thought which
is because I'm trying to get a health
ahead of myself you're going to tell us
what part you don't like about this was
given to us what's
15 years ago I don't know 12 years ago
if you don't contract you send the check
Anthem even though you have no contract
you either have to send the check to the
member
or you send it to the provider Anthem
has largely chosen to send it to the
member I think that problem with that is
and I understand that particularly with
the economy the way it is member gets
the check and it evaporates so that's up
to you to decide I'm just telling you
that it takes away other leverage
because it makes it so much easier for
people to stay non-contractable what's
it say in the bill no excuse me what's
it say in the this bill it's taking away
the option of sending it to the member
right okay right cool and that's my
testimony and I you know I I just would
like to see some action on this and I
think it's going to take
maybe no more commissions or study
committees because if you go to them and
the same thing gets said and then people
sort of throw up their hands and they'll
say let's look at it next session is
there something that could be done with
the Emergency Services folks the
insurance department people of Good Will
to sit down and figure something out
that's my testimony
great thank you thank you all right
Heidi
what a day huh don't you just love
Insurance health insurance day
would you love how I schedule these all
together
good afternoon members of the committee
again for the record my name is Heidi
Kroll I work at Gallagher Callahan and
gartrell and I'm here representing ahip
which is America's health insurance
plans the trade Association for the
health insurance carriers
um I don't think I have much more to add
beyond what um Miss Rogers has shared
with you we are in this a hip is in the
same position we support the first part
of the bill in terms of trying to
protect consumers from being balanced
build
um I I get a lot of emails and one came
across my desk the other day and see if
I can if I put it in here or not
um but anyway something you know like uh
over 50 of people get I think balanced
build
um on on ground ambulance so
um
and you know there's an affordability
challenge there for people so we do um
support kind of taking the patient out
of the mix and protecting them
um I agree I've I have not been around
um as long as some people in the room
but I've been around for many sessions
and this is kind of one that keeps
coming back and back and it would be
nice if we could finally find a solution
to it
um we do share the concern about
striking the language in the second part
of the bill
um
about the the checks and really the
issue there is that it's the only piece
of Leverage that carriers even remotely
have to try to get the ambulance
providers to come to the table and try
to negotiate and actually get them in
network because when they are in network
the check does go directly to them and
only to them and so it was meant it was
deliberately it was something that this
committee years ago debated I was around
for that I was in the room at the time
yes and it was a deliberate conscious
decision to try to give some leverage to
encourage the ambulance providers to to
join Networks
so be happy to try to answer any
questions but I know this is going to
subcommittee and it's okay
thank you
uh
I'm interested to to find out why it is
that the insurance companies would
um uh want to be able to send the checks
to the
um uh member and not to the out of
network provider I have some personal
experience with this unfortunately
um having had to write in ambulances in
Concord uh where unless something has
changed in the last couple of years
there has never been a contract between
the Concord ambulance provider and uh
Anthem Blue Cross
uh and
I've been told repeatedly that
um
this is because they couldn't I've been
told repeatedly by Blue Cross that this
was because they could not come to an
agreement
um
our I guess my question is
um are you aware of how much confusion
and complication this
method of handling the problem causes
for the member who is trying to do the
right thing and pay the provider
right so again I do support I support
the goal of the legislation which is to
take the patient out of this the mix and
and uh remove the the confusion and the
burden for them
um I think the reason that the check
would go on a I think it could go to the
patient or the ambulance provider or I
think in some cases it could be
addressed to both but the issue is that
there is no contract between the carrier
and the ambulance provider
but that's there is no relationship
there it the relationship is between the
carrier and the member
so
when when the provider when the
ambulance provider is out right
yeah so I I guess I'll just build on
that for everybody so everybody can
hopefully
uh maybe unbeknownst to you you might
hard to believe but when uh you sign up
with an insurance company
um uh they don't necessarily have
contracts with every hospital
I remember uh it was a couple years ago
that Anthem actually dropped 10
hospitals when it came to uh the
exchange or in the individual Market
when they just did they were not in
network uh and so
you so we don't we always think that
okay but of course my doctor's in the
network well
that's in New Hampshire it's very common
unfortunately
um when it came to ambulances that the
insurance companies never made an offer
that was worth signing a contract for
and it was always too little to it
wasn't wasn't enough
and so the issue was okay well how do we
get them to sign the contract and that's
where we said well you know and and I'll
never forget today when you when we
passed the this bill it was that the
issue was insurance company well if we
don't have a contract with them then how
do we know their address how do we know
where to send the check to
guys okay that that's you know that was
the position and they say yeah so we'll
send it to the person who you know is
the is is the patient
and then you would would be responsible
to forward that check to ambulance
because they didn't have a contract
follow-up inquiry thank you
um and thank you yes um I I do
appreciate that um and I understand
there are complications on the side of
the insurance company as well I guess I
what I have here is now a would you
believe
um which involves my having to have a
long conversation with someone at Blue
Cross uh which ended with my asking her
what she would have done
um if she had waked up at three o'clock
in the morning in excruciating pain
um which turned out to be from a kidney
stone uh and she finally agreed that she
would have done exactly what I did which
was call and call 9-1-1 and get into
whatever ambulance arrived
okay thank you all right so I have a
number of cards from all you gentlemen I
don't know the ladies in the bunch but
um I I sorted them by I'm doing a little
test for myself in New Hampshire so I I
went for whoever was the farthest one
away so so we'll see how well I do here
when I do this uh needless to say we
understand I think the committee gets
what the problem is
um so I'll ask you to be brief please
don't repeat yourselves uh but certainly
you know you could tell a convincing
story to why why
um you don't want to lose the balance
billing so I'll start out with Nathan
Borland because he's in Colebrook and I
gotta figure Nathan is the farthest one
away
thank you sir
thank you commissioner I appreciate the
understanding for the three-hour drive
down this morning
uh I spoke to you the last time that
this bill was up in 2019 I don't know if
you remember me no I remember that I
remember faces I don't remember names
but at that time I identified myself to
you as the elephant in the room because
we are the most rural furthest North
farthest from anywhere service in the
entire state
we cover nine percent of the land mass
of Northern New Hampshire
um so a little bit about our area we
have during the week uh the town of
Pittsburgh has a population of 800
people and on the weekend when the
snow's out we have 10 000 people in town
so we're busy on the weekend and we may
not do much at all during the week
our coverage area
um is a very very depressed economically
area there's very little to draw anybody
in there so we don't have a lot of
resources to draw from at all
um our organization we staff one station
off of Route 3 just north of Colebrook
we cover 57 miles of Route 3 from the
Columbia uh Town line all the way up to
the Canadian border crossing our
response times can be over an hour for a
9-1-1 call just getting there
not to mention than having to treat the
patient and get back to a hospital
um we do have the luxury of air support
occasionally with dart or Life Flight of
Maine if the nine different weather
systems between them and us are all
cooperating so most of the time we're on
our own our next nearest service to back
us up would be Grove to the ambulance
and they're 35 miles south uh we have a
Berlin area there's another paid service
that is an hour away or we have new
party ambulance over in Vermont and
Morgan That's again about an hour
response time to us so we are it this is
all we have we have four trucks that we
staff uh two at 24 hours a day so my
labor costs are about a hundred and
fifty dollars an hour at this point
whether we're on a call or not it's 150
an hour to staff we try to put a
paramedic and an EMT on every single
truck because where we're at
we have to if you're out in the middle
of the woods and you're in a major
snowmobile accident you want the highest
level of care there you possibly can the
days of us just picking you up throwing
in the truck and driving you to the
hospital long gone I've spent 23 years
educating myself to the point where I'm
at now to be able to do this job as has
most of my staff
um
so the problem is we're driving around
in a truck right now that cost us a
hundred and seventy two thousand dollars
in 2017 when we purchased it brand new
it has 250 000 miles on it because of
where we're located and to replace that
truck if I ordered it today I might see
it two years from now and it's going to
cost me 350 000 to replace it sitting in
that truck is a cardiac monitor that I
use on almost every single call to do an
EKG a blood pressure check your oxygen
saturation that monitor is between 35
and 50 000 just for that piece of
equipment
and each truck has one so there's you
know two hundred thousand dollars worth
of equipment sitting inside our million
dollars worth of ambulances our
ventilators run about fifteen thousand a
piece and again Each truck has one
um something as simple as an i o needle
that is used if we can't get IV access
on you because you're in shock and your
vasculature has collapsed we actually
drill a needle into the bone marrow to
be able to get access to get your
medicines and fluids and they cost 150 a
piece
so I don't have all of last year's
numbers because we're in January at this
point so I'm going to use 2021 numbers
to for you guys to understand the
finances that we're dealing with we did
875 911 calls that year and 325 of them
were what we call no transports we go we
evaluate the patient we treat them on
scene if that's what's feasible or they
decide I really don't want to go to the
hospital or it's a fire standby or it's
a cardiac arrest where we work on that
patient for up to 45 minutes spend a lot
of money on equipment and supplies
trying to save their life and if we
can't and we call it we can't bill for
that we don't get paid for that at all
so we've spent five or six hundred
dollars working that cardiac arrest and
we don't get paid for it that's built
into the cost of the 450 9-1-1 calls
that we actually were able to bill for
that year
um or 550 I apologize to supplement we
do inter-facility transports it was
mentioned uh by a few people ahead of me
where we're taking a patient from One
hospital to another uh those are
expensive to address uh why the bill
might be up to eight thousand dollars
for that
with the state of our health care System
right now I used to go to Dartmouth all
of the time now we're going to Hartford
Connecticut Albany New York Bay State
Medical Center in Springfield Mass
Bangor Maine and these are the only beds
available for these patients so we're on
the road the last one I did to Hartford
Connecticut I was on the road 13 hours
when I got back to the station I looked
and mileage wise if I decided no I'm
running away I'd be in Washington DC by
that point we've gone that far half of
my mileage was unloaded in six hours of
my time we didn't have a patient on
board so we weren't paid for that time
we were only paid for the trip down
so you're starting to see why my costs
are as high as they are you know in the
cities and you were you know your city
areas down here where you have AMR or
Concord fire their trucks might be on
the road for half an hour at a time 45
minutes even so they can turn around and
do you know up to two or three calls an
hour we might do one call that takes us
six hours and we so we can send one bill
in the time that other services might be
sending out 20.
so that addresses you know all of the
problems so that you understand why
we're our service is probably one of the
most expensive in the state
we don't want to balance Bill our
patients to be very clear none of us
none of my peers behind me got into this
field to bankrupt people and to get rich
we all got in this field because we want
to help people
absolutely we want to help people I do
not like as the chief of our department
sending that bill to that patient
knowing it's going to be a surprise and
they're not expecting and in fact I
often tell patients when I'm dropping
them off at Dartmouth or wherever I've
brought them when you get the bill call
me and I'll give them my card because I
want to work with these people and
explain to them this is you know I
understand this is a hardship we don't
like to do it but it's necessary right
now with the way the system is set up
it's stacked against us looking back on
2021 numbers we build out 2.4 million in
Billing we received in just about a
million dollars actual cash back out of
the 2.4 that we build out so we're right
around that 40 mark as well and that's
because my hands are tied the insurance
company will not negotiate with us here
it is take it or leave it one of our
local fire chiefs actually just recently
he's also on my board of directors has
given me permission to talk about his
case
he had a medical emergency his bill was
just shy of 2000 I think it was like
eighteen hundred he happens to be an
Anthem subscriber I'm sorry Paula
um Anthem sent him the statement that
hey your explanation of benefits we're
going to pay 813 dollars of this 1800
claim we think that's a commercially
reasonable rate and he's he called them
back and said wait a minute I pay you
guys 14 or 15 000 a year for my health
insurance why are you only paying this
amount and they told him the person he
spoke with on the phone after four hours
of automated operators and trying to
reach somebody they said well you can
appeal it and we might pay more if you
appeal it but if you lose the appeal we
pay zero
finally lastly addressing why we don't
contract with the insurance carriers
there may be in-network ambulances in
this state if there are I don't know
them I don't know who they are nobody
that I know is in network because there
is absolutely no incentive at all to
join that Network my predecessor Bill
Watkins who was Chief from 2014 to 2018
tried to negotiate with Anthem in 2016.
as a commercially acceptable rate after
all of the numbers I've just told you it
cost us to operate they said
672 is a reasonable amount of money
to which Bill said I guess we're not
signing and that's the last time we've
tried to negotiate because they won't
negotiate they treat us with the same
with our call volumes and our expenses
like they'd treat you know Services down
further south that don't have the
response times
I think I've pretty much talked myself
out of everything here so if you have
any questions I'll certainly try to
answer as best I can
I think they get it
okay thank you thank you for your safe
drive home
okay next one is North Woodstock uh
David tauben
good afternoon
thank you for spending all this time and
listening to us I think director Borland
hit pretty much all of it right on the
head so I won't repeat it I'm the chief
of the uh non-profit 9-1-1 service that
covers the town of Woodstock in Lincoln
um we're in a similar situation to Chief
Borland and that our nearest hospitals
are 30 miles away we have no other
choices nothing closer
and we are also at about 40 percent we
have tried to negotiate with the
insurance companies to be in network and
so on and so forth and they essentially
say the same thing take it or leave it
for something that is about roughly a
third of what it actually costs us to
run the service
we have great concerns that we don't we
think that patients should be protected
and the purpose of the bill is is great
however to shift all of the
um authority over to the insurance
commissioner leaves us a little bit of a
problem because as you heard from the
insurance company and as the
representative over here pointed out
they're dealing with information that's
at least 10 years out of date in terms
of what's legal in the state of New
Hampshire he cited several suggestions
that just are not legal we would lose
our licenses if we did what he suggested
so to put all of the authority over on
the insurance commissioner as a sole
arbitrator is not very helpful at all
and it will hurt Emergency Medical
Services that are already struggling we
have a three-town area immediately to
the north of us that as of Tuesday has
no EMS and no ambulance available to us
there's going to be a house of cards
that's Fallen quickly because of the
reimbursement rates which are basically
a quarter of what it's costing us to
provide the services as uh as director
Borland just pointed out
so I you know uh I'm thinking I should
ask this question
um how much does the Two Towns pay
Two Towns do subsidize us a bit for the
911 calls but as Nate just suggested
about half of our 911 calls are no
transports which means they're not
billable in the first place so we will
go to a cardiac arrest call and empty
everything on the ambulance into this
patient in an effort a valiant effort to
save them
um in the crew time and the Personnel
time and all the Expendable equipment
and we cannot bill for that we cannot
collect dissent we have other calls
where we get called to motor vehicle
accidents to check out a patient's
ouches and and and so on and so forth
and find that they are fit to travel by
their own private car
uh to a hospital and they do that and
again our time and effort on that call
is not reimbursed whatsoever and on a
9-1-1 service that's about 50 of our
calls
sorry okay
thank you
I guess we're all set enjoy your drive
home thank you say hi to Bonnie Hymn for
us
okay uh Derek arms I thought it was
Hobart Hubbard Hubert is that where you
are how far away is that
Oh that's oh man
man answer you the bad hand right all
right
you got me on that one I'm actually
representing New London and uh my name
is Derek almond I'm the director of the
New London England okay um I'm not going
to spend a lot of time because
um to both Chief and uh Nate's points um
well covered I will say that um you know
one of the things that I think is a very
real reality that you need to consider
is that someday you dial 9-1-1 you
expect an ambulance to come and it
doesn't show and we are
precipitously near that edge for that
kind of thing happening and it's not
just you know the the money is a lot of
other things you know you heard about
things like supply chain you heard about
you know the distance of travel you know
some of these you know people somebody
said eight thousand dollar transfer you
know yeah that's real but it's not
somebody that's going three miles as the
commissioner said it's somebody that's
going a hundred miles you know New
London to Boston you know it's pretty
easy mileage to figure out you know
somebody's being taken care of on a
ventilator you know in Mass indexing in
New Hampshire that's not just a you know
one person in the back you know transfer
that requires at least three people one
person driving two people in the back
and that's statutory that's not you know
my decision saying oh I'm gonna put two
people back there so you know I again
just there's more eloquent people coming
after me that I have a lot better things
to say please listen to them and I thank
you for your time
oh do I have a question
I have a question
what do you think the answer is
ma'am if you can figure that out you're
a lot smarter than me
honestly it's uh it's very complicated
you know because you do have the rural
you know considerations you have you
know I'm I have Nate sitting behind me I
thought I was Far New London Colebrook
beats me two times three times over
and you know there's you know the when I
first started in this job 30 years ago I
graduated from New Hampshire Tech in
1992 and you know what we could do back
then is we could stick a line in
somebody and shock them and maybe go to
the hospital what you get now in a
paramedic ambulance is the technology
and the skill is amazing and people have
that expectation to show up whether it's
you know in Manchester or Colebrook or
little Springfield you know I saw
Grantham from somebody is on this
committee you know the expectation is
they're getting that level of care that
level of care costs money
yeah exactly
no she's not going to ask a question she
she has a some she needs to tell Jane
something
okay representative Gibbs
um would it be helpful uh if the
insurance companies were required to
send their check to the ambulance
provider rather than to the patient I
think it it's I think that is them just
simply strong arming the ambulance you
know it needs to happen because that is
I'll tell you I worked for a private
Service as a collection manager down in
Massachusetts and they went to steps as
you know to take people to court to lean
houses to you know to go after other you
know Monies
that's the additional steps that we have
to take just to survive you know so that
money would be much better used going
directly to the provider so the answer
is yes it would be helpful
thank you
it was in pillow thank you Mr chair
thank you for taking my question so do
you think there should be a state fund
to help support
uh the ambulance services especially the
northern ones
um
I think that any source of money that
can help
is going to be beneficial
I think that you know the
and I I understand the insurance
company's problem I do I you know but I
wear a paramedic patch and I respond to
emergencies and I know what's needed to
do that call if there's a value to you
know having that resource available and
you think about here in New Hampshire
you know down in Mass down in the uh the
southern side that resource is more
available than say I mean I can't even
imagine cold Works problems you know an
hour response time I was complaining the
other day it took 22 minutes to get
somewhere you know there so any source
of Revenue that can help out these
Services mine included
this would be helpful thanks thank you
representative post thank you Mr
chairman
um and thank you for being here this
late in the day so my question is why
can't the ambulance charge for
everything they're doing with that their
mileage their time their labor their
everything they would use and needs to
be replenished in helping an individual
what why can't you put that forth as a
bill
we can
they they do we do well you don't you
don't think they should change how much
they send the invoice
it could be multi multiple pages
so so the issue is you're not getting
paid because it's going to the customer
that is one of the issues
and what is the issue issue is the
insurance companies reimbursement you
know for it
why aren't they reimbursing them
representative representative prove if I
may just like he's not here but
representative pru made a good point you
know the scale or the um the fee
schedule that is sometimes provided by
insurance companies is not something
that's ever been shared and said you
know let's look at this as a actual this
is what it costs this is what you should
be in reimbursed and negotiated on
there's a schedule somewhere that exists
that is nebulous and has not been
provided some places are contracted
Medicare of course is contracted we get
what we we get
yeah to the end of the day insurance
company is going to send the check that
they think that they've
there's no obligation we don't have a
law that says to the insurance company
they got to pay the rack rate
the full rate
okay
thank you very much all right next is
Nottingham Larry best
good evening
I was gonna say good afternoon but I
guess it is evening uh so thank you Mr
chairman for the record my name is Larry
best I'm representing the New Hampshire
Association of Fire Chiefs as the
president of that Association uh we're
going to kind of tag team it today to
have Chief setar from uh who's also a
member of the association and try and do
this as quickly as possible and
respectful of your time great um so to
just summarize real quickly uh our
colleagues ahead of us made a lot of
good points and stuff but I just want to
talk briefly just about the bill our
association opposes this bill We Believe
uh the bill does not address all the
issues associated with financing of the
provision of ambulance services it's
intended to protect protect the
customers by curbing the practice of
balanced billing
um this would obviously it would help
the customers with out-of-pocket
expenses for individuals however it does
not address how providers of ambulance
services would ensure that we recoup
lost Revenue speaking from the
perspective I forgot to mention I'm also
the fire chief in Salem So speaking from
the municipal ambulance perspective of
such as the local fire department that's
providing the ambulance service we don't
really
we aren't in this to generate a profit
we're in this to as far as the billing
goes it's to try and recoup some of the
costs of providing the services I can
speak for my department in particular as
we don't cover all the costs that it
runs that it takes with the balance
billing and the effect of this and again
I'm going to try and summarize this for
timeliness
um
it helps us offset and if we don't if we
lose that balance billing and we lose
that Revenue then as a municipality the
only place we have to turn is the
taxpayers the local taxpayers kind of
how we view the 911 emergency ambulance
service because that's what we most of
us as Fire Chiefs deal with is the
taxpayer all the taxpayers in a
particular Community pays taxes to have
that ambulance on standby and Associated
Personnel cost
on standby and ready if that ambulance
is needed and once there's an emergency
medical call then the user with the help
of their insurance company pays the cost
of providing that service to them
providing that service to the patient so
again with that as far as the
communities
we provide an opportunity as most
communities provide an opportunity for
an individual to demonstrate a hardship
most communities work with a patient
with payment plans or hardship programs
so we communities work with this and
this is something that we we do on a
regular basis it's also important to
remember that any individual who's
covered by Medicare and Medicaid cannot
receive a balanced bill so that's
important to remember as well that's
just Captain it is what it is and stuff
I talked about the Lost Revenue
um
and again it's just to offset portions
of our costs of operating the ambulance
so
moving forward the New Hampshire
Association of Fire Chiefs we'd prefer
to see legislation that both insures
customers are protected um that but it
also provides more certainty regarding
the reimbursement levels of providing
the ambulance services the bill
obviously curbs the bill seeks to curb
the practice first and of balance
billing and then have the Department of
Insurance develop a report to determine
the impact from our perspective it would
make more sense to finalize the extent
of Actuarial study that's referenced in
the the back of the bill if we can do
that first get the fiscal note first and
then work on it to work on it and stuff
from there decisions about carbon
curbing balance billing would make more
sense if we got to know what the fiscal
impact is and stuff so this legislation
obviously proposes the end ending the
practice without an alternative to
ensure that providers will be
compensated accurately by the carriers
so we've heard how that is handled from
the previous testimony given
further the prospect of appealing
reimbursement amounts from carriers to
the New Hampshire Department of
Insurance just trying to picture how
that would work is it would likely
require many municipalities to devote
more costs to Legal expenses regular
staff to to be able to deal with this so
it's going to put more of a burden on
your local municipalities to do this as
there's appeals and so on it would make
an already administratively challenging
challenging process even more difficult
just kind of wrapping up so last session
the house of Commerce Committee uh had
House Bill 343 relative to billing for
ambulance services they sent it to an
interim Study last fall that committee
voted 15 to 1 to not recommend similar
legislation the committee report
indicated that there would be meetings
with stakeholders prior to
reintroduction of legislation in 2023 if
those meetings occurred we as the New
Hampshire Chiefs we did not participate
we didn't know I don't know if meetings
occurred or not we believe that we're a
key a key stakeholder in these services
that are provided by many of our local
municipalities and fire departments we
would welcome the opportunity to work
with anyone who's interested in this
subject and try and develop a better
solution
um so finally we are concerned that if
that if reasonable rates are not
determined prior to the implementation
of this balanced billing prohibition
um it would have a negative effect on
the entire EMS system and could end up
causing uh the local taxpayer to even
pay more through their Municipal Taxes
to for the ambulances and and funding
and stuff just because a lot of this is
offsetting revenue that we would receive
as a municipality I'd be happy to answer
any questions and I Know Chief cetar
also has a few comments
foreign
thank you Mr chairman my name is Mike
Sita I'm the chief of the Tilton
Northfield fire district one of the
things I talk about is the rural and and
stuff and what I'm doing right now in my
department which is required from every
ground ambulance thing is to fill out
this Medicare ground ambulance data
collection
so over a course of four years every
ground ambulance is going to fill it out
this is the the directions on how to
fill it out and they give you you take
your data from one year and you they
give you five months at the end of that
one year to fill out this form
um it's done on the computer but these
are the direction so I'm in the middle
of that process right now but they may
try to make a distinction this is
certainly big difference between a
Suburban Ambulance Service a rural
Ambulance Service and say up in Coburn
where it would be it's considered a
super rural Ambulance Service and
Medicare is trying to take that into
effect when they're collecting this data
but I think it would be fair if we wait
until all this data is collected and we
have the actual numbers of what it
really costs to run an ambulance service
and all those different categories and
come up with appropriate rates using all
that data before we start limiting
balance billing by the EMS services and
again as Chief best says
I think my department charges a very
fair rate for the services we provide
we do not balance Bill people who live
within the fire district
we only end up balance billing people
who have private insurances that live
outside the fire district and then
usually most of the times the balance
bill is their co-pay or their deductible
so you know they have a contract with
their insurance whichever one they have
at that time that you know they will pay
a co-pay for services or they have a
deductible for services and the
insurance companies the private
insurance companies generally send a
check to the the the
owner of the insurance and and not often
do we get that check and so it's a loss
for us and uh in the end we'll end up
having to write it off at some point and
the cost of that is actually absorbed by
the taxpayers of the five district and
so
I think what was we're looking for
something that that's there
fair for everybody we're not out to
bankrupt anybody I've never taken
anybody to court over an ambulance bill
because most of my ambulance bills you
know the you know 1400 or 1600 dollars
for the level of service that's an ALS
One Rate there's a basic rate ALS one
ALS 2 and special DKR rate those eight
thousand dollar transports those are
Specialty Care rates uh very rarely do I
have one of those in my service
but um we want what's fair we don't want
to be we're not in it for the money we
just want to try and help uh recoup some
of the costs that if for this very very
expensive service
be happy to answer any questions
representative Gibbs thank you Mr
chairman
um you've spoken about the um problems
of Revenue loss um that would be created
by um ending balance billing and
um I thank you for how clearly you've
explained the problem and also I want to
thank
um some of the other uh representatives
of ambulance services
um for how clearly they've explained uh
the revenue problems that affect their
ambulance services uh but you haven't
really addressed the other half of the
requirements of this bill so I'd like to
ask you the same question that I asked
the person who testified just before you
and that is would it help would it help
your members uh if the insurance
companies were required to send their
checks directly to the ambulance
providers rather than to the patient yes
I believe that would help
thank you
okay thank you that was a good move
since you lived so close
have you ever remembered uh
this is this is one of those it's really
all about the money I don't I don't see
that this bill is going to
my question is
I don't think anybody's
making money in the ambulance business
outside of the Metro areas if that
so in our rural towns where there's no
way you're going to make money this is
to not balance bill means how much money
am I going to lose
but my question or or not lose as a town
so my question to you is what percentage
of
ambulance services in the state do you
think or no are actually for profit
versus semi-volunteer for town
the only ones that I know of a prophet
are the private ambulances Services
most ambulance services that I'm aware
of are run by municipalities
um they're certainly not for profit and
then there are certainly a lot of
ambulance services that are um
non-profits they're non-profit as well
Jeffrey Rindge is non-profit yeah
yeah but but I would say that you know
like the big companies like Stuarts or
Ami I certainly think that they would be
for profit
so then the majority
are volunteer or municipal
so all we're really doing is trying to
recoup our costs
that's correct yes otherwise the
taxpayers are gonna have to
pick it up for us there's some Cheshire
county and we're not even going to get
the tracks in our town okay so thank you
very much guys thank you okay so I was
wrong there was a uh uh Nicole you say I
you were
didn't see you there with all those guys
around you
so now we're getting to how far away I
live it's like
and then we have Ed Walker good um thank
you I was going to start my remarks with
good afternoon but I'll start them with
good evening
um so I'm Ed Walker the fire chief and
ambulance service director for the town
of Peterborough I've been active in the
fire and Emergency Medical Services for
over 40 years 14 of which is leading
municipal fire departments with
transport ambulances I'm here to urge
you today to reject House Bill 373 which
seeks to eliminate the ability for
ambulance services in the state of New
Hampshire to build patients for fees or
amounts other than co-payments
deductibles or coinsurance if the
service is covered under the patient's
health insurance plan
China Peterborough ambulance provides
emergency transport service to over 13
000 residents in six communities as well
as emerging and non-emergent transports
out of Monona Community Hospital are
local critical access hospital last year
we transported over 1800 patients from
our 2500 plus calls
during the past decade we have seen the
percentage of original charge paid by
primary Insurance fall from 43 percent
to 33 percent while the cost for
delivery of those Services have
significantly increased
although taxpayers are in our service
communities contribute to the operating
budget we rely heavily on patient
billing Revenue to fund the service with
the above reference decrease in direct
insurance payments it is more important
than ambulance services maintain the
ability to build the user of the service
for the direct cost for those services
one of the challenges we would face
which has been addressed is their
ability to determine what is a managed
care plan
even though the healthcare business
management association the American
Medical Association and most other
professional health care organizations
have jointly pleaded with Congress and
CMS center for Medicare Medicaid
services to mandate insurers disclose
the type of plan of beneficiary is on
a second challenge is the different way
payers adjudicate claims to having
exhausted that process up to and
including mediation before being able to
appeal
some real numbers in 2022 after removing
Medicare Medicaid and federal insurers
the amount collected from patients was
234 159 dollars for our service a
sizable portion of that would have been
at risk had this law been affected our
billing company estimates that loss
would have ranged between 100 and 150
000 or 12 to 18 percent of our
non-taxpayer Revenue
meanwhile the proposed Bill seeks to
circumvent the current federal process
which Chiefs a card spoke to of
obtaining real low cost data from ground
ambulance services this bill as proposed
would only create more confusion in the
industry in the public mindset worse it
benefits the insurance industry while
placing more burden on our local tax
base
everybody would like to limit the impact
of emergency ambulance bills Shifting
the burden from the insurance companies
to the taxpayers should not be the
answer let alone the only answer the
proposed bill is written treats
Municipal ambulance services as villains
after patients money while insurance
companies are awarded for refusing to
acknowledge the true cost of emergency
ambulance care
I'm going to skip over most of my
remarks because most of that's already
been covered and and chief Walker did a
great job addressing most this issue
what I'd like to turn your attention to
though is the back page of the letter
that I provided which shows how we
actually charge out the cost of
providing a 911 ambulance service to the
communities that we serve so again we
serve the towns of Peterborough Dublin
Hancock Temple Francis town and Sharon
what we have at the top left hand corner
there are our costs these are our actual
costs to run the ambulance service in
fiscal year of 2022.
then we have below that the fees that we
we collected uh and this comes from
insurance this comes from self-pay this
comes from Medicaid and Medicare
that leaves us right now with a
shortfall of 486 077 dollars
and you add to that our Capital
Improvement plan costs this is the cost
to replace those four hundred fifty
thousand dollar ambulances the heart
monitors the stretchers and everything
else that we need we have a 10-year plan
but we only put a portion of it into
this contract what you see actually here
is a page out of the contract that we
have with the other towns
then we break that out across all the
towns based on the population of each of
those communities and the actual call
numbers of the communities
and then when you have down at the
bottom there all the way over to the
right the total amount that the
taxpayers of each of those communities
is obligated to pay to have us continue
to provide the service that we're
providing
what we're talking about here really is
increasing that cost of service
dramatically this isn't this wouldn't be
a small increase it would be a big jump
if we take the estimates that Chief
Walker provided you and added that to
what we're already building these towns
so when it comes down to it the property
taxpayers really are already paying the
cost of having the ambulance service
available to respond to the patient when
the patient needs them what we're really
doing when you get down to it is have
asking the patient or their insurance
company to pay the cost of the service
that they're getting itself
towns and cities at the end of the day
if this pass is as written would be
forced to give up deciding what level of
Emergency Care their residents need and
instead have to be asking if the
taxpayers can afford to provide that
emergency care at all
I think that's really these are the
conversations already having I'm you
know as I said Town Administrator for
the town of Peterborough so we're in the
middle of our budget process right now
because we're one of those weird towns
that has a Maytown meeting yeah you're
aware
um so we're in the middle of this right
now and this is a very contentious issue
even though so much of the ambulance
service is funded by what we receive
from the fees that we charge out to the
insurance companies Medicaid and
Medicare there's still a substantial
amount here that we're asking these
towns to cover and these bills
especially you know Peterborough yes
it's a big we pay for most of it most of
that unfunded cost but for the town of
Francis town a town which only has 1600
residents we're asking them to pay
seventy four thousand dollars of
taxpayer funds to support the ambulance
service today without asking them to
cover more of the cost that the
insurance companies are refusing to pay
for the service
as the others have said we're a rural
community not as roles Colebrook but
we're still pretty rural our chief and
his paramedics and EMTs are on the road
for hours at a time bringing folks to
the hospitals where they can get the
care that they that they need the
definitive care that will help them with
whatever their immediate issue is yes
absolutely as I say in this letter I
agree that removing that provision in
the law that's currently written in that
allows the insurance companies to decide
where they want to send the check to
would be great I think that that would
be a vast Improvement it would clear up
an awful lot of confusion I can't tell
you how many patients have been in my
office so confused that they're still
getting a bill and not understanding
what do you mean you you you think I've
been paid no one's paid me I got a
little bit of money for the insurance
company well that was supposed to go
towards the ambulance it and that is
very confusing it's very distressing for
them it's distressing for us too
um because we don't want to to be
putting patients who are already in
difficult situation into an even worse
situation
but at the same time there is a real
cost to the service they've been
provided we work with the um we work
with the patients if they're unable to
pay their bills themselves we do have a
connection with the hospital's Financial
program Financial I'm sorry I'm very
tired now
um we do have a we have a connection
with the hospital and we whatever level
of financial grants they've been
approved for we mirror that with the
ambulance bill so if they've been
granted a 75 or even 100 write-off we
will mirror the same but whatever the
insurance company has given them as a
check that's supposed to go towards the
ambulance bill we're expecting them
unfortunately to pay that to us and that
can get uncomfortable
so if there are any questions so the
balance billing is in the fees so if you
look
you look shortfall
before the show about this this is the
fees is
upwards so I understand but if you did
balance Bill yes I'm sorry yes I just
want to make sure that it's already in
the 622. it's captured in there it's
already captured yep okay
okay
thank you very much thank you so much
I'll have to take this back to our town
and see how we're doing
okay uh Chris dewas from Hollis
good evening good evening I had a lot of
things ready to say but most of them
have already been said and since I my
parking ticket ran out at four I
probably have a parking ticket now so
um but thank you for the opportunity to
testify today about House Bill 373 my
name is Chris dewas I'm a lifelong New
Hampshire resident reside in a town of
Hollis with my wife and family I've been
a nationally registered paramedic for
the last 39 years and uh as my friend
Paula mentioned I didn't have gray hair
back then when I first started but I
sure do now I'm currently employed by
American Medical Response which is the
largest ground and air Medical
Transportation provider in the country
and the largest 911 ambulance provider
in the state of New Hampshire
I want to just set the record straight
if I can first there was a comment that
was made by one of the first speakers
here today that said that an ambulance
service in Manchester was going out of
business
we are the only Ambulance Service in
Manchester we are not going out of
business we have no plans to go out of
business we I I don't know where that
information is we have one in Keene that
might be going out of business okay but
my literally my phone has been blowing
up since that comment was made I've got
over 200 employees who are extremely
concerned now and I will do my best to
address that and that it means that many
people are watching us today uh well you
know it's a texting world so people
people text it
one other point I wanted to make on a
comment that was made by that same
speaker was Congress did reauthorize a
23 temporary boost to the super rural
which really only affects the 45th
parallel in in our state of Medicare
payments
and that's not a new 23 that's an
extension of an existing 23 kicker for
those folks and a much less one for all
other ambulance services that was
something that was industry-wide really
would have decimated ambulance services
across the country and Congress was able
to uh Stave that off for an additional
two years now I I agree with everything
that Chief best and his
colleagues said it makes absolute sense
that we allow the center for Medicare
and Medicaid services to complete their
five-year cost study and that's a
national cost study we're halfway
through it to determine what the actual
cost of ambulance service is in every
state in the country that's an enormous
process to go through
as a part of the no surprises act which
people have mentioned there is also a
federal ambulance balance billing
committee that has been formed and I'm
actually proud to say that senator
suprentice from Lebanon New Hampshire is
on that committee she represents the
insurance Regulators that committee is
tasked with reporting back to Congress
within 180 days of their first meeting
of offering a solution for Congress to
finally settle this on a national level
once and for all what wasn't mentioned
earlier was that air ambulance was also
excluded from the no surprises act yep
but they're only fifty thousand dollars
right
the same process was done with air
ambulance that's currently being done
with ground ambulance and that situation
was solved there are no more surprise
bills for air ambulance a group of
stakeholders met they determined what
the actual costs were they came up with
a methodology that was felt to be fair
to both sides and they implemented it I
have every confidence that that will
happen on a federal level
with ground Ambulance Service as well
you've heard today from all of my
colleagues that this is not a simple fix
by any means one thing I will say
however is that it's pretty clear to me
that the tactic being used currently by
the insurance carriers to send the check
to the patient
isn't helping to get anybody in network
it's been 10 plus years since that
started and as far as I know we are the
only one in network with Anthem I
actually don't remember it that way I
remember it was always sent to the page
that we added May right send it to you
yeah well in New Hampshire we are
anthems Network I'm not aware of anybody
behind me that's in anthem's network and
we do it for a variety of different
reasons we're a national company we work
with Anthem across the company or across
the country so it's a strategic decision
for us what is the name of your company
I'm sorry American Medical Response
you're the AMR okay okay cool
is and I want to respond to as far as
the cities go
um I would argue that we are not as well
funded in the cities because most of our
patients are on Medicaid
and most of the other most part of our
patients are Indigent and have no
insurance at all in fact last year I'm
happy to say that we were able to get
the legislature to increase the Medicaid
rates for ground ambulance in the state
of New Hampshire for the first time
since 2005.
now we're at 50 in this state right now
of what Medicare currently pays
ambulance services our neighboring
states Maine is at 100 percent
um Vermont I believe is at 82 percent
and Massachusetts is at 72 percent so we
have a ways to go if there's a solution
that's immediate that's going to make an
impact on everybody behind me from
for-profits to non-profits it's to raise
the State Medicaid rate for ground
ambulance services to a reasonable level
and that's why hasn't our congressional
district fix this problem that's a state
it's actually a state rate right but
it's state but it's a federal or you say
Medicare or Medicaid Medicaid a Medicaid
yes Medicaid yeah don't forget that
money so I'm hopeful and we've worked
with director Lipman at um uh at
Medicaid and hoping that he's put that
in the budget for this year but that
would be a a very meaningful uh have a
very meaningful impact on on all of the
ambulance services in this state as well
so I oppose the legislation as it
currently is written and I certainly
agree that patients should not be in the
middle of a Health care billing dispute
but as an industry we're seeking a fair
and Equitable solution to this problem
but this as it's written today is not it
great thank you
thank you all right last but not least
only because that guy from Tilton you
know jumped so uh Justin then Ethan from
Stewart's ambulance
scrap most of my speech because we all
want to leave here and I'll try and only
touch on things we haven't discussed
um one to answer your question five
years ago there were about a dozen
private for-profit ambulance services
today I'm aware of three all the other
ones have gone out of business if you
have a Bible for me I'll put my hand on
it we are only cash flow positive
because of taxpayer subsidies as a
company we're the largest rural
Ambulance Service that exists as
everyone has mentioned
um every other state around us is
finding ways to funnel more money to EMS
and this bill would eliminate funds that
are currently going to EMS so anyways
I'm Justin I live in holderness I'm the
chairman of the board and have been for
almost 20 years now at Stewart's I've
also worked extensively with Cheshire
county to help them set up their
ambulance service with delusio
unfortunately going
um bankrupt as I've testified despite
the fact we're not private Equity you're
not bankrupt yet what well the IRS he
said that they were going to pay pay the
bill oh
they took that a hundred thousand
hundred whatever is 100
they said they were going to pay it my
mistake I hadn't seen that so
um hopefully they won't they won't
follow the likes of American and not
America AMR but American and uh Care
Plus and all the other companies that
have gone bankrupt
um
we're not private Equity owned despite a
couple of reference to that we're owned
by a wealthy philanthropist out of
Massachusetts uh he's actually very very
generous uh and one of the things that
we don't do and we have not done for
over a decade is balance build we don't
do it it also means that we're one of
the most expensive ambulance services in
New Hampshire because the way we pay for
not balanced billing patients because we
know patients hate billing is we charge
insurance companies more upfront not
everybody pays it
um and that's really the one thing that
I wanted to touch on with you guys today
uh because it's the challenges that we
live with is just before I left I
grabbed 10 eobs the most recent the
explanations of benefits payments that
we got for ambulance transports every
single one of these it's the exact same
code it's 80427 it is a 9-1-1 call
mileage is excluded from this it's just
you know the first part so it should be
the same for everybody that we treat
um the average on this in the state of
New Hampshire according to new Hampshire
healthcost.nh.gov is a little over
fifteen hundred bucks right
one of the largest insurance companies
in New Hampshire here's 10 bills four of
them they told us the appropriate amount
of money to to get paid averages fifteen
hundred is four hundred and eighty
dollars that's less than Medicare pays
us and by the way Medicare is not
acknowledged as being the right number I
think Congress has all said it's paying
less than what it cost us to run the
service so four times out of ten they
pay us less than Medicare and then we
get one and it's 781 dollars well maybe
they thought it was more expensive zip
code okay maybe there's a little bit of
discrepancy and then we get one they
paid thirty two hundred dollars on again
this is all in the last few weeks in the
state of New Hampshire on the same type
of 9-1-1 call except that thirty two
hundred dollars they paid that check to
the patient all the other ones they gave
to us the next one thirty three hundred
dollars the next one thirty five hundred
dollars the next one thirty six hundred
dollars the next one Thirty seven
hundred dollars the next one thirty six
hundred dollars this is one insurance
company in New Hampshire making payments
in the last two weeks for the exact same
nine one one call by the way every one
of those ones that wasn't 400 bucks they
sent the check to the patient and then
they tell us on average we paid you
fifteen hundred dollars which is the
state average I go no you didn't you
paid us four hundred dollars you paid
the patient I don't know what does that
work out to be twenty thousand dollars
and now we've got to chase the patient
and we'll be lucky if we get a third of
that once the patient is done and and
this is the problem these games we don't
balance Bill the patients so if somebody
gives us 400 bucks okay great we'll bill
you for copana optimal we have to do
that but that's it we don't balance bill
you and say hey your insurance company
paid everyone else at thirty five
hundred dollars so we're going to
balance bill you the difference we don't
and the insurance companies are taking
advantage of this one of you asked
what's the solution again hopefully
somebody's smarter than me he thinks
about this maybe it does and I don't
like regulatory oversight but maybe it
does need some level of regulatory
oversight but my one concerned I spent
20 minutes talking to the insurance
commissioner he seems like a really nice
guy hadn't interacted with him before
but you talk to those folks his deputies
and even to the commissioner they don't
like the insurance companies I can't
tell you how many times I heard the word
usurus used ref you know multiple
references that are things that are flat
out illegal in our industry so if you're
gonna regulate it I think you've got to
do something with Health and Human
Services Commissioner of safety and the
insurance commissioner and you bring
together that voice that says okay wait
a second how in God's name do you say
1911 sandwiches worth 400 and the other
one's worth thirty five hundred dollars
in their three days apart because that's
what we all deal with on a regular basis
so that's it I'll skip the rest of it
because I think it's all been said and
everybody wants to leave so thank you
all for your time today it's sort of
like the lottery you never know what
you're going to get
it's true that's why my colleagues have
to balance bill but
okay I have no more cards uh and I think
we will close the public hearing and I
thank you all for staying and
and uh
thank you all thank you
and this will be on the subcommittee
thank you so much